order a lot
the public order emergency commission is
now in session
went over
good morning bonjour
just a couple of comments before we get
started
um this the rest of this week
uh the witnesses being called are in a
little different situation in the sense
that most if not all do not have a
witness statement that's been filed and
uh
uh in some cases uh commission Council
may not even have uh interviewed them or
interviewed them to any extent so
the estimates of time are there for a
little less certain than they normally
are
so uh I just want to raise if if people
uh some of the parties have put time in
if you like as a
stakeholder in case something came up
you might want to advise a commission
council at the end of the evidence that
you're you there is no need
and those who
have seen something come up that makes
it such that they feel they need more
time
can maybe be given more time so I'm
going to be a little more flexible than
normal
in the circumstances because we don't
really know what's going to come out and
to what degree it will affect one or
other party more than what was expected
so I'm just setting that out
the times are challenging this week they
will be big weeks big days rather so
I will still be somewhat strict about
timelines but flexible if there is
movement available given that some
people I suspect and I don't mean to
uh
suggest anything nefarious but people
may have taken
positions on timing they won't need so
that's just as a as a preliminary and
that would apply I think for the
witnesses for the balance of the week so
with that brief introduction uh have we
got a witness planned uh yes the next
witness is Chris Barber
good morning
um and if I could ask and I realized
there's a fair amount of Interest by
some parties and and maybe some
emotional investment in some of the
testimony but I would ask that we keep
it the way it it normally is in a
courtroom and in a uh in a an inquiry so
that we can keep it going also we don't
we don't have much time uh so with that
go ahead
Mr Barber sorry owner Mr Barber will you
swear on a religious document or do you
wish to affirm I swear on the Bible
please
thank you
okay
for the record please State your full
name and spell it out Christopher Joan
Barber b-a-r-b-e-r
do you swear that the evidence to be
given by you to this commission shall be
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the true self you got I do thank you
thank you
good morning Mr Barber good morning
my name is John Mather I am commission
counsel before I begin my questions I
believe your Council wants to make a
statement
good morning sir for the record Brennan
Miller Council for Freedom Corp as I
believe you already know we've made
invocations under all Evidence Act
Provisions both federally and
provincially as well as section 13 of
the charter that's been done in writing
I'm wondering if I have to do that each
and every time the witness testifies or
if the commission has accepted the
written invocation I've already provided
sir
I think we can deem that the witness has
objected to answers each and every
question and uh that uh on the grounds
of the answers May tend to incriminate
them or may tend to establish liability
in a civil proceeding so I think that's
taken as a given uh and has been filed
in thank you very much sir that's all
that's my statement okay
uh so good morning again Mr Barber um
just so you're aware of that the process
today I'm going to ask you questions for
approximately the next 90 minutes when
I'm complete the parties who have
requested time will have uh time to ask
you some questions uh themselves again
for depending on how things go roughly
90 minutes and uh we will have a final
opportunity to ask you some follow-up
questions if that's proves necessary
okay
um I want to start with some basic
information about yourself so I
understand that you're from Swift
Current Saskatchewan is that correct I
am correct how long have you lived in
Swift Current uh my life 47 years
and I also understand that you operate a
trucking business called CB Trucking
limited do I have that correct that is
correct okay and can you just briefly
describe the nature of that business a
long-haul short haul weehall agriculture
equipment across the Prairies and into
the United States
and what's your role with the business
I'm the business owner
and a driver
and how many other drivers do you have I
employ my son and a couple other lease
operators contract employees
how long have you been in the trucking
business
since I was 18 so it's 28 years roughly
and were you operating CB Trucking in
January 2022 I was yes
as the commission understands that Mr
Barber you are one of the original
organizers of the freedom Convoy that
arrived in Ottawa in January 2022. I
take it you agree with that
and you just have to make sure you speak
audibly when you give your address just
for the the transcript thank you
how did you get involved in the Convoy
I was contacted by Bridget Belton
another social media follower uh via the
app tick tock uh Communications started
from there
speaking about possibly slow rolls uh to
protest the mandates for the border
crossing
coming into effect January 15th for
cross-border travel for commercial
vehicles do you recall When Miss Belton
first contacted you
I believe it was the beginning of
January sometime dates might be fuzzy uh
January 8th January 7th somewhere in
there and did you know Miss Belton
before no what did you come to know
about Miss Belton she's just another
trucker
uh cross-border driver that was facing
her job to be lost on the 15th of
January unless she complied with the
mandates
and what did Miss Belton uh what was she
asking you to do get involved to start
something to try and uh to try and and
speak out against the government going
too far and some of these mandates
and when you say government going too
far on some of these mandates can you
explain at that point in time what
mandates were concerning you the
cross-border travel specifically
and you're talking about the decision of
the federal government to no longer
exempt uh truckers from the requirement
that they'd be vaccinated otherwise they
would have to quarantine yes sir
you mentioned that Miss Belton uh
communicated with you on Tick Tock do I
did I hear that correctly yes perhaps
for the benefit of the commission and
maybe uh people who don't who aren't as
familiar with social media can you
explain what Tick Tock is uh Tick Tock
is an app a social media app
short videos under three minutes
my daughter got me into it about three
four years ago approximately I surpassed
her and followers right away so that
made her quite anxious
and prior to getting involved in Tick
Tock were you using any other social
media yeah I was on Facebook
and you you noted that you attracted a
lot of followers in January 2022 do you
know how many followers you had on tick
tock
prior to the Convoy yes uh I would have
guessed roughly guessed around thirty
thousand maybe thirty thousand and uh
you know in in by the time you know in
in mid-February 2022 which we'll get to
but how did your followers grow at that
point in time quite significantly uh
we're up I I don't know the numbers over
170 000 somewhere in there
so again prior to miss Belton contacting
you can you give us a sense of the sort
of content you were posting on Tick Tock
a lot of trucking videos hauling videos
just I'm a generally a smart guy on on
social media a lot of humor
were you posting at all about uh
covid-19 and public health uh measures
yes how would you describe the nature of
those posts
uh Angry
very angry
why were you angry
the Mendes the provincial mandates the
federal mandates they just keep tossing
more on it seemed like it was
it was just an overreach or or it just
they went too far on on a regular basis
and uh it was very frustrating
how did the
covid-19 Public Health mandates affect
you personally
we lost a lot of drivers
um what freaked I can't handle myself
for my company I share with other fellow
drivers and other company owners
uh we lost the government likes to say
10 of cross-border drivers I didn't see
that I seen it more 35 to 40 percent we
lost a lot of drivers like a tremendous
amount of drivers where Freight was
backed up both sides of the border and
caused some significant trouble when you
say you lost a lot of drivers what about
and I understand when we're talking
about public health restrictions we're
talking at various levels of government
but what what about those restrictions
led to you losing drivers
the the lack of the drivers getting the
vaccination to be able to cross the
border as of the 15th
and when you say as of the 15th you mean
as of the 15th of January 2022 yes sir
okay and so what I understand you to be
saying is that the government's decision
to uh no longer exempt truckers from
vaccination uh from vaccination
requirements that was your concern
projecting forward correct is that fair
yes had you lost drivers prior to that
in relation to covid-19 no
is there any other ways that the that
again doesn't matter the level of
government for the purpose of the
questions any other way that the public
health restrictions relating to kova 19
affected you personally uh personally uh
when the when the covert vaccine
passport came in made things a little
tricky we weren't allowed to enter
restaurants anymore
um it was I trucked throughout the whole
pandemic I never stopped I I was I was
uh
I was eating in my truck I was at a
coffee pot a coffee maker in my truck
the restaurants are closed gas stations
were closed bathrooms were closed
it was really tricky I remember about
two weeks into the pandemic thinking
this isn't worth it and going home and
then the customer demands kept climbing
so I ended up
United States
did you yourself get vaccinated yes sir
why did you make that decision uh I've
spent the better part of 16 years
running my company keeping the big
carriers away from my customer base and
I was at risk of losing all that hard
work
to not being able to cross the border
anymore when you say big carriers it's
my understanding that you CB Trucking
limited as an independent trucking
company is that correct it's a small
company yes can you explain to the
commission and what it means to be an
independent trucker as opposed to a big
carrier uh yeah uh independent carriers
three trucks on my fleet it's it's a lot
harder to run a smaller company like
that compared to the big companies
most of my competition is up around the
200 5 50 to 200 trucks
so uh you indicated in your uh earlier
response that uh your Tick Tock
following grew as you participated in
the freedom Convoy in terms of
discussing the freedom Convoy and
planning the freedom Convoy did you use
any other social media other than Tick
Tock I did Facebook yes any other social
media uh Snapchat
anything else a little bit on Instagram
I'd say but not much
and I've the commission is seen in in
some some of the documents relating to
you that at times you would refer to
yourself as an Internet troll is that is
that accurate unfortunately yes and can
you explain to the commission what it
means to be an Internet troll a
troublemaker online troublemaker
and could you maybe give an example of
of what that means and you know when it
comes to tick tock for instance well on
Tick Tock I deal with trolls on a
regular basis they constantly attack me
uh usually they're faceless
um some of them you can see their
profiles
um I engaged with them like I always
have
life I fight back and forth with them on
a regular basis and I've done that for
many years
When Miss Belton reached out to you and
began discussing the possibility of a
convoy or a slow roll I take it that was
something you were interested in
participating in yes sir and why was
that
to speak my part to do my part to
protest
to try and get the government to start
listening to us
and picking up on that last part what at
the outset what were you hoping to
achieve by participating in the Convoy
uh I primarily wanted the government to
listen to our concerns
anything else no sir
were you politically active before
covid-19 I was not were you an active
member of any political party no sir
one final question about Tick Tock
um we've seen information that suggested
that in January 2022 you had multiple
Tick Tock accounts is that is that
accurate yes why did you have more than
one Tick Tock account uh the Internet
troll that I would like to be would
constantly become banned
for posting inappropriate things or
things that went against Community
standards so your punishment for that
would be seven days
of three to seven days off the the
device so you would log into another
account so so when you were suspended
you would then open another account so
you could continue posting
did you find it hard to
gain the followers you had when you
started with a new account no no I've
always ran a couple different accounts
right now I think I post on three
different accounts
so miss Belton contacts you and you said
you recall was perhaps early in January
2022 and begins asking you about
slow rules and potentially a convoy what
happened next
discussion started we will then move
forward with planning
other people other members other other
teams became involved really fast we
realized that there was there was a lot
of support behind us the more we we got
into the logistics of it all
who were involved in the early
discussions early discussions Bridget
Belton and I uh a male called Dave
steenberg
and with that Bridget introduced me to
people like James belder with Canada
Unity uh Patrick King
online social media guy
and we'll have some questions about them
in a moment but I think what would be
beneficial to the commission is to
understand how uh you know to the extent
you can explain it how you go from Miss
Belton contacting you raising this idea
and then getting to the point where uh
you're you're organizing what what
becomes a large event can you explain
sort of how that progressed it was
completely organic everything just
literally fell right into place it was
I believe it was about two weeks from
the time we started talking about it to
the time we actually left
it was extremely fast
who was organized in in planning the
Convoy all of us there wasn't one
necessarily a leader it was a group of
organizers per se we had people in every
province that stepped up we had helpers
in every Province it was all everyone
just came together
was there people who were more involved
in planning than others yes sir yes and
who was that
or myself tomorrow each
Bridget Belton
James belder and Patrick King
and in those two weeks
how was the Convoy promoted
via social media for the most part
can you provide some more information
Samara leech and I were in contact I
believe the middle of January specific
date maybe around the 13th maybe the
10th Tamara started a Facebook page
and a Twitter account for Freedom Convoy
2022 and uh the word started to spread
from there we kept up on our Tick Tock
videos we all we all did Facebook lives
we all promoted it via our independent
social media apps and we understand that
Miss Leach started the Facebook page as
you indicated around January 13th prior
to that what promotion had been done
about the very little very little had
any promotion been done just little
things on social media just getting the
word out and finding out who was willing
to help and who was coming to the plate
um it's commission's understanding that
you participated in a Facebook live
event on January 13 2022 do you know
what I'm referring to correct yes and uh
on in that Facebook live event
um in attendance where uh yourself James
bouter who you've referenced Miss Belton
who we've spoken about in Pat King and
is that a chord with your recollection
yes sir and there was other individuals
there who were assisting in planning is
that fair I believe so yes and I
understand that that video uh took place
prior to Mrs Miss Leach's involvement is
that correct I Believe Miss Leach was
involved at that point I believe that
she was busy that night and could not
attend that if my memory serves me right
um and have you reviewed that video
prior to your testimony I have yes okay
um and it's a approximately an hour and
a half long and uh subject to any
comments from the parties what I suggest
to do is just read out the document ID
and have it entered without uh showing
the video itself because I would run out
of time if that happened
um so it is uh com
uh five zeros eight two nine
and the commission is also asked a
transcriptionist to prepare a
transcription of that video which I may
ask you about later but again I'm just
going to read out the document ID right
now which is com50838
so Mr Barber I can take you to portions
of the transcript if it will assist but
in reviewing the video it strikes the
commission that at that point in time
um both Mr bowder and Mr King were
active we're already actively involved
in planning roots and promoting uh the
Convoy to the people that they were
already connected with is that a fair
statement correct okay
and do you know how Mr bowder and Mr
King were promoting the Convoy uh can I
add I can add that Canada Union become
became involved and Canada Unity was
actually planning I learned later they
were planning some sort of a road across
Canada to Ottawa for a protests they had
the stops and everything already planned
they had a website ready they had
everything was all in place to my
recollection
so so yes uh the commission's
understanding is a Mr bowder had a
website through Canada unity and on that
website there was already root maps and
stops and locations is that is that your
understanding yes correct and Mr bowder
is expected to testify and we can ask
him more questions about that so I just
want to clarify what you said there was
is it your recollection that that
planning was already in place by the
time you were connected with Mr batter I
believe so yes and do you know how Mr
bowder got connected to you and Miss
Belton I believe through Bridget Belton
um
in the video from January 13 2022 which
I've already referenced
um Mr bowder presented a document that
he referred to as a memorandum of
understanding do you recall that yes
um were you aware of the memorandum of
understanding before January 13 2012 no
sorry and just for the sake of the
transcriptions just if you could wait
till I'm finished my question before I
answer just clean your transcript so
were you aware of that memorandum no it
was not okay um what do you recall Mr
bowder saying about the memorandum of
understanding
I reviewed the the video just a couple
days ago and I remembered again uh he
just I believe he just explained
how the document worked and that it had
already been sent to the government
governor general into the government I
believe
do you recall if at that time and when I
say at that time I mean January 13th if
you had a record if you had an
understanding then what Mr bowder was uh
hoping to do with his memorandum of
understanding I believe I just ignored
it I don't know I wasn't into that that
sort of thing and again we're we expect
to hear from Mr bowder and we'll we'll
hear his evidence on it
um the commission understands that one
of the things that the memorandum of
understanding presented was a notion
that uh in respect of the covid-19 uh
mandates that there were Mr bowder
believed that there was not enough time
for lawsuits to challenge those mandates
and that in fact through a uh a piece of
law called the Helsinki act that uh the
a group of a Citizens committee could
come to an agreement with the senate in
in any mandates they viewed as unlawful
would would stop is that your
understanding of ultimately what the
memorandum of understanding meant not to
my knowledge to this day I still have
yet to read the memorandum understanding
I have no clue what's in the document
and I I will never read it in January
2022 did you have any understanding of
what Mr bowder's goals were with the
Convoy that he had organized
no I did not
um like I said before it was a matter of
of a whole bunch of different groups
coming together at the perfect timing
and having an input into this into the
into the planning of it and everyone had
their peace
and we were so unorganized for the most
part we used whatever we could whatever
means whatever tools we could find
foreign
in the early planning stage what was
Bridget Belton doing
same as myself she was posting Tick Tock
videos and promoting through her
Facebook
and Mr King who was on the January 13th
live stream what was he doing I believe
the same thing Patrick had a quite large
following on social media especially
Facebook
so he promoted and did videos on his
platform
and prior to January 2022 did you know
who Pat King was I did not no and how
were you first introduced to him via the
zoom call on the 13th I believe
and maybe I'll ask this at this point
prior to the the January 13th Facebook
live stream had you participated any
calls or meetings with Mr bowder or Mr
King I don't I don't believe so there
might have been one in there earlier
I don't recall one personally
do you recall how you were introduced to
Mr King
I don't sorry when you when you first
came to understand that Mr King was
promoting the Convoy what did you come
to learn about him
just another helping hand another person
with a large following that could that
would help to Danny did you come to
learn anything about his background
prior to January 2022 uh not until
no
not until probably two days into the
Convoy itself
when you were meeting Mr King and and Mr
bowder and Miss Belton uh
did you ask any of them about their
backgrounds and why they were
participating in the Convoy
I I believe so yes I understand Patrick
King had uh children that were
unvaccinated I believe in Bridget was
the fact that she was going to lose her
job on the 15th of January
foreign
did you have any
did you have any questions yourself
about who am I getting Who Am I who am I
organizing with and and and and who are
these people who are going to assist me
in this
I think I was just so excited and so
overwhelmed right from the day one I
don't think I I really had time
it was a very busy time
foreign
the commission understands that many
people
stated goal in terms of the Convoy was
then coveted 19 mandates is that fair
correct
um were you aware of anyone who
participated in the early organization
who had a different goal than that no
sir
yeah
as the Convoy began traveling to Ottawa
and then after it arrived in Ottawa do
you believe there were people who
participated who wanted something more
than to end kova 19 mandates yes
and can you describe why you the basis
of that belief uh there is there is
different organizations that came and
went
for the most part we stayed as a close
group Tamara and I and myself and
Bridget the core group of actual
truckers stayed together
organizations kind of came in tried to
set set Camp up and and we either found
a way to keep it under control or keep
in the in the it was it was a power
struggle a lot of the time
can you just can you provide some more
details about that power struggle what
organizations what they were trying to
do and what you did in response
well we had a little bit of conflict
between Canada Unity that was one
um
not necessarily conflict but taking back
our freedoms was involved there
um no conflict but the war vets joined
us
they were they were beside us the entire
time we had retired police officers
OPP
so Canada uni that's Mr bowder's
organization is that right correct can
you explain to me what the conflict was
with Canada Unity
power control
simple
what was Canada Unity doing that uh that
you that you didn't agree with
I didn't like the mou I believe even
though I still have yet to read it
so at some point I take it you came to
understand what Canada Unity was trying
to achieve with the mou is that fair I
still believe that they were after the
same things we were I believe it maybe
was more massmantics more coveted
restrictions in general
so you indicated that the conflict with
candidate Unity was about the mou and
I'm just trying to understand what about
the mou had gave rise to conflict
improperly written mou according to the
people I spoke to about it
it wasn't something on our agenda it
wasn't something we were pushing for it
had nothing to do with the reason why we
actually came to Ottawa
who did you speak to about the mou Miss
Leach okay and what did she tell you
about the mou we had the same opinion
but I what did she tell you about what
was in the mou I can't speak for what
Tamara said I'm not sure if she's read
it or not
did you have any concerns that the mou
uh advocated or provided for
um uh
an undemocratic uh change of power in
Canada I I heard rumors about it being
that way I heard rumors on both sides
that it it
could be interpreted that way and then
it couldn't be interpreted that way it
was kind of a mixed did you take any
steps to figure out what exactly Mr
bowder was trying to achieve with the
mou not necessarily we uh we we I
remember calling on Mr bowder and having
him renounce the mou partial of the way
through the Convoy
do you recall roughly when that occurred
I do not and what led you to ultimately
make a phone call to Mr bowder and ask
him to pronounce it I believe it was
Tamara that made the call
um just too much there was too much
highlight in it there was too much
Spotlight in in this document that we we
didn't have anything to do with
and when you say too much highlight and
too much Spotlight is are you talking
about I think you'd characterize as the
rumors that it called for something on
Democratic correct
what happened after to your
understanding Miss Leach called Mr
bowder and asked him to rescind it I
believe it was rescind I believe they
they removed it
did you continue working with Mr bowder
throughout the Convoy James was around
um not necessarily worked with him he
was around we we've seen each other from
time to time
another group you mentioned in terms of
there being and maybe this is one of
your words but I understand a power
struggle is that fair among groups yeah
yeah one with another group you you
mentioned was taking back our freedoms
yes who is taking back our freedoms I
don't know names I know Roy and James
were the ones that came out they uh they
tried to help us out
um create structure and inside the
meetings and and the day-to-day planning
do you know what taking back our
Freedom's goals were with respect to the
Convoy to this day I do not I believe
mandate freedom
of government gone too far and uh I
think you described there was a level of
friction with them is that fair from
times yeah there was yes and uh is there
did you take any steps when you had this
group that there was some friction or
conflict with did you take any steps to
figure out what their goals are what
they were trying to do I believe so yes
and what did you do I wasn't personally
part of those I uh
I found my role outside walking the
streets a lot so the inter meetings I
tended to skip out on quite a bit
and we've spoken already a little bit
about Miss Leach
um who I as I understand it uh your
recollection is that she was likely
involved around the time of the January
13th live stream she just did not
participate did I have that correctly I
believe so how did Miss Leach become
involved in the freedom Convoy a
misleach called me on my cell phone I
believe like I said somewhere before the
10th of January and uh told me she had a
little bit of experience in in the
department of protesting and Convoy she
was part of the 2019 united we were all
tour we needed help and I acknowledged
that
it was just a phone call out of the blue
Tamara got my phone number and uh and
the friendship and
continue do you ever
find out how Miss Leach got your phone
number
she said the name before I don't
remember what the name was she's a
friend of a friend had my contact
and you mentioned that Miss Leach had
participated in the 2019 United We Roll
Convoy correct When Miss Leach phoned
you did you know what that was yes I did
okay and could you explain to the
commission what the 2019 united we will
Convoy was oil and gas I believe they
came from Alberta to Ottawa
protesting pipeline pipeline shutdowns
or pipeline building one of the two and
Miss Leach was your understanding was
involved in that conflict she was
involved with some of the
and did you understand that Mr King was
also involved in that conference yes
afterwards what about Mr bowder
I don't know about James
When Miss Leach called you had you heard
of Tamara leech before
no I had not and what did you come to
know about Miss Leach
she's a she's a mother she's a
grandmother
she's a regular albertan
good-hearted strong person
did you become aware in your early
conversations with Miss Leach that she
had been participated in the wexit
movement in Alberta and been involved in
the Maverick party I believe I really I
was told about that in route to
Ottawa
and does it Miss Lisa told you that or
did someone else tell you yes it was
mostly yes
did you have any concerns that in
participating in the convoys misleach
would be pursuing goals other than Mass
mandates and maybe pursuing political
goals of either the wexit movement or
the Maverick party that was not my
no I didn't they feel that at all is
that something you discussed with Miss
Leach I don't know if I've discussed it
but it wasn't really an issue we never
discussed anything in detail it was it
was noted that she was part of that in
the past
I believe she wasn't I don't think she
was or she is now she was and uh it was
it was never an issue after that
uh we expect that there may be evidence
that
um you know whether it be misleach or
other people who became involved in the
Convoy organization uh that there was an
attempt to use the Convoy as an
opportunity to pursue political goals
that weren't just about ending the kova
19 mandates including political goals
that may exist for within the Maverick
party or within the wexit movement
um is that a concern that you have now
looking back
no it was never brought to my attention
that they were a player in this
situation
um and that wasn't the reason why we
came to Ottawa
I would have thought that and why would
you have thought that that wasn't the
reason why we came to Ottawa we came to
Ottawa for Mass sorry for uh border
mandates
now going to ask you some questions
about
the process of uh having trucks begin in
British Columbia and drive across Canada
and then arrive in Ottawa
um
first question do you have a sense of
how many trucks participated in the
Convoy that you had organized with Mr
bowder Mr King Miss Belton and Miss
Leach
the tricky part was trying to get a
solid number there would be a certain
amount of trucks cars buses campers that
would come into the Convoy for a short
period of time let's say from Regina to
Winnipeg just to take part in the wood
exit off and at that same time more
people would come in from Winnipeg to go
to Kenora I know for a fact some people
left with their children in a semi from
Saskatchewan planning on going to Regina
and went home three weeks later
we arranged anywhere from 500 to 2500
Vehicles is what I was told looking in
the mirrors it was incredible to see the
lights behind you and and the long lines
and watching the videos it was
approximately 25 kilometers long and
sometimes
did you ever expect that level of
participation no not in my wildest
dreams what was your reaction when you
saw the level of participation well
there's a lot of Tears
can you expand on that emotions we were
the things that we've seen out the
windshield of the truck as we crossed
the Prairies and in Ontario overwhelming
support people standing on the side of
the highways people lining over passes
we were often late by or around two
hours we were never really on schedule
and people stood in freaking
temperatures minus 20 to minus 30 just
to get a chance to see us come through
could you explain to the commission
how the Convoy organization was able to
coordinate that movement of trucks to
come to Ottawa how did people know when
they where they were supposed to be
where the Convoy was what was going to
happen to them when they joined the
Convoy
we had code of ethics we had rules to
follow we had speeds to an endure we had
constant communication on VE either VHF
FM radios
or CB radios
a cell phone interaction with other
people too
uh constant communication uh safety was
number one priority when you're leading
that many vehicles uh the
error was what could have been at any
minute so
we managed to successfully make it from
the West to Ottawa without a single
issue to my knowledge
during that travel who who was primarily
responsible for all of that coordination
you're talking about
uh I was at the lead of the pack we had
two escort pilot trucks leading us
Patrick King was in his motor home
halfway back looking after the back
back
um it was just it was constant
communication on the radio constantly
upping our speeds lowering our speeds
trying to keep the Convoy at a steady
Pace together uh if if I was going too
fast
people would start to lag and there
would be a distance
we would have to then slow down and
catch everybody up
was there any point on the journey to
Ottawa where you were concerned that the
Convoy you know might not make it or
something may interfere in in the trucks
arriving
no uh no everything was well
orchestrated uh we had police
communication right from
my my role began from Swift Current to
Medicine Hat Alberta where I picked up
Miss Leach
and joined the West Convoy
and that was where my my part started
um we were in communication with the
first police force would have been
Medicine Hat we were in contact with
Swift Current Regina moosha
all the way across the country for for
police escorts if there was a traffic
light we actually called for
um traffic control at those
intersections so we could proceed
through the intersection safely
right and it's uh the commission's
understanding based on some of the
documents that uh your Council has
produced that uh people were in contact
with the police on a daily basis yes sir
is that accurate yes and were you were
you one of those people I was yes
um
again based on the documents the
commissions received we also understand
that when the Convoy arrived in Ontario
that an opp escort was there to meet the
Convoy is that correct yes you just
provide some more explanation about that
I I don't know his last name his name
was Marty he met us at the West talk
scale which is a scale that borders
Ontario and Manitoba he he met us there
he jumped out in front and ledis I
believe Marty follow our lettuce I
believe to thunder bayish area where
then
he got us into Kenora he led us downtown
Kenora to the Rec Center parking lot
where we were where we staged for the
evening we had
a funny story not a funny story but
coming into headingley Manitoba the 108
communities from around the Winnipeg
area uh came into headingley with food
trailers they had hot food Burgers
everything you could think of RCMP had
called me and said the amount of people
in the headingley area was too great it
was a huge risk to safety to get in and
out of the parking lot for the truck
stop so in this we had to abandon the
plan to stop
um so we carried on around Winnipeg
and three uh hutterite vehicles with
trailers followed us to Kenora
and fed us in the parking lot at the rec
center that night it was cold as can be
and uh and they had the barbecues out
and the slow cookers was quite amazing
so when you get into Ontario
um I I assume the daily contact with the
police continued yes and did that
include daily contact with both the opp
and the Ops or would can you just
explain what Police Services you were
contactless was made with I believe her
name was Isabel from Ops
uh Isabelle was in constant contact with
I believe Chris Guerra with adopted
trucker
and things were planned on our arrival
and were you in contact with Isabelle or
anyone from the Ottawa Police Service I
spoke with Isabelle a few times on the
phone I've met her once on the ground
here I didn't have a lot of logistics
with Isabelle that was already being
looked after
and did you speak with Isabelle prior to
the Convoy's arrival in Ottawa I believe
I did I made contact with Isabel but I'm
not sure exactly when there was a phone
call made to say I'm Chris here's my
contact
when you were speaking with either the
opp or the Ops
um and I'm talking about you personally
what were you telling them about the
convoys plans when they arrived in
Ottawa
exactly what it was we were there to
protest
border mandates and our main priority
was safety and working with law
enforcement whatever it took do you
recall having any discussions with any
police officers about how long the
protest might last
I think the discussion started after the
first weekend with Ops I believe and
we had one uh a couple OPP officers in
constant contact too I know his name was
Andrew
so prior to that prior to that point you
referenced so after the first weekend
did you discuss the potential length of
the protest with any police officials I
believe not at what point did you
realize that the protest may continue
for an extended period of time
I don't know if I ever really thought
much into it everything moved so fast
when we arrived
prior to arriving in Ottawa had you
personally turned your mind to how long
you would stay
well my business would suffer a little
longer I was away from it so
that in the back of my mind I I really
didn't know it was a movement of its own
and it just it continued to grow and you
mentally had to try and keep up with it
I guess
in your discussions with either the opp
or the Ops as the Convoy was approaching
Ottawa did any of the police services
give you uh Direction on where you could
park the trucks once you arrived in
Ottawa interesting story
um all the way to Ottawa my
understanding via people in the Convoy
Canada Unity was that we had two major
staging areas one was Major Hill Park
and the other one was Confederate Park I
believe Confederate and that was to my
acknowledge my understanding that's
where we were allowed to park and and
protest peacefully
is that where you ultimately parked that
was not no and how did where did where I
understand that you parked your truck on
Wellington Street is that fair we had a
police escort uh down Sir Johnny
McDonald off the 417
my understanding I I didn't know this
till afterwards police uh blocked the
Convoy after myself and another tractor
trailer went through uh they they shut
the Convoy down around the warm all the
the war museum on Sir Johnny McDonald
they then LED myself and Tamara and the
pilot trucks
we made it to roughly the Supreme Court
on Wellington and that was as far as we
could go there was a ton of vehicles
that come in the night before apparently
wanting to be there for the for the
arrival so there had already been
tractor trailers lined up in front of
parliament down to approximately the
Supreme Court did that surprise you to
see that there was already large
commercial vehicles
yes and why did that surprise you I was
unaware of it my understanding was we
were going to come in police were going
to ask order straight to the two parks
we would park safely out of the way and
and it would be fine did anyone from any
Police Service ever explain to you what
had changed
I believe not no
I don't know if I ever asked that
question
did anyone else ever explain to you what
had led to the to the part of the the
vehicles being parked in the downtown
core as opposed to in the Parks you into
identified apparently we caught him off
guard over we overwhelmed them um right
off the bat with the trucks coming in
the night before that we were unaware of
our main Convoy
uh as far as I know had nothing to do
with those those prior arrivals so
have you since learned uh who was the
early arrivals
uh they were all they're all
semi-operators I knew a couple from my
home Province they were they were in the
area apparently they weren't part of the
Convoy but they were in the area and
they they took they took part in the in
the protest
so I I asked you this and I think you
have confirmed it but you parked your
vehicle on Wellington Street is that
correct yes
um
after you've parked there at any point
in time up until we'll say February 14th
were you given any indication by any
police services that you shouldn't be
parked on Wellington and you'd need to
move I was not no did that come as a
surprise to you
uh
I don't know if I really had time to
think if it was the surprise it was it
was so fast paced
the commission has heard evidence from
several police Witnesses who have been
asked questions essentially about
whether more could have been done to
limit or control the size and scope of
the protest in Ottawa in the early days
um
I I've heard your answers but I'm just
going to ask you one more time
was the police response to the Convoy
what you were expecting or anticipating
when you arrived
I guess it's a hard question to answer
um I believe they did the best they
could
um the the scope of the amount of
vehicles that came in
um I I don't know how things went so
went so wrong when we first arrived we
were
I they did what they could they did the
best they could we were all
um 90 of the trucks were stuck out on on
Sir Johnny McDonald I believe with
pretty much abandoned nobody knew where
to go nobody had Direction
in retrospect do you think it would have
been better had the trucks parked where
they were initially designated to park
oh absolutely and why is that well if it
was staging areas we were allowed to
take
major Hills Park and and Confederate
Park I understand now that that was
never part of the deal apparently
although I don't know that was all I was
told
and why would have that been better we
would have been off the main streets
occupying or or parking all over the
city was never
part of of why we came
thank you
so I've just been handed a note to
suggest that both you and I are speaking
a little quickly for The Interpreter so
I will try to slow down I apologize
we'll try to slow down so that's okay
we're both to blame so it's okay
um
so I'm now going to ask you and we've
we've already touched on it a little bit
but
um about
what happened with the uh people who
were originally involved in organizing
the Convoy we've spoken about Mr bowder
already but I'm I'm going to now ask you
about Pat king
um and as I understand it that in or
around
uh January 22nd 24th in around that time
period
um you and Miss Leach began having
discussions about concerns relating to
Mr King do you know what I'm talking
about yes okay can you please explain to
me the nature of those discussions and
what the concerns were I believe the
first episode was a CBC article came out
of of some past prior social media posts
that Pat had been a part of and we we
met with Pat
discussed our concerns
I believe we smoothed the waters over
and we carried on at that point
so do you recall what concerns and what
had been reported in that CBC article
that caused you concern I I don't really
I didn't ever read this the article um
there was something about something Pat
said years ago according to Pat Uh the
the article was was edited or what he
said was edited
I can can confirm or or deny that so I'm
going to pull up a document it's
hrf401221 and we'll go to page two and
while this document comes up Mr Barber
this is a document that has been
provided by the Convoy organizers group
um it's a
a timeline of events that has been
provided so this was provided to us from
your prior Council and if we could go to
January 24th at the bottom of page two
um and would it be possible um yeah
thank you Mr Clark
so
uh you can read the uh the entry that
says concerns re Pat King do you see
that yes
so this here says tomorrow and Chris
discuss concerns about Pat king after
viewing a tweet with a video making
reference to bullets
do you see that yes
um do you is is this conversation being
described here the same conversation we
were just talking about I believe so yes
does this refresh your memory at all
about what the concerns were yes okay
can you please explain
uh this the article was was made to
sound like like bullets would be flying
apparently according to Mr King when
when we confronted it on him he'd stated
that the article was was taken out of
contest edited to make him sound like he
was planning violence where I believe is
what he was trying to convey in that
article was was different than was what
was portrayed by the by the media and
the commission has seen reports that at
some point in time Mr King made a
comment along the lines of this this was
going to end in bullets do you know if
that's what was being discussed that was
according to what I was told that was a
quarter there was a previous post two
years prior
something to do with an indigenous
standoff
and
during this conversation we were also
aware that their the media was reporting
on a video that in which Mr King had
made a suggestion that uh that at some
point Justin Trudeau may catch a bullet
one day were you aware I recall
something about that yes do you remember
if that was something you knew about
during this discussion or after this
discussion did you learn more about what
Mr King had posted I believe it would
have been after
foreign
so it says in here in the second
sentence Chris agreed perhaps Pat should
be sent home but there was concern about
the trucks Pat brought with him do you
see that yes
um what was the concern about the trucks
uh possibly division inside the Convoy
Pat brought a certain following
with
um
I don't remember the extent of of
anything after that we discuss sending
him home and obviously he didn't
was the concern that if
Mr King was sent home or asked to not
participate that his supporters would
also stop participating I would have
been
a good guess yes
so if we can continue on the next
sentence that talks about a it says talk
to Pat about the tweet on the roadside
do you see that yes was that uh the
conversation you had already described
to us yes and was it were you a part of
that conversation I believe so yes
um and then it says uh following this a
captain's meeting was held in Kenora and
at the end of the day where everyone
expressed concern about cat Pat King's
involvement
yes thank you
the decision was made that someone would
talk to Pat within the coming days and
request that he not attended Ottawa do
you see that yes okay
um I'm going to ask you a question about
this send these two sentences but before
I do that can you just explain what a
captain's meeting is we had Road
captains involved in in
approximately two Road captains per
province
to organize the trucks those were the
the people that the people from that
Province could go to with concerns or
issues
so we had a number of Road captains
within the within the Convoy
and it sounds in here like after your
initial conversation with Mr King that
concerns continued to be raised by other
members of the organization is that
correct yes okay and
do you know if someone ultimately spoke
with Mr King and asked him not to attend
an Ottawa
possibly I wasn't involved in that
conversation
at any point did you hear from Miss
leecher anyone else about whether that
conversation had occurred not to my
recollection I don't and Mr King
continued on to Ottawa yes he did were
you aware of any resolution having been
reached between the people who had
concerns and Mr King
I believe whatever happened it worked
itself out to the point where Pat stayed
with the Convoy
were you personally concerned about what
Mr King had said previously on social
media
I don't believe it was a concern he
explained to me that it was taken out of
context in an edited to make him sound
worse than it was I took him for his
word on it
so you accepted the explanation at the
time yes do you today still believe that
do you still accept that explanation I
believe Pat had all the right cons or
all the right reasons and and a good
heart
so I'm going to pull up another document
this is a com50902
and while we're waiting for the document
to come up Mr Barber this is a news
article and we can go to page three of
the of the document this is a news
article and uh it reports on text
messages between yourself and Miss Leach
and as I understand it and we will get
to this later when you were arrested the
police sees your phone and you no longer
have access to the messages on your
phone is that yes
and I also understand that we expect to
hear from Miss Leach that she also no
longer has access to her text messages
you don't need to comment on that we can
ask Miss Leach about it
but I'm showing you this news article
and as we go through if there's anything
in the article that you think is not
accurate and I appreciate you don't have
your phone with you anymore you can let
me know okay
so
um
if we go down it says on January 22nd uh
Leach told Barbara they needed to have a
very Frank discussion with King raising
concerns about past allegations with him
despite these concerns leech also said
he was needed by the movement in an
apparent contrast to later statements in
which the Convoy tried to existence
themselves distance itself from King
we need him and I don't care about his
past but it only takes one if she said
we have to control his rhetoric not even
threatening to throw snowballs at
Parliament do you see that yes okay
um do you recall if this is something
that misleached text messaged you
my phone was very busy I'm assuming it's
here so it had to be
no reason to to know say this was not a
message she sent you right
um
When Miss Leach said uh
the the movement needed Mr King do you
know what she meant by that
I can't I I'm not sure
do you agree that the movement needed Mr
King
the the best thing about the movement
was it was inclusive to everyone
regardless of
of any beliefs I guess everyone had a
place everybody had a spot it was just
managing
how
so I take it from your answers and I I
just want to make sure I'm I'm Fair here
is that you from what you had learned
about what Mr King and maybe said in the
past the content of those statements
didn't concern you because of the
explanation Mr King provided is that
fair
I guess Pat and I had a power struggle
between each other that was pretty
evident
great from day one it was just it was a
it was a it was a power struggle back
and forth Over Control
um it wasn't anything that couldn't have
been managed
did you have any concerns separate apart
from your own views about what Mr King
mayermann said do you have any concern
about
the
Public Image of having Mr King
associated with the freedom Convoy
movement
I guess there would have been some
concerns at times I guess the the bad
media
uh posts and releases on a regular basis
definitely caused some concern
and can you just explain what you mean
by did you say the the media yeah and
what was concerning you about the media
they attacked them on a regular basis I
believe
did you think those attacks were Fair
I didn't know I didn't like I said I
didn't know Pat previous to the Convoy I
met him on the 13th for the first time
and and things were so busy after that
it was hard to to keep your head around
all the different moving parts
other than being busy is there any
reason you didn't do more to look into
the people who are associated with your
convoy
my primary goal was to get those trucks
to Ottawa safely so
um phone conversations and that were
were hard to have uh everything that we
did was was Logistics it was it was
myself on the mic
on the CB mic or the FM radio mic all
day long making sure the trucks were
safe I kind of left that up to other
people in the organization
you say this media report says that you
texted to miss Leach I know he's had
issues I've got skeletons in the closet
too do you see that yes do you recall
texting that to miss Leach yes okay what
were the skeletons in your closet well
I've been like I've said before I've
been an Internet troll for many years
at this point in time was there
something in was there was there
anything in particular that concerned
you about what you had done on the
internet
nothing that was related to the Convoy
what about things that were unrelated to
the Convoy yes what concerned you I used
to post nasty
distasteful memes via share memes or or
just posting online in a negative way
and it's the commission's understanding
that some some members of the media
identified certain Facebook posts that
you had made and and had reported on
them or tweeted about them is that
something you were aware of at the time
yep they've been circulated for quite
some time okay and
um these include Facebook posts that
contained racist and anti-muslim
comments is that a fair characterization
yes okay
and I expect you may be asked questions
about those by some of the parties and I
wanted to give you an opportunity now if
you wanted it to speak to some of the
racist or anti-muslim things you posted
well I can honestly say that if anybody
learned anything or grow Gruen more
during the Convoy it was me I uh I was I
was a different person
nine months ago whatever it was 10
months ago
um
coming out here and seeing the amount of
love and the people of all different
colors all different race everything it
was it was such a diverse crowd of
people here there was uh
so there were so many tears there were
so many hugs there was so much laughter
there was so much
it was it changed the person it changed
me
how did you change
uh it just it it humbled me
yes it uh it made me realize that that a
lot of the stuff that I used to post on
the internet before was was very
distasteful and there's a better way to
do it
one of the things that the media
reported on during the Convoy was that
you had a Confederate flag in your shop
in Swift Current do you know what I'm
talking about yes okay
and
um you posted at least one or two tick
tocks addressing that issue do you
recall I did yes and one of those tick
tocks you said that the Confederate flag
was you explained that you would I
believe you purchased it in the United
States do I have that correct yes and
then you described it as a piece of
cloth and get over yourself yes is that
a sentiment you continue to have
I believe there's two different contexts
to look at the the Confederate flag I've
got a good friend that lives outside of
Atlanta Georgia she's an
African-American lady I had an in-depth
conversation with her many times on this
occasion
she's explained it to me quite well she
said the way the the two different
contexts is how you look at the flag
was the area of the General Lee in the
Dukes of Hazzard
via like Kid Rock Lynyrd Skynyrd music
when we grew up in our in our hometown
we had we called it a rebel flag or a
Dixie flag we didn't really call it a
Confederate flag it was on license
plates it was on back windows it was
everywhere and at that time
it was more accepted apparently so in my
travels in the Deep South years ago I'd
come across a flag store I seen the the
Dixie flag there I purchased it I hung
it up on the wall in my shop not
thinking anything of it my my
African-American lady friend in in
Georgia explained to me that if you wore
that flag over your shoulders to a
Confederate Battlefield I would probably
call you a lot of names but she said
being the way you're you're just playing
it now and the fact that you you loved
your childhood watching The Dukes of
Hazzard and seeing that flag on the roof
of the General Lee
it's a different context
do you still have the flag in your shop
what I did with the flags in the shop
was I zip tied them so they were hanging
on the wall of the shop I went up on a
ladder and I zip tied them together
they're still there but they're not
displayed in the correct manner
out of respect for
and when you talk about how you've
changed is that an example of something
you're doing different that would be yes
um we've spoken about uh
uh Mr King a bit once you arrived in
Ottawa did you uh and and
did you continue to work with Mr bowder
in terms of the protest activity that
was going on in Ottawa no I hardly seen
James the time I was here
and uh We've Spoken a bit about Miss
Belton once you arrived in Ottawa what
was Miss belton's role in the in the
Convoy same as myself
um she was more centralized around the
hotel area where we had our daily
meetings
making sure things were looked after my
job
morphed into more of a outside walking
the streets making sure the trucks were
well looked after making sure the
concerns were well working with law
enforcement on a day-to-day basis making
sure that we had emergency lanes open
wherever the trucks were parked we had a
couple different hot spots not hot spots
but places in the city that we had we'd
lost
we couldn't get the emergency lanes open
and they weren't uh Looking Back Now
they weren't the trucks that came with
us
from the West the one issue was Rito and
Sussex we spent many days down trying to
get an emergency Lane open with law
enforcement OPP and Ops and then we're
going to have some questions about
Rideau Sussex in a moment
um we we expect that Miss Belton May
indicate that there's been a falling out
between you and her is that true yes and
what what's the nature of that falling
out just friends of opinions what what
are the different opinions
oh
I don't even
just difference of opinion uh different
direction
I just chose to to stay on a path my
criminal charges have left me to be a
lot more silent I can't
I can't speak with
what I used to be able to speak about
the Convoy
I've had to remain silent so I've uh
instead of fight with anybody there I've
said my piece and went my my different
ways
if we could pull up a video hrf146
and again I'll give you some context
while it comes up so this is one of your
tick tocks uh Mr Barber
and we're going to watch it in its
entirety and then I'll have some
questions flowing from it
hey guys Convoy related issues right now
and I just want to get this out there
this Convoy to Ottawa next week on
Sunday
is a peaceful protest
anybody that joins this protest or this
Convoy from either Coast to Coast
is to adhere to the rules of the Convoy
and I am dead serious if anybody [ __ ]
with them they're out emergency vehicles
have the right-of-way when it when the
lights are flashing we pull over and
they are the utmost attention law
enforcement is to be respected never
ever not respected we are working with
law enforcement across the country in
big cities and we have their approval a
hundred percent until we [ __ ] that up
Convoy rules where there's a Code of
Ethics we're going to have to follow we
want this done properly right now the
public is 100 on the truckers and this
mandate removal of mandates side we do
not want to lose that when we start
acting like [ __ ] we lose that let's
keep our eyes on the prize
and hit the federal government where it
hurts we want the mandates gone mandates
need to be removed
and we're not leaving until they are
thanks guys
thank you Mr clerk you can pull that
down so I have a few questions arising
out of that video
um one of the things you say early on is
that you want a peaceful protest and the
commission has seen many instances and
we don't have the time to take you to
the mall of where you insist on the
protest being peaceful and to the extent
there's any sort of suggestion of
violence you immediately step in and say
this needs to be peaceful why was that
important to you we had the public honor
support that was and I apologize for the
for the language there commissioner um
that was another thing that I've worked
on in the last number of months I look
at myself I've heard work so that's good
you can take the trucker out of the
truck but yeah
um that was the utmost importance we had
the world was watching us we we had uh
there were so many people in safety was
utmost and
we were totally by by the lawyers flew
out uh I believe it was the end of the
month the first part of February
something like that and we were told by
the lawyers on the daily basis that we
were we were a legitimate protests we
were allowed to be there we were doing
the right things and the last thing I
wanted to do was wreck that for the
people that we were trying to represent
and there was a ton of support all
across the country all over the world
really and to put that video into a bit
of context you say that this is a
message for the Convoy that's coming
next week so we're arriving and so we
understand that that video was taken
probably sometime in the week of January
23rd does that sound right I believe so
yes so that would have been before you
would the lawyers had gotten involved in
just beginning to get direction from
them is that correct yes so at that
point in time when you're emphasizing
the importance of a peaceful protest
did you have a concern that the people
who were participating in the Convoy
might not be peaceful
I'll give you a little example of truck
drivers
they're like herding cats
they uh you've got every different
style of driver and uh I've always said
you put 200 truck drivers in a room and
somebody's gonna get a black eye and a
broken nose but
and I know I'm not going into it
um I was worried about that because of
the differences opinion with all truck
drivers I can honestly say that that was
something that surprised me there was
none of that the drivers were well
in my what I've seen they were extremely
well behaved they listened to the the
rules of the road I I didn't have a
single incident with with
to my recollection that did went bad so
they listened to the rules of the road I
assumed you mean on the way to Ottawa is
that fair yes once you got into Ottawa
was your observation that the protest
was peaceful
I believe it was loud but it was
peaceful
did you see any acts of violence I did
not no and we'll get to the of the noise
in a moment
um in another Tick Tock video you posted
um and I'm
and this would have been during the
protests in in Ottawa you say that the
last thing we need is a January 6th
style Insurrection and that was one of
your biggest concerns do you recall
saying that yes why was that one of your
biggest concerns
I believe the federal government was
backed into a corner
and
I personally believe that that was the
only way
I guess out of it for them to demonize
us to the point where they could say
Insurrection when that wasn't the case
and so I pushed that message constantly
daily
peace love unity like I said it changed
me as a person listening to myself daily
saying that
when you were saying that was what sort
of activity were you contemplating that
might give rise either correctly or
incorrectly to the impression that this
was going to be some form of
insurrection the police build up
um we had daily uh meetings with police
whether it be OPP or Ops
and everything was positive and and but
it seemed like the police presence built
on a daily basis
um was there anything that other
protesters were doing that were
concerning you and I'm not just talking
about protesters within your group I'm
talking about of all the people who are
in Ottawa
not that I've seen no the trucks that I
looked after on a day-to-day basis were
all
we're excited they were excited we were
two years outside of a of lockdowns
to live again and we've seen that on a
daily basis
so another thing you mentioned in the
video that we showed was that there was
rules of the Convoy you talked about
clearing the way for emergency occults
and that law enforcement need to be
respected was there any other rules of
the Convoy
basically that was it
um
yes there was a code of I I don't
remember if we actually did a code of
conduct up or not or we just mornings we
had tailgate safety meetings with the
drivers to make sure that everything was
well
um there was constant communication with
everything
I had no concerns with the trucks the
trucks were always well behaved and like
I said law enforcement was always open
and honest we did we worked really well
with every law enforcement that I ever
spoke to
but at the same time you recognized that
it was important to have rules and try
as an organizer to at least have try to
have some sort of order over the people
that were in Ottawa is that fair yes
as an organizer did you believe that you
had responsibility for the conduct of
the protesters in Ottawa
I took it upon myself to uh
to to do everything in my power to make
sure that the drivers were were notified
if if things weren't right
I can't say it was my responsibility I I
don't I don't act on behalf of someone
else but I definitely did what I could
to try and and make sure things were
done properly
and what motivated you to do that
just the sheer size of it
um and the support we had support like I
said all over the country all over the
world and uh and there were so many
people watching it was
exciting to see
the general public and one of the
biggest things for me was excited to see
the young kids get back involved with
with trucks that were excited for the
the horn honk the standing on the side
of the highway kids wanted to be truck
drivers again and I haven't seen that
since I was a child
so from what I'm hearing and I want you
to correct me if I'm wrong is that you
you liked what you were seeing you felt
it was positive and you wanted to uh try
to keep that atmosphere because you
wanted to continue the positive
experience is that a fairer sort of
summary perhaps not the most articulate
correct
when you were in Ottawa what were your
views on the police's responsibilities
with respect to peaceful protest
well they they always they seem to
respect
I dealt with quite a few on a daily
basis and I can't
I can't say I had a harsh conversation
or anything with any of them maybe
police were always respectful I would
walk up to random officers standing on
the side of the street and just or
sitting in a police car patrolling a
barricade and say
everything okay have you seen anything
that was a concern and uh
I never once
once got a reaction bad
in the video we showed you mentioned
that the public is on our side and when
we start acting like [ __ ] we lose
that absolutely do you recall that yes
what did it mean to you to be acting
like an [ __ ]
disrespectful
um not not not playing by the code of
conduct or the rules
can you give me an example of something
that you believed was would be
disrespectful
um
being disruptive I guess
um
like I said we tried on a daily basis to
make sure
everybody was looked after
um
so the police had free Lanes through
through all ambulances had free Lanes I
know it was pretty tricky we worked
diligently on it I lost about 20 pounds
in the matter of three weeks with the
amount of walking I did working with law
enforcement I didn't I had a vehicle
here but it was hard to get around to
the vehicle so a lot of times it was
walking and it was frigid it was 20 to
30 below I had two t-shirts on two
hoodies on and long underwear and three
pairs of socks at times
I won't ask you if you put the weight
back on so uh
um I wouldn't want anyone asking me that
question so
um
you say acting like an [ __ ] included
conduct that was uh disrespectful or
disruptive did you see anything that was
disrespectful or disruptive when you
were in Ottawa personally I didn't know
and
and when I say that I appreciate that
not everyone in Ottawa was necessarily
someone who would come with your group
or who might listen to you is that fair
that's fair so we with that in mind at
any point did you see anything in Ottawa
that
you know that might not be the person
who came with you but you wish they
weren't doing it
I never seen like I said I've never seen
anything that really concerned me if
somebody was was there that wasn't part
of the original group that I brought in
um I would try really hard to negotiate
with them or work with them to to open
that lane if they were parked in a spot
that wasn't
where it should have been sometimes it
was successful sometimes it wasn't I I
really struggled a lot with
like I said before when it comes to all
truckers are different that dynamically
played in certain parts of the city
where
what was your view on how the protest
was uh portrayed in the media
it was a negative light right from day
one
they uh they uh yeah
what do you think was being missed
everything
um I had numerous occasions where people
came up to me and said they had to come
down
and see it for themselves because the
media wasn't portraying it properly
and it was a different thing when they
got here
the commission has heard and received
heard evidence and received written
evidence from various residents and
Municipal officials several complaints
about the protesters conduct I expect
you'll be familiar with them but some of
the things that the commission has heard
is that there is excessive noise due to
air horns there was harassment and
intimidating Behavior including people
yelling racist or homophobic slurs and
that there was just a general disorder
and unsafe conditions including open
fires propane tanks near near buildings
and and cars
um is this is this sort of evidence or
or concerns or are you familiar with
that I can honestly say I never
encountered a single episode of that
obviously there was fires where people
trying to stay warm there was there was
propane tanks for for heating things no
different than
I have a propane tank on my my porch
with a with a portable barbecue so
um as long as it was looked after safely
I guess
in your mind who was responsible for
making sure that taking with the propane
tanks or other
or other flammables who was responsible
for making sure the protest was safe and
not that anyone was going to do anything
intentional with a propane tank but
something bad could happen and and and
people could get hurt who was
responsible for avoiding that outcome we
left things up to the road captains like
I said there was usually two Road caps
captains per Province but that morphed
into usually a couple Road captains per
block and we would hold not myself
personally I stayed out of most of those
meetings but the people would hold
meetings every day
um to go over certain things and issues
and safety concerns
they now ask you about the horn honking
the commission has heard evidence and
I'm sure you're aware that at different
times in the protest there was a lot of
horn honking I assume you'll agree with
me about that yes did you consider The
Horde honking to be a form of peaceful
protest
I consider the horn honking to be a form
of excitement
more than peaceful protest I'll be the
first to admit the horns annoyed me I
did everything in my power to try and
get the horns to stop I've put out
multiple videos on a regular basis
saying
stop
especially after the court order came in
on I believe what whatever day that was
the seventh
so let's let's let's pause there for a
moment
the horns bothered you and prior to the
court order which was an injunction to
stop stop the horn honking what steps
did you take to limit the horns prior to
the court order
speaking to the drivers
it was getting everyone orientated
trying to get them situated in a place
where they were safe and their needs
could be met I guess seeing his
our entry was was
so messed up I'll use the words
um
it was it was organized chaos
unorganized chaos there was trucks
everywhere there was Vehicles everywhere
the only thing I could do was put my
videos out stating you know like we're
not here to disrupt residents of Ottawa
they didn't ask for this it was the
federal government is why we came and uh
which is what we could
so I'm going to show you a video and
then a post from your Facebook so we'll
start with the video
this is hrf 192.
and again this is one of your tick tocks
[Music]
to a lawsuit against us for horns
am I doing my part
foreign
five zeros eight eight nine
did you get an idea what kind of guy I
am on social media by that
all that while we pulled up would that
be an example of you being a troll
no that's me being a funny guy
all right so now I'm showing if we could
zoom out so we can see this
and uh we understand this to be a
Facebook post from that you made on
February 12 2022
um
to assist I believe that is the
character Buffalo Bill from the movie
Silence of the Lambs and this is uh a
joke about uh how that if they if the
government doesn't get rid of the
mandates the horns are going to come
back do you see that
yes and then I'm going to show you one
other Facebook post that's uh com5088
and so in this one
this appears that you're sharing on
February 13th a photo I would guess this
would be described as a meme of a a boy
blowing a
bugle or a trumpet being symbolized as
the rest of Canada and then the Ottawa
Ottawa plugging their ears is that fair
yes okay
um and first I'll ask you uh are these
are these two posts that you made on
Facebook it's my name
um like I said things were so busy I I'm
assuming I I shared that one obviously I
would have
probably shared the first one too it was
a scrolling Facebook and seeing it and
just hit the share button that was
probably more like I found it humorous
at the time I guess
so when you look at the video we showed
in these two Facebook posts
could you see why someone would question
your sincerity when you say that you did
everything in your power to stop the
horns absolutely yes and what would you
again you have an opportunity to speak
to that is there anything you'd like to
say
I can't take what I what I posted I
guess it was the excitement of the of
the day on social media flipping through
social media and seeing the post and and
it's a click of a button to share it and
put it out
seeing it now I'd say it's distasteful
we can take that down
briefly I'm going to ask you some
questions about efforts to move trucks
onto Wellington Street and I understand
there was a a few different attempts and
we're going to hear more evidence about
it this week but I have some questions
for you
um
agreement was reached there you were
involved in moving four large trucks up
to Wellington Street is that correct it
was more than four yes sorry I said 40.
yes okay sure sorry
um and prior to that we understand that
the freedom Convoy group had made an
effort to have the trucks and the Rito
and Sussex intersection moved on to
Wellington Street do I have that correct
we made an attempt yes okay and can you
tell me what happened with that an
attempt
I was successful with one truck there
was uh if there's uh there was a load
safe it was a tractor trailer he was
parked
near right by the war memorial I
remember the story on a uh he was parked
sideways across the complete
intersection and law enforcement had
tried to get him to straighten his truck
out for quite some time and failed at it
miserably
um
I remember it was easy I walked over to
the truck I stepped up on the running
board and I said hey buddy you're in the
way really bad and you're causing this
some grief could you just back it up
against the curb please and you'll save
us all a lot of trouble and he literally
put the truck in gear and backed it up
against the the opp and the Ops officers
were amazed it was that easy
was the other were you able to move the
other trucks on Rita was not no those
were uh those were a different group
there it was harder to talk to them and
what was your understanding at the time
of who was in the Rito and Sussex
intersection I remember there being a
language barrier there was a lot of
quebecers in that corner right in the
burrito Sussex corner so that
yeah I didn't have much interaction I
remember being there maybe twice to try
and work something out to get some lanes
open as for Ops and OPP asking
I was unsuccessful every time so as I
under I just want to make sure I
understand this correctly uh in in your
conversations with the Ops and OPP you
were trying to get a lane open for
emergency vehicles is that correct
correct and uh you you made an effort
with the people at Rideau Sussex it was
unsuccessful yes and other than the
language barrier was there any other
reasons that that was unsuccessful to
your mind uh they were they were there
and they they just refused to move so I
did what I could I worked with law
enforcement I said maybe it was twice
Miss Miss Leach and I were there with
Ops
one day and I believe I was there by
myself with Ops another separate time so
probably twice I was there
um
and did you have uh
prior at the time were you familiar with
the name of the farfadas I was not no
um do you know when the first time you
heard the term farfa does about a week
ago under a week ago in the context of
this commission yes
apparently it was according to well we
will have a witness testifying later
today who I'm sure can shed more light
on the far more than me yes
um
I'm going to now ask you some questions
about the other protests that occurred
outside of Ottawa uh in in January and
February 2022. well you were in Ottawa
did you have any Communications or
interactions with anyone who was
participating in protests in Windsor
I don't believe I was I I don't believe
so if there was messages on my phone
they would be for people with no contact
information just phone numbers I
received so many text messages from so
many different people I don't want to
say that I didn't because I may have I
never endorsed it I never communicated
openly with anybody from Windsor at all
did it do you recall whether anyone
asked you uh or anyone that you were
working with in Ottawa For assistance
with respect to the protests in Windsor
if anybody asked me I declined we were
never Associated we had our own we had
enough to deal with here we weren't
worried about
did you have any interactions or
Communications with anyone anyone
participating in any of the other
protests anywhere else in Canada and I
can give you examples if it helps but
I'm going to ask you generally to start
I got text messages from some friends at
Coots uh never any uh just just saying
how things were going never any advice
or never asked any questions to my
recollection they had their own thing
going on there and it wasn't involved
with us in the city here who are your
friends at Coots uh oh
there's a couple guys that were down
there just some local drivers that I've
been friends with for years who were
they ah one man his name is Dan
Somerville he was off and on he was
never an active participant he went down
just to check it out and come back there
was another guy I don't know his name
I'd have to look at my phone I know what
truck he drives I know what he hauls and
do you know this individual whose name
you don't recall do you know if he was
participating in the organization of the
Coots protest or if he was a participant
I think he was just a participant yeah I
don't know the organizers at Coots or
Windsor so
did you have any Communications with
anyone who was protesting in Emerson or
Surrey
I would imagine text messages on my
phone but not people that that I'm
familiar with
did you ever interact with Jeremy
McKenzie while you were in Ottawa I did
not no did you know who Mr Mckenzie was
uh during the protests
I became aware of Mr McKenzie during the
protest
um just know that he was a he was a
veteran and we did a lot of work with
the veterans when we were here I
although I never seen Jeremy
that I know of I met a lot of people
during but I don't recall meeting or
seeing them or I've never spoke with
them too were you familiar with the
group diagonalon during the protests yes
what did you well not no sorry not
during the protest afterwards
um my knowledge of diagonal and it's a
fictional
it's a meme it's uh it was something
that Jeremy
made up to
Patrol online troll
have you spoken with Mr McKenzie since
the protest I have not
coming near to the end of our time so I
just have a few more questions for you
um
it's our understanding that after the
emergencies Act was invoked
um you were one of the people who had
their bank accounts Frozen is that
correct yes can you tell the commission
what that meant for you and what that
was like well my bank accounts were
frozen I believe on the day I was
arrested on the February 17th my
corporate accounts as well as my joint
accounts were frozen for the weekend
unfrozen I believe the Monday
uh my Toronto Dominion Bank account was
frozen for upwards of three and a half
months
and how did that impact you
I learned how to use cash again
and you mentioned already that you were
arrested on February 17th I was yes okay
how is the arrest affected your life
uh the I guess they kind of caught us
off guard they were really professional
and really good to work with so I can't
see a bad thing about anyone
um I was walking with my son and three
other the road captains so if you Google
my name in the arrest you'll see a photo
of me Greening
um my son was there he was 18 years old
at the time and uh
I looked over at him and seen him that
that look he had his uh as a
six-year-old or seven-year-old kids
where the you know the tears were
welling up he was scared and uh
so I simply just said hey bud you're
good and uh in green like that and they
caught me on camera of course and
everything's been good since it just has
changed quite a bit what's changed well
the criminal charges no and uh I've
never
had criminal charges I've never been in
trouble with the law before
and uh one final question for you is
there anything that you think it's
important for the commission to hear
that we haven't touched on
I think we've touched all the bases um
the truth is here I have nothing to hide
as far as I know we were doing
everything within the law according to
legal counsel
that was my main primary goals
thank you those are my questions thank
you
okay
so
um we have the cross-examinations uh to
go ahead the government of Canada I
think is up first
foreign
[Music]
this applies to all of us I assume
a note about the translators the
reminder for the translator is still
here
good morning good morning my name is
Andrew Gibbs and I'm part of the council
team for the government of Canada Mr
groups
foreign
so we've heard a fair bit of testimony
this morning about the uh the start of
the the Convoy and the general
organization and the factions or
divisions within the groups that uh that
preceded is that is that fair correct
so the spark as I understand it was are
you and uh Ms Belton leading over Tick
Tock yes
and you eventually uh organized with
others to come to Ottawa to drop the
Border mandates yes and that was your
sole objective that was my personal sole
objection yes
so to be clear then the others that
eventually joined or started
participating may have had other goals
and objectives quite possibly yes and
you're aware of some of those goals and
objectives there was a lot going on but
yes for the most part
for example Canada Unity was seeking to
sign the mou that commission Council
spoke to you about yes
and others were seeking to
I'll say overthrow but replace the
government of Canada
my understanding when it comes to the
mou and I think that was the only thing
that ever came up was was the fact that
there was something in the mou that said
and not necessarily overthrow but hold
the government accountable apparently I
and like I said before I've never read
the mou
that was never anything that we came to
to Ottawa for that was was not even on
the cards and if anybody came to me
stating that I would have probably told
them to go home
um
I think you you had mentioned you
attended a Facebook live uh interview
yes and
um
Pat King was uh hosting it yes and I
believe uh the mou was presented during
that yes correct and uh do you recall uh
Pat King saying that
um
the objective was to tell the government
who's in control you could have yes and
to give them pink slips
I possibly
and a pink slip you would understand as
removing them from their jobs firing
them essentially I can't speak for Mr
King but possibly okay
now as the group started joining you I
think we saw one Tick Tock video where
uh you mentioned that it this is and I
believe your testimony as well today was
that uh never expected this level of
participation in your wildest dreams no
so many many people joined this protest
yes
and in fact it became
a multi-purpose protest
I I guess so I I stayed with my my
original beliefs of the Border mandates
that was the one that affected me the
most
um that was the reason why I got
involved
um
all the other mandates in place that I
had issues were provincial mandates so
really had no relevance here in Ottawa
but some people in the group seem to
think they did
I guess so like I said I can only speak
for myself and and then my my primary
goal was border mandates okay and so
um during the Facebook live I Mr bowder
suggests that
um
there will be a number of events
um that occur and in fact in addition to
the Facebook live which was uh
referenced at uh com uh 50829 there's a
separate video
um where you and the other organizers Ms
Belton uh Mr bowder and Mr King are
interviewed by a Bonita Peterson do you
recall that interview I don't recall
that okay
um it's in the record at com50838
um and
during that interview and we can we can
bring it up if you like uh it again is
is a lengthy interview over an hour and
a half long
um
but it does speak to
um the activities or events that Mr
bowder
proposes to have
um he also shares the mou again
and suggests that one of the
um events will be to present that mou
to the government of Canada or
Representatives thereof
okay
um
the last uh point that I would make
um just with respect to that video but
I'll I'll move on to the the basic idea
here that um there were as you say a
number of factions or groups that were
involved
okay and you didn't have a vetting
procedure to check who was going to be
there we did not this was a purely
organic
and so as the announcements and the
invitations started to come
the Convoy that was planned with Mr
bowder's Logistics
um started to catch fire yes
and you'd mentioned that all truckers
are different it's very much so and it's
a bit like herding cats yes and if you
put 200 in the room somebody's going to
get a black eye or a broken nose
primarily yes how many did you bring to
Ottawa
oh Manny
like I said there would have been 2500
vehicles in in the West
Convoy there was convoys from the East
convoys from the south there was convoys
I don't know the numbers on how many
people were here there was a lot on the
weekends it was
it was very very busy it was very busy
and is it fair to say that you couldn't
control them all absolutely I could not
control them all
is it also uh not correct that you had a
large flag on the back of your truck
I had a I had a oh yeah I was a
billboard sign I believe and what did it
say
I don't remember it's hanging on the
wall in my shop right now but it's
something about mandates I would imagine
I don't remember if you could refresh my
memory if you haven't well
um you I believe that perhaps you'll
agree with me that there were many flags
around town with the message F Trudeau
yes I didn't have a uh on the back of
the bunk of the truck I have a decal
there that says that I did not have a
flag on my tractor that had that on it
okay so there was a decal on your truck
with that slogan yeah a smaller decal up
on the back of the bunk and would you
agree that that became a bit of a
rallying cry I was surprised to see how
many it was
um yeah it was there was a lot
all the way across the country yes
and were there other messages against
the Liberals
I think it was just that as far as I
remember
okay
I've seen a better rendition of it the
other day by the way my thoughts have
kind of changed on that a little bit
I've seen a young kid a couple days ago
that said hi to me and he had a truck
Trudeau shirt on
foreign
message but probably a little more
politically corrected right but
understood by the crowd as being the
same message I would assume and
encouraging children to share that
message I was a child that had it so
okay
um
you had mentioned uh to commission
Council that you were frustrated with
the mandates
correct and you're you were I believe
your testimony was that you were very
angry yes and uh did this protest and
Convoy and general uh sentiment
that you and Ms Belton started uh did
that Inspire others
yes I did of course
as part of your group
um
and this when I say your group I'm
referring specifically to the freedom
Convoy 2022 I think it's you and Miss
Belton at one point and Ms Leach yes and
Mr Bolton by the uh about her Sorry by
that point is
outside of the group he was always
Canada Unity I don't believe he was ever
part of uh freedom freedom conference
and Mr King has been kind of pushed to
the side yeah yeah okay he still has a
large following yes I believe so okay
um and
I think we we well we heard reference to
a video about
um social media on Tick Tock where Mr
King uh was attributed as saying that Mr
Trudeau was going to catch a bullet you
recall that I heard about it yes I don't
think I ever I'm not sure if I ever seen
it or not okay perhaps I can show it to
you now if we
um were to bring up uh Mr Clerk
ops-407967
and we'll just I'd like to just play the
first 20 seconds of it
it goes on
Trudeau someone's gonna make you catch a
bullet one day to the rest of this
government someone's gonna [ __ ] do
you Zin
you sons of [ __ ] the only way that
and I'm gonna say it out loud the only
way that this is going to be solved is
with bullets
and yeah I said it that's the only way
something's gonna happen a massive
Revolution on a
thank you
now I believe you suggested that Mr King
had told you previously in a
conversation that this was edited and
taken out of context he did yes and you
will agree that it came to light during
the protest yes I believe the second
part of the video my understanding with
Pat was that that was from a previous
post something to do with indigenous
lockdowns or indigenous protests
somewhere else in the country where that
bullet Comet came from right but it it
was posted during the Convoy it was yes
I believe okay and you yourself admitted
I believe to commission Council that
being a bit of an Internet or troll yes
sir and having previously posted nasty
racist and anti-muslim content
regretfully so yes and you have a
significant following now
on The Tick Tock I do yes yes and Mr
King also has a significant following uh
Mr King I believe due to his conditions
isn't allowed on social media at the
time at the time I think he had a
significant following on Facebook I
don't think he was on
on Tick Tock and we saw a discussion
between you and Ms Leach referred to
um by commission Council where you and
Miss Leach discussed the need to keep
him around if possible because of his
following
apparently yes
okay
so
you're aware that the freedom Convoy
group this would be your group
um put out daily briefings yes and these
daily briefings
um did you have input into them
not very often no my job
was literally out with the trucks on a
regular basis I would would come sit in
at the end of the day and have
conversations with other people in the
group to just to get but I don't
remember being
I remember being at the first news
conference I remember telling Miss Leach
that I didn't want to be the one in
front of the camera but I would be the
one that Stood Beside the one at the
camera and that was the only time I was
I think I did a couple but I was always
sitting off to the side um my job was
truck safety truck issues making sure
everybody was was looked after
looked after in terms of fuel and
mechanics and yeah fuel mechanics if any
issues arose working with the police
that was my my main job was working with
law enforcement
okay and um would you agree that the
daily updates the purpose of those was
to inform the participants in your group
of the daily uh events I believe so yes
and it was circulated each day I believe
so yes
and it would be circulated in the
morning presumably the weather for the
day okay so if we can turn to hrf
seven Zero's nine
and this should be
um
dated January 28th if I'm not mistaken
does this look like one of the updates
that the freedom Convoy 2022 group would
have circulated it could have I don't
really remember reading any of them okay
well
um
well just walk through it briefly
um because there are a few of them that
I'd like to bring to your attention this
one is dated January 28th it provides
that the Saturday weather is sunny low
minus 21 etc for Sunday Monday Tuesday
Wednesday
and then it's giving the general update
on the overview
you see the overview paragraph there
will be the biggest protest movement in
Canada ever would you agree with that
yes
and
um
if you scroll to item eight I just want
to bring this to your attention because
I believe you said earlier that the only
purpose of this uh your group Freedom
Convoy 2022 was to end the Border
mandate I noted that was my personality
that was of myself I don't speak for
everyone on the group so I I didn't have
anything to do with these drafts on a on
a daily basis I was I was purely here
for the mandates okay so is there
somebody we should be speaking to with
respect to these daily updates I'm not
even sure who produced these on a daily
basis I can't speak to that I uh like I
said I was out
I literally go to bed at seven o'clock
in the morning every morning if not
earlier I was out with the trucks the
end sorry slow down please the entire
day I was uh I was on the ground the
entire time at the end of the day
if something urgent arose I didn't take
part in any of these updates so you'd
agree that you were one of the faces of
the freedom Convoy 2022 I agreed yes
with the largest social media presence
that could be contested I'm not sure I
Yeah by others in the power struggle
presumably could have been yes okay
so item eight states of note Deputy
Prime Minister and Finance Minister
Christian Freeland Is On The Board of
Trustees for the world economic forum
she is a key figure there along with
President XI of China Bill Gates and
other globalists
it was the global economic Forum that
started it is 2030. you will own nothing
that stated sorry it is 2030 you will
own nothing and you will be happy had
you heard this message before I've seen
it on social media before I didn't like
I said I never read this document so I
don't know what would be in it
okay
um
there are a series of these daily
briefings often making reference to the
world economic forum
and um
there is one at hrf 5029
on February 8th
that refers to at the top can we pull
that one up please
foreign
again this is February 8th and there's
an image of the covid-19 the great reset
is from the world economic Forum Deputy
Prime Minister Freeland Is On The Board
of Trustees of the wef again
had you heard of the great reset before
via social media posts more so in the
last
six months I don't recall seeing that or
even hearing about it at the time
and what is the nature of your
understanding of this book The Great
reset I I've never read it okay if
you'll scroll to
um the bottom of this there's a
reference a section that deals with
um
the
uh if you go to the next page
tow trucks refusing service
you see that section yes according to
Ottawa city manager Steve kanalakos who
testified earlier about the difficulty
of obtaining tow trucks to the
commission all tow truck companies under
contract to the city of Ottawa are
refusing to provide heavy tow truck
services
this has been sorry this has been a
common occurrence right across Canada
as tow truck operators are considering
their long-term relationships with the
trucking industry as well as the
Canadian public
is that consistent with your
understanding I believe so yes thank you
okay
if we now turn to February 16th
at hrf6052
and this is the last uh or second to
last daily update I'll bring you to
this one begins with a photograph
of prime minister Trudeau
with World economic Forum leader Klaus
Schwab do you see that yes
and underneath there's a description of
a video
of Klaus Schwab describing Trudeau's
loyalty to the world economic forum
a video has emerged World economic Forum
leader Klaus Schwab describing Trudeau's
loyalty to this globalist organization
the video appears to have been taken in
2016 just after Trudeau became the Prime
Minister do you see that yes
and
if we scroll to the bottom there's a
Twitter link there uh with the no number
one waffler
um if we scroll to the bottom it ends
with a photo of Deputy Prime Minister
Christian Freeland
yes do you see that photo I do yes and
the caption reads Finance Minister
Freeland seen here at a world economic
Forum event says The Government Can
arbitrarily seize bank accounts
crowdfunding money and cryptocurrencies
now this is issued on February 16th this
newsletter to your group the the the
fraction of Freedom Convoy 2022 correct
yes
on February 17th
another post is issued hrf
six zeros eight three
which is a special notice
issued by the group
just to note that you're out of time but
you know if you'll be much longer I need
about five minutes on these two points
sir
and they'll tie the two together okay
well thank you let me have your adults
you have the post and this is a uh
Freedom Convoy 2022 reaffirms its
commitment to Peaceful demonstration
correct
yes
and uh in this notice you'll see that it
it expressly condemns if we scroll down
um
one two three fourth paragraph
Pat King does not speak for us we
expressly condemn any talk of violence
from him or others
you see that yes and that accurately
reflects your views at that time I again
I had nothing to do with this document
so it would have been inside the
meetings I would assume but in terms of
your views of Pat King yes if that's an
accurate statement from your perspective
yes and also talk of violence from him
or others yes
were you aware sir that the night before
on February 16th following the other
notice with the photograph of Christian
Freeland at the bottom
that Deputy Prime Minister Freeland
received a death threat I was not no
so if we can turn to PB dot can
four zeros
1757 underscore Rel
and again you had said earlier your
testimony here today is that you had no
control over the people who had come
to the protest
at in response to your open invitation
correct
and so have you seen this
email before I have not no
it's sent on Wednesday February 16th at
1 23 pm
to
Christia Freeland MP and it reads I
declare war on all the Canadian
government for lying about covet 19.
Christian Freeland will get a Bullet to
the Head
prepare to feel our Wrath
yours truly
the Canadian covet government resistance
we will visit you at your home this
Friday at 6 PM so you better be hidden
and be placed into protection because we
know where you live and signed Larry
Jenkins
I assume you would
reject this statement in any such action
unequivocally yes thank you
and the last
question then is were you aware sir
that on February 16th the same day
the opp apprehended someone in Ottawa
who was wearing body armor
and carrying a large knife
along with other knives
a sword and machetes that were seized
out of his truck I was not aware of that
no okay I will take you to Ops three
zeros one one eight three seven
Mr commissioner I understand my friends
out of time and this witness has
testified several times he has no
knowledge of these things so I'm
wondering what the purpose of this is
other than grandstanding
yeah not sure this is hugely helpful in
the sense that he can't comment on any
of these but maybe you can just file it
for the moment and try it on someone
else when you have some time
thank you sir so the last question then
is would you agree with me that when
when you start a fire and fan the flames
it can get out of control and you had no
control over those other factions who
had come to this
protest that's where uh that's where I
spent a lot of time on the ground I
spent a lot of time working with people
that were with the original Convoy from
the past from the west and with people
that were not with the West if somebody
had a concern I said it on more than one
occasion on my videos if anybody has a
problem if anybody wants to yell at
somebody find my number and phone me and
yell at me I will gladly take it um the
last thing I ever wanted was a letter
like that I never ever heard that story
up until now understood and I believe
sir that you'd also confirmed that
um you were not always successful in
your efforts to convince the
participants to agree with you or to
follow you agreed yes thank you those
are my questions
okay so that takes us I think to the
morning break so we'll take a little
time
um and so we'll take 15 minutes
and continue on the return
the commission is in recess for 15
minutes
you know
thank you
once again
thank you
order a lot
the commission is reconvened
okay
um next I understand
it's the city of Ottawa wants to go next
okay
I I think it's more a request from the
coalition to go later but I said we're
happy to go anytime okay well and let's
uh let's start with the city of Ottawa
I was checking if it's morning or
afternoon good morning Mr Barber uh
Alyssa Tomkins Council for the city of
Ottawa I I just have a few questions for
you today
um we saw earlier in this proceeding
that you had text with Kim ayat who is
the general manager of emergency and
protective services at the city yeah I'm
not sure of his role but yes I I'm just
gonna put them on the screen to assist
you in that regard so if we could bring
up document
Ott
I think it's three zeros three zero zero
five seven
and these are the the text messages were
produced by Mr ayat so uh I believe
Chris protester is you
I'm assuming so yes it looks like Kevin
um yeah so if we could just scroll down
to the third page and I I just want to
talk to you a little bit about your your
role in moving the trucks and how far it
got so if we get to here starting at
this exchange uh we're now February 15th
which I believe is the Tuesday at 8 30
and Kim is asking you uh how it's gone
moving the trucks effectively and in
particular how many big trucks uh you're
able to move so if we could keep
scrolling please just the large trucks
and not the pickups or cars
and then I believe this is your response
if we keep scrolling
yeah can you um
confirm that you provided this
information to Mr ayat that it's
accurate and any elaboration that you
see fit so to my recollection we moved
approximately 100 Vehicles into the
downtown core on that uh February 15th
uh 40 of which were tractors semi-units
and apparently approximately 23 were
moved up onto Wellington in one block
okay now when you say 23 uh what
happened to the the rest of the 40. they
moved out of town they would have went
to
um oh exit we called it actually the 88
um armoire
urn
yeah yeah and Tremor there's a there's
two different ones that I always got
confused with which one it was it was
the one on the east side of town anyway
so okay that was that was my my next
question was about the trucks leaving
downtown now
um after this if we keep scrolling you
we are it refers I note in passing to
you tiring yourself out so again your
your weight loss if sorry if you could
scroll up Mr clerk apologies uh so then
uh Kim writes to you about running into
trouble with any checks and then if we
can scroll down to your response
uh thanks keep scrolling
yeah so if if you can just confirm uh
that you wrote this to Mr Ed and then
just provide a little more context for
the commissioner absolutely uh so
February 14th we had a meeting at City
Hall with Kim and uh uh Drummond and I
believe
Steve if I'm not correct I believe so
yes
um we left that meeting excited ready to
go out uh we had an agreement that we
were going to move as many trucks as we
could out of the residential area up
onto Wellington
um myself and three other Road captains
that were close with me went out and
started speaking with the drivers trying
to figure out who was ready to move
sorry who was ready to move first thing
Monday morning who we could count on and
where we could get them to move
um so seven o'clock in the morning
rolled around Monday morning February
15th
and we struggled with communication
between police City
and ourselves as to who allowed the move
so we were on at 7 00 am it was roughly
I'm thinking about 12 30
after lunch before the first police car
actually moved and we were allowed to
move so my understanding we had 72 hours
to get as many vehicles out of the
downtown core as possible
something broke down it was out of my
control we got as many trucks as we
could that day and you remember it was
cold and I at the end of the day I was I
was I was wore out I was done it was a
lot of walking it was a tremendous
amount of walking
something happened at the end of the day
there was a breakdown I believe
um she slowly resigned something
happened where the deal was off the
table and we were
we were done so I did everything in
power
we had so many more places on Wellington
we were we could have put more trucks we
mapped everything out we had guys that
were ready to move we ran at a time in
the day on the Monday and then planned
to continue moving on the Tuesday
and like I said something fell apart we
were done okay when you say something
fell apart uh you have no further
evidence on that like the commissioner
my communication was with Nicole with
Ops and she'd explained to me that did
we'd had our chance I don't remember how
my text messages are at the at the
police station
um that we had our chance and we didn't
accomplish what we agreed to do and the
deal was off the table
okay that was different from
what my understanding of what the day
was
um where things fell apart I I still yet
to understand
okay that
students thank you very much
okay the next uh I believe is the uh
Ottawa Police Service
thank you Mr commissioner this is
Jessica Barrow for the Ottawa Police
Service our questions have already been
canvassed so we have nothing further for
this witness thank you
okay and the Ontario Provincial Police
I have no questions thank you
commissioner
uh Mr slowly this Council
morning I'm Tom Curry for former Chief
slowly I just have a few questions about
some facts if you can help us
um the uh the trucks first of all I
appreciate you don't have a a good
accurate count of how many vehicles were
in the aggregate of the of the Convoy or
even I suppose the Western Convoy that'd
be right oh yes can you tell the
commissioner though whether the trucks
that came with you
in in the part of the Convoy that you
had initiated uh were those independent
operators yes uh a lot of the major
companies
didn't want the advertisements from from
their business names on the doors for
company drivers so
I would say 95 98 of the of the tractor
trailer units were independent operators
that would be affected by the border
mandates right and that probably relates
doesn't it to your inability to to have
all of them follow a particular single
set of instructions independent operator
is more likely to be an independent
thinker and and uh yes generally yes and
were those were those independent
operators who came from the West
uh operating
um
tractors that had
uh sleeping compartments
there was a mix uh I'm not sure the
numbers a very small but we consider
they're called day cabs where it's just
the cab and no sleeper unit a very small
amount I I remember seeing
a handful yes there was some a few there
and a day cab operator is not by
definition that's a person who's who's
not operating
a vehicle Along on a long haul unless
they've got accommodation someplace else
which they wouldn't normally have right
and so the for the for the drivers and
operators who were in tractors with
sleeper units did they remain
in their sleeper units During the period
of the Convoy
I'd say there'd be a good a mixed bag
um
what I kind of realized the community
really came together so there would be
the trucks would have to run a lot
because it was so frigid
um what one guy would do would rent a
hotel room and then cycle through
drivers to get cleaned up and showered
and looked after
um the majority of the guys slept in in
their trucks in the night and they'd
need fuel to keep running for the
reasons that you've given to keep the
unit warm yes for heat and so the fuel
did you recognize it as that
and I appreciate what you told my
friends that you weren't 100 sure how
long this thing was going to last when
you came
fuel wasn't something we were we were
worried about at the first we we didn't
know I I didn't know what to expect when
we got here I honestly I had no clue
um and so it was a
it was confusing to try and keep
everything straight in a day
and fuel became a challenge for you as a
convoy organizer
and police and the and the residents in
the community because of the safety risk
is that fair yes and was that one of the
things that you tried to work with
police
to minimize that risk I remember having
conversations with with some of the
officers in regards to what we call a
slip tank which is a fixed 500 gallon
tank in the back of a of a pickup truck
with a hose and a pump
um was a lot safer and and a lot less
risk of fuel spilling compared to people
walking around with with five gallon
Jerry cans that that wasn't that wasn't
the proper way to do things and I tried
to have a conversation multiple times to
get more slip tanks in to put fuel in
those trucks compared to safety hazards
of the of the Jerry cans right you
hadn't brought few slip tanks yourselves
no no we didn't no so so they there
there was in terms of the organization
the fuel and how you were going to
provide fuel for trucks running past say
the first weekend uh was not a pla part
of the plan that you had it was okay and
then
um a couple of things you told us that
told the commissioner that that you
succeeded in moving the load I think it
was a load safe truck that was on an
angle at Rideau and Sussex yeah police
had been unable to get that operator to
cooperate
and even then when when you turn to the
rest of the Rito and Sussex
operators no luck at all I I I tried
multiple times the threito in Sussex and
good guys really good guys and they had
a point and they were protesting and uh
yeah we just set a difference I did what
it could but
couple of other things and finally if I
could uh Mr Barber you told us and I
don't want to know what the legal advice
was but early early on in this effort is
it right that you turned your minds to
the to what protest what lawful protest
looked like and what unlawful protests
would look like we were very fortunate
that we had legal we had lawyers fly in
I believe it was the first week and and
we had guidance there we had somebody
that we could it would tell us what what
our rights were because you know being
truck drivers were not all really good
at litigating so we had lawyers we had
people that could give us advice we had
there was a ton of advice there and it
was very much appreciated weren't able
necessarily or maybe at all to convey
to put that legal advice into action
across the whole spectrum of the convoys
though no
and final thing then at I think on the
7th of February it be you became aware
that police were were intending to
mobilize additional Personnel in the
number of 1800 am I right that that
signaled to you as a convoy operator
that there was there was going to be a
police response coming yes it did yeah
we were we knew it was inevitable at
some point I guess we were hoping it
wasn't we hoping we were able to resolve
the issues with the government and we
could all go home but that didn't that
didn't transpire and you knew as to that
the negotiation that speaking to police
police you've heard about the police you
probably saw them I spoke with a lot of
police liaison liaison they weren't able
to they they were never going to be able
to make a to negotiate with you for the
kinds of things that you wanted to speak
to government about no they were they
were successful in negotiating between
the city I believe and and us and then
that was a step in the right direction
we were hoping that one step forward
would maybe result in another step
higher and we could we could have an
audience but it didn't with with federal
government some sort of federal
government yes thank you for your time
thank you
thank you
next uh the Ottawa residents
uh thank you commissioner Mr Barbara my
name is Paul champ I'm lawyer for the
auto Coalition for residents and
businesses good morning Mr Trump have
some questions for you sure
I think you probably uh you may already
be aware of this I'm from Saskatchewan
as well so yeah oh I wasn't aware of
that okay
we're both from God's land where
whereabouts may I ask Regina ah good but
I've been I've been in your area many
many times this is God's country
um
so Mr Barbara I'd just like to start
about this about the reasons why you
were coming to Ottawa uh it was about
mandates generally or was it just the
trucker uh mandates the Mandate or the
the Border uh restriction that truckers
could no longer enter or pass through if
they I can only speak for myself but for
me personally it was the Border
amenities that was the that was the last
straw per se in in the government going
too far and and wanting I knew we I
needed my voice to be heard right and
government going too far it was it was
everything it was the restrictions the
the the the uh the restrictions from
going into restaurants from you know
schools were shut down all those sorts
of things it just built up and that was
the last straw for you
there's so many different stories that
I've heard throughout this ordeal that
that contribute to why
we went there when you're hearing
stories of people's parents dying in a
hospital bed alone because mandates
wouldn't allow their kids to be with
their with their with their adults when
they took their last breath there's
you've seen the mental health issues in
this country just plummet it was it was
sad I watched that with my own children
my daughter it was 16 at the time I was
uh was unvaxed in high school bullied by
the rest of her classmates because she
was
wasn't vaccinated she had to play a
clarinet in music class in a separate
room
the um the trucker mandate in particular
though the United States had a mandate
in place at the same time correct so it
didn't matter what Ottawa did I believe
it came in afterwards I believe the
Canadian the Canadian government
announced to the Mandate first
excuse me but many mandates that people
are upset about were provincial mandates
right I guess
Otto is like a symbol of all levels of
government for many of those people in
the Convoy I think honestly when I come
to the provincial mandates they they
were a lot to deal with
um they didn't affect my business to the
way that the federal mandates affected
my business that that was the a driving
and it's I struggled with it even though
they've been in place since since then
it has still been a struggle the entire
summer to try and keep up with a lack of
drivers and equipment we can get across
the border but we've literally lost a
lot of guys
so Mr Barbara I want to ask you some
questions about your rival in Ottawa
since the Ottawa Police didn't ask you
any questions about this I want to
understand you believed that when you
were coming to Ottawa uh when you were
in the last 100 kilometers you
understanding was that the trucks would
be going to staging areas is that right
yes and outside the city no
um and to this day I've never been to
these Parks but my understanding coming
across Canada was a two-staging areas
major Hills Park and Confederate Park
were the two places that the opp now
whether
that message got mixed up somewhere
along the lines that is what I was told
and that is what I understood coming
across Canada we had places to stay
staging areas in these two parks we had
porta potties set up ready to go they
were prepared for us for us when we got
there and that turned out to be not true
and when did that change like who
informed you that you could just go to
downtown Ottawa instead and when well
Ops LED myself in another truck before
the the Convoy was cut off at the war
Mormon War Museum there it became clear
to me then with the amount of people
downtown with the amount of traffic in
downtown and we slowly kind of worked
our way
to the Supreme Court is is where I
couldn't go any further and that's where
I was stopped that's where my tractor
remained for until I believe I've
removed it from the city on the 7th of
February okay and where did you stay uh
during the course of the protest I had a
hotel room we were at uh we were at the
arc hotel for a little while and then we
uh we moved to the Sheridan I believe
and
um
we've I've seen a news story about your
text messages that you had with some of
the organizers and seen uh reference uh
you having texts with Ms Leach on
January 30th where she said that she'd
received a call from the command center
what was the command center for you guys
I remember seeing that in my uh my
disclosure too
um so the text message was to the
something to the sort of received a
message from the from the command center
was the basement at the Swiss hotel we
had people there that were looking after
EMTs we had people on the ground to make
sure people were safe in the crowds
um emtr CNP or police response it was
quite the operation Tamara discussed the
fact they wanted to
gridlocked the city gridlock the city
right and she said I don't want to make
this decision on my own can you come uh
head over here soon did you go over to
that meeting at the command center
I don't remember having that
conversation with her and uh and even if
it it had happened
I went right back out to uh to make sure
emergency lanes were open with with
police so I if there was a meeting it
wasn't the gridlock the city it would
have been too
keep the emergency lanes open that was
my primary job the entire time I was
here but the trucks did gridlock the
city you would agree with me in certain
spots they did yes like I I tried really
hard to make sure at least the emergency
lanes were open emergency lanes I can I
can tell you I almost got into a
physical altercation at least twice with
the driver that was was ignorant about
about moving when I asked them to um
now I just want to ask you a couple
questions about you told us that you
were protesting about uh the the trucker
mandate at the border uh did you have
were you opposed to mask mandates as
well I always I don't like a mask
it's not something that I really enjoy
wearing but in the province of
Saskatchewan where I'm from I always
wore my mask
um I like to look at it is I didn't want
to have that business get into trouble
if a health officer walked in the door
and seen I was being ignorant didn't
wear a mask so I'll admit when I was in
Ottawa I didn't wear a mask here we were
here for anti-mandates but I have always
followed the rules wherever they are in
every restaurant when the coveted
vaccine passport came out in
Saskatchewan October 1st I will I I
didn't I didn't go to a restaurant
uh in in Ottawa though uh you'd agree
with me that large groups of Convoy
protesters uh were going into stores and
restaurants and shops all unmasked you
ever wear that I was never part of that
you weren't part of that but that was
that was a protest tactic wasn't it not
on my part I believe that was more
Canada unity and James bouter I believe
that was that was something that was
discussed in the jail the January 13th I
remember watching it and listening to
James talk about that so it was a tactic
that was discussed but you weren't you
you didn't necessarily support it or
take part in it I never took part in it
no and you were aware that in Ontario
there was a law that stores and shops
couldn't allow people in with masks and
they'd be fined if they allowed that you
understood yes yeah and did you hear
stories about staff who were saying
things people please take put on a mask
or leave and staff being threatened did
you hear stories about that uh well I
was sick for a little while with with a
cold a really bad cold and I remember
going into Shoppers Drug Mart downtown
somewhere near
the hotel and uh I had to put a mask on
because the lady wouldn't serve us and
refused to service so I put the mask on
and oh blood
I just want to ask you some questions
about the money uh the money that was
raised was meant to cover Fuel and food
and travel expenses for the truckers is
that right yes it also covered Hotel
bills is that right
we we never had any access to the money
we had a short stint of access a lot of
times the drivers paid for their own
hotel rooms
we had approximately I believe it was
like twenty thousand dollars that's all
the access we had to the money before
I believe that if bank accounts were
frozen you're talking about the GoFundMe
money yeah but you guys raised an
enormous amount of money outside of that
right you were raising thousands of
dollars a day in cash and he transfers
correct
yeah the e-transfers would have went
into Mrs slitch's personal bank account
um and cash
I don't know what happened with the cash
the cash was there was always people
donating cash it was all around I guess
there's an interview summary uh in this
matter I presume you're aware of Mr Eros
uh you know chatty or us yes and Chad
says that uh there was approximately
twenty thousand dollars being raised in
cash per day uh does that sound roughly
accurate to you uh he was the freedom
Corp paid accountant um I had no
knowledge that I wasn't involved with
any of that he also speaks about how uh
that occasionally to get rid of all this
cash on hand they were putting in an
envelopes putting numbers on it and
we're giving it out to truckers you're
aware of that yes I took part in that
spot you took part in that so you were
aware there was large amounts of cash I
didn't get to count the cash I was given
envelopes and I would go in and see what
drivers were in need of some cash and
deposit or give them the cash right so
you were handing out it's my
understanding those envelopes is between
five hundred dollars and two thousand
dollars per envelope 500 there was
another group that came in towards the
end that the I Believe Miss belton's
group we're we're handing out two
thousand dollars apparently but it
didn't go as far and the average trucker
earns about 45 to 50 000 a year is that
right Mr uh I would say probably more I
maybe I'm not sure 70. it's kind of hard
to live off fifty thousand dollars a
year in this country now for sure for
sure
now uh the big amount of money that was
raised that you could never access with
give with GoFundMe nor Gibson go uh
there was a lot of people wanting access
to that money is that right I believe so
yes and you guys had to deal with people
opportunistically wanting to try to find
ways to access that money from you
I I believe it'd be better question for
Miss Lynch I really never sorry that's
fair okay
um just getting back to the hotel bills
though your hotel bill was paid for by
someone else correct yes and who was
that Mr Gara that was paying for your
hotel no uh we had we had uh um there
was a businessman that helped us out
along the way Mr burgo Joseph Pergo I
believe he he was fitting the bills for
some of our hotel rooms and and then
mentoring us and and helping us out with
with
what about uh Mr King Pat King his hotel
Bell was paid as well uh by your group
is that right I believe you I I don't
know where Pat stayed I was under the
understanding he was outside the city
somewhere in a in a Airbnb or whatever
they call her uh didn't Mr King approach
you at times uh asking if uh the war
room or the command center could provide
a large amount of money to pay off Hotel
bills of other supporters
I don't recall him talking to me
personally about that but him asking you
to put you and him in touch with someone
who had access to the money
there's a lot of things going on on a
regular basis but I don't recall
I just want to ask you now about the
honking
um now as a truck driver uh can you tell
us what are air horns and Trey horns for
so an air horn is the factory set of
horns on a commercial truck which is
usually mounted on the roof of the cab
operated by in my personal truck that's
a chain in the center of the dash on the
top and you pull it it operates the two
horns that are on the roof a train horn
is an aftermarket it is literally three
large terrain horns with a valve usually
guys Mount them I don't own a train horn
I've never owned one it's mounted on the
floor and it's got a valve for you you
put more air to it to make a louder
noise I guess they're obnoxious and and
the purpose is uh because the trucks are
so large to warn people from very very
very far away that a truck is coming
correct
now the purpose in my opinion personal
opinion on a train horn is is just well
air horns are training horns same yeah
yeah no it's it's used for two primary
reasons one's for um for excitement I
always like to to go back to the the
kids sitting on the side of the road or
when you have a vehicle past you with
kids in the back seat and they're doing
the arm pump that's the excitement part
of an air horn
um then the other part of the air horn
is is the
Danger
right
um and you're trained as a with your
commercial license that air horns even
in themselves can be dangerously loud
correct yes
but uh in this case horns became a bit
of a symbol for the Truckers coming to
Ottawa is that right I guess so yes and
assembled for the protest
my truck was parked in front of the
Supreme Court for from uh February 29th
when we arrived until I removed it from
downtown on February 7th
um so I I don't believe I personally
pulled an air horn after that wasn't my
question my question was that the horns
became a bit of a symbol for they did
yeah they were they were everywhere yes
and once the truckers Park you didn't I
get that but many of the trucks were
honking all day and night correct
for the first little while yes and those
that wouldn't listen we we tried to
reason with and get them I tried to
reason with to try and get them under
control and they were honking on a
schedule of some type correct like it
would be like 10 minutes straight for
every 30 minutes or something like that
I don't recall that there was something
to do with that there was a couple guys
in front of Parliament that were
obnoxiously blowing their horn we'll say
well the block captains were and Road
the block captains were coordinating
within each other about how and when to
blow the horns were they not that was
never part of my dealings uh I involved
myself in a couple of the block Captain
meetings but
for the most part
I I didn't I don't remember hearing
anything about that I remember there
being a curfew
um what was it seven to seven or
something like that that somebody
negotiated in the first week my memory
fails Beyond exactly what it was and uh
you've told us you testified that you
put out several videos asking the
truckers to stop honking and respect
their Essence is that right yes but
isn't it true Mr Barber that your videos
were just telling them not to blow the
horns in the middle of the night
I don't recall that I remember no the
videos when I would yell
I could use multiple videos out there of
me yelling stop and then there was
daylight hours so I was sleeping at
night and then to be honest with you
where I was in the hotel room I don't
remember the the train or the horns
actually waking me or having a hard time
sleeping
the uh just there's a HR I'm not gonna
ask to put it up because we don't have
time hrf 183 is a video of February 1st
and Tick Tock where you tell guys to
stop
uh honking and stop laying on the horns
at 3am and the guys have stopped which
is nice
so you're asking guys not to lay on
horns in the middle of the night I'd
have to see the video again to see that
I don't recall that video I'm not saying
it's not there but um or later that day
it might have been in the evening I
would say I remember yeah
I remember doing a video I've seen it in
my in in my evidence here
um last night where I I showed the
street in front of my hotel room with
the trucks and it was in the evening and
it was perfectly quiet
you did put out a tick tock video on
February 9th though did you not uh
saying that if the police tried to come
to a truck they should uh notwithstand
in the injunction they should pull on
their horns correct so in regards to
that video there
um in consultation with legal teams we
were instructed
the the bunk of your truck was
considered a residence
and the police needed to have a warrant
to breach the residents of your truck
and we were also
instructed by legal counsel did in a
case of something like that
um what we what they were telling me
I've never been involved with something
else before so I'm I have no idea what
happens when police Kettle but on my
understanding was if the police come
and their Mass arrests happening we were
allowed to try and warn the other
drivers so yes there was a video it's in
evidence I believe
um yeah that's sad
hrf000217 for the record and Mr Barber
uh Mr Wilson has put in an interview
summary we're going to hear from him
tomorrow where he says that uh you were
asking truckers to implement a quiet
hours and to only honk between 8 A.M and
8pm is that correct apparently there was
a there was some sort of a deal in the
first week or so we were allowed to honk
during the days apparently so yeah
trying to play with the rules if I uh
deal with whom I think with the city I
was never involved with the inner
workings of the deals with the city
other than when we did the truck move or
the accordion Junction or something to
that effect there was there was a deal
out there and I'm not I don't remember
exactly well I think we might I think we
heard a little bit of evidence that Mr
Wilson and Ms chippyak were trying to
negotiate with this city saying if the
truckers agreed to uh not oppose the
renewal of the injunction and to only
keep honking between 8 A.M and 8 PM so
they're trying to get a deal like that
could be possible they work behind the
scenes Relentless they were honestly God
sets they were they were they were right
there with us for help
because the the truck horns were all day
even all day was quite they were
annoying um I remember a Sunday service
in front of the stage and uh we were
trying to listen to the pastor do a
sermon and
you couldn't it was kind of like quit
but that was in front of Wellington and
that was I believe in the first week so
uh just to ask a couple questions Mr
Barber
um uh have you ever met or communicated
with Tyler Russell I don't know that
name or uh Derek Harrison I don't know
that name either have you ever met her
communicated with Alex Breen no
and have you ever oh you've already been
asked about Mr McKenzie
if I had there's like I said my phone
was extremely busy there's a ton of
numbers on that phone that
if there would be no contact name with
it there might have been somebody
contact me but
not to my knowledge I should say right
I understand
all right thank you Mr Brown with us
thank you Mr thank you
okay next uh call on the ccla
uh good good afternoon Mr Barber I'm uh
going to be asking you questions via
Zoom my name is Eva crayefska and I'm
counselor to the Canadians civil
liberties Association pleased to meet
you
uh my questions are going to focus on
the impact of the orders freezing the
bank accounts
so I understand from your earlier
evidence that your bank accounts were
frozen uh uh during the course of or
after the protest is that fair yes they
were
and can you just say specify for me was
it your personal account that was frozen
so we've got three major accounts that
were frozen one was the corporate
account uh the other one was a joint
bank account with my my lovely wife and
the third was Toronto Dominion personal
bank account the personal bank account
with Toronto Dominion was closed for
roughly three and a half months I had no
access to funds
the other two bank accounts were
uh they were closed for the weekend a
couple payments went back I had one NSF
NSF charge I believe and uh the fuel
cards got shut off for my drivers so
they weren't very happy
okay and uh so let me just break that
down the fuel cards for your drivers are
those uh business credit cards
in in my line of business with the
trucking company we run KOA card lock
cards with different fuel Distributors
and I have agreements with those fuel
companies to withdraw payments
automatically out of my accounts every
Sunday so I'm up on current on my fuel
bills
and are those linked to your corporate
account then yes they are yes and so
when your corporate account was frozen
then the fuel cards were also
inoperative yes
and you said that they were frozen on
the Sunday so is that uh would that be
the Sunday
the
um the 20th of February 20th they were
would have been frozen on the 17th I
believe
um my bank manager at CIBC explained to
me that they were reopened on Monday
she wouldn't give me details she she'd
explain to me that she'd got an email
from RCMP saying it was a an illegal
freeze or something and and that they
were reopened right away but Toronto
Dominion was a different story they
Toronto Dominion was closed without any
excuse I tried desperately
to get a hold of somebody from Toronto
Dominion to explain to me why my
accounts are frozen and I I had to
receive an explanation
when your accounts were frozen were they
frozen before or after you were arrested
I believe they were frozen on the day of
we weren't I wasn't really using a debit
card all the stores were closed downtown
so I believe the 17th is when they were
frozen
right and you were informed that they
were frozen with respect to your
corporate account your CIBC corporate
account it was someone at CIBC who
informed you that they were frozen I
believe so I don't think I knew that the
corporate account was frozen until
I didn't have a cell phone so I couldn't
check
um balances or anything until I got back
home I believe
so it was only after the fact when you
came home that you learned that it had
been frozen by uh by a letter from CIBC
or by a telephone call
that I can't recall I don't remember if
I got much correspondence on personal
friends with my banker at CIBC so she
may have sent me a text message I didn't
have a phone so
I can't recall and your TD Bank account
how did you learn the personal one how
did you learn that that was frozen well
the debit card wouldn't work
and and you said that you tried to
obtain information from TD as to why it
was frozen and why it took so long to
reopen yes
did you get a satisfactory answer no no
I didn't I was given a phone number and
a first name and when I called that
number I was uh just a short answer I
believe I spoke with them he called me
back once I kind of made it a point to
call them every week to question him on
why
and uh I never did get an answer back
I was the first name and phone number
that you received there was someone from
uh TD Bank it was yeah somebody in
Ontario I believe
his name did you ever receive any
correspondence from the from the RCMP or
the Ops with respect to the freezing of
your bank accounts I did not no
okay and uh can you can you speak to me
first about the the impact of the
freezing of your corporate bank account
what impact did it have on your business
you mentioned the cancellation of the
fuel cards can you elaborate on that
yeah a cancellation on my field card so
uh I had to remake the payment
fuel cards were shut off because of the
lack of payment there was an NSF charge
one one that happened down the road a
little ways I applied for a loan
and was going to put a significant
amount of cash down the money down on
the loan for for a deposit and I was
rejected
from my financing company because of my
uh because of the account being frozen
apparently I don't know they wouldn't
really explain they just said I was
declined the loan and uh
I have a perfect credit rating I've
never been in trouble with better it's
been years since I've been in trouble
with the credit rating
20 some plus years I would say so I
stand good with the banks
sorry sir with respect to the fuel cards
for how long were your drivers not able
to use the fuel cards to supply the
vehicles I would imagine it was a matter
of a day or two I I was into the bank
right away I was home so I was able to
get into the bank and make the payment
right away and fuel companies are good
but they get pretty nervous when uh when
a payment gets returned
I'm sure I'm sure everybody does
um and so with respect to your personal
bank account you said that how did that
impact can you provide a little bit more
elaboration on how it impacted you it
said you said that you had to use cash
uh what can you elaborate on what you
you mean by that or how it impact you to
have your personal bank account Frozen
uh it changes everything you do you
don't realize how much you use the debit
card in your pocket I guess I went back
to as any Canadian there apparently you
keep a small stash of cash for
emergencies and that that got used
um yeah I had to go back to cash for the
time being
thank you sir those are all my questions
appreciate it
okay next uh
jccf and democracy fund
oh
foreign
Mr commissioner Mr Barber afternoon my
name is Antoine Dai I'm counsel to
Citizens for Freedom representing the
peaceful wind peaceful protesters in
Windsor appreciate it uh Mr Barbary
indicated that you let a convoy of
trucks from out west to Ottawa and that
you were a point of contact with local
police forces along the way
have you had have you ever had any
contact with the Windsor Police Service
I don't believe so no
he indicated that while you're traveling
across the country that one of your
primary responsibilities was dealing
with Logistics listening to the radio
chatter do you ever recall receiving or
responding to any requests for support
from the demonstrators in Windsor
whether it's you know request for trucks
or other logistical support
I don't believe so no there was it was a
busy phone I may have missed something
but I don't remember or recall ever
receiving any content perfect and and if
you did receive this type of request is
this something that you would have
brought up with with your internal
leadership team uh no we were we were
busy here enough we weren't worried
about Windsor Coots or anywhere else
perfect and so the Convoy that you were
leading across the country to Ottawa
that did not pass through or anywhere
near Windsor Ontario is that correct it
did not know
and were any of the road captains or
other trucks that were part of your
convoy were any of them to your
knowledge dispatched to Windsor not to
my knowledge no
now earlier this morning you were
showing a tick tock video uh where
you're talking about let's let's hit
them presuming the federal government
where it hurts and I like to paint some
clarity from you on on that statement so
in this case when you say let us hit
them us in this case you're referring to
the Convoy and its supporters is that
correct yes against the mandates
and in terms of where it hurts
was one of those places you were you
were referencing the Ambassador Bridge
or were you focused exclusively on
attending a protest in Ottawa
exclusively attending the protests in
Ottawa perfect and so to the best of
your knowledge
did any of the core organizers of the
freedom Convoy attempt to establish any
kind of slow role or any type of
blockade in Windsor for the purposes of
impeding border traffic no not to my
knowledge
so is it then fair to say that from your
perspective
blocking ports of Entry or impeding
traffic at any Port of Entry whether
that's in in Windsor or in Sarnia was
not an objective of the Convoy
organizers yeah we had nothing to do
with Windsor that was uh as far as I
know they had more issues at those
border crossings from what I watched on
the on on social media lives
it wasn't it wasn't the same thing as
what we were doing here
okay and when were you first made aware
that the demonstration at The Ambassador
Bridge had been cleared by police
I don't remember recall when I don't
know the story there I didn't pay enough
like I said it was so busy here I didn't
have time to pay attention to anywhere
else
fair enough okay thank you very much
those are my questions
thank you and uh for the Convoy
organizers
foreign
ER Miller how are you I'm very well for
the record Brennan Miller appearing as
Council for the
freedom Corp which is the entity that
represents the protesters including
yourself uh that were in Ottawa in
January and February of 2022. uh good
morning how you feeling feeling good
thank you very much great so first
question
if at any time during the protest and
the demonstration if the city of Ottawa
the Ottawa Police Service provided you
the truckers and the protesters in the
order from a court saying that you had
to leave or move your trucks out of
downtown Ottawa what would you have done
a court order I would assume we would
have left yes yeah
and I understand you've and
we've had discussions and you've had
discussions with legal counsel you
understand what invoking the riot act
now means do you not approximately yes
and so if a mayor shared for justice
invoked the riot act and ordered that
you and the protesters and the trucks
left downtown
Ottawa what would you have done
instructed people to leave
as fair to say as Chief slowly testified
at no time did any police officer or
city official come and tell the
protesters that they were illegally
parked and illegally unlawfully
protesting and had to leave is that fair
not to my knowledge at that point my
truck was out of the city I had I had no
equipment here okay
so my friend asked you about the
memorandum of understanding drafted by a
Mr James bouter and his Canada Unity
organization I have a few questions
about that
so these Canada Unity folks to your
knowledge how many of them were in
Ottawa
uh hard to say I I honestly don't know
James batter was the only one at the
time that I knew there was different
people I think representing him okay so
how many Canada Unity folks did you
interact with that you knew were
representing him
I believe none
okay I believe none
and
Did You observe Mr bowder or anyone else
that may have been with Canada Unity to
be violent and commit any violent acts
no sir okay and did you hear of any of
these Canada Unity members act in a
violent way or try to incite violence no
did you hear any of these Canada union
members State they wanted to overflow
the government of Canada by violent
means I never heard anything
and I take it that you asked your
lawyers in Ottawa at the time being
Keith Wilson and Eva chippyuk about this
memorandum of understanding from Canada
Unity is that right
I don't recall having a conversation
with them I believe
it might have been a conversation in in
the in the group of people together that
uh it had no bearing and it wasn't to be
looked at it was it was it was
essentially nothing do you remember the
lawyers describing it as legal nonsense
yes I do yes okay
and
I also understand of course you've had
some interactions with Mr Pat king
um and as well as some of his followers
how many followers did Mr King have
I think Pat had a national uh following
on on Facebook I believe what do I mean
physically in Ottawa oh
there was a few absolutely there was a
few how would you use a bit of a weasel
word do you mind if I uh you can clarify
what number would you estimate
there are so many people here
um so many people with with every
different background I I would I don't
even know if I could guess Mr Miller
okay and did you observe Pat king or any
of his followers carry out any acts of
violence I did not no and did you hear
Pat king or any of his followers and
cite protesters in Ottawa to commit acts
of violence no
did Pat king or any of his followers
ever state to you that they're going to
physically and violently overthrow the
government of Canada never no and what
about this Jeremy McKenzie fella uh did
you ever hear of him seeking that
protesters act violently or incite
people to commit violent acts no Jeremy
McKenzie or any of his followers or
veterans that you know of uh say that
they were going to physically and
violently overthrow the government of
Canada none
and lastly of course Miss Tamara Leach
how's your relationship with Miss Leach
definitely strained over the last uh
however many months it's been with a
court order against us contacting each
other so yeah um I met her I spent
approximately a month where I got to
know her quite well she's a genuine a
good person and uh and then I only get
to see her now through legal counsel so
someday maybe we'll fix that no no I
take it did how tall is Miss Leach
pretty close to [ __ ] Heights like yeah
she's about a [ __ ] and I'm not even
gonna look at her but she's I take it
she's still a very scary lady is she not
it's the short ones you really have to
worry about well yeah like Napoleon
absolutely absolutely so she's the the
Napoleon of truckers is that fair
all right now did uh the Napoleon of
truckers misleads did she ever say to
you that she intended to carry out an
act of violence while she was in Ottawa
I don't think she'd harm a butterfly I
know she would never say that right and
she I take it she also uh you never saw
her assault anyone to commit any violent
acts absolutely not and I take it uh she
never said to you that she was here in
Ottawa to violently take over the
government account absolutely not thank
you now my friends asked you uh some
questions about what I would refer to as
collusion with some of the other
protests that were outside of Ottawa
right so you had the big ones you had
Coots Windsor
um as well as the ones in Manitoba and
another one in Surrey uh to your
knowledge did any of the truckers or
protesters at all in all of Ottawa to
your knowledge have any coordination in
whatsoever in setting up these other
protests outside of Ottawa no they were
all uh as far as I understand they were
all organic movements right and you
heard the evidence from Chief stully and
as well as commissioner uh carreric they
speculated that it was possible that the
one protest in Windsor was coordinated
with Ottawa just based on the
geographical distance between the two
and the splitting of resources do you
have any comment on that I don't agree
with that assumption I I can't see being
how organic the movement was I honestly
I'd say we weren't smart enough to come
up with that idea
okay well it's it's that's a fine
admission now if uh
Mr register if you wouldn't mind putting
up document
hrf00052 it's the one that Canada
um for the Attorney General put to my
client earlier
now did you have a chance to review this
document before the questions that were
asked of you of the Attorney General
today
I don't believe I did can we just give
you a quick moment to do that
and so if uh Mr register if you could
scroll down there
so they're in just for summary for the
folks at home you have a heading with
Ottawa weather inspiration thoughts for
the day a video of Klaus Schwab
describing Trudeau's loyalty to the
world economic Forum A CTV poll on the
emergencies act which states that 81
percent of people disapprove of it uh
Financial supporters scrolling down
Quebec drops mandates
feds scrap pre-arrival PCR test British
Columbia drops capacity limits Bank Run
crypto Bank
the picture of
Madam Deputy Prime Minister another Al
Burton
and daily humor
yes do you see anything invoking
violence in that document I don't know
do you know of any of the documents that
are like that the daily briefings that
asked for violence
or sought violence I can't speak I I
don't think I read any of them but I
would say no there wouldn't have there
was never any talk of of it okay now I'd
like to bring up if I'm if I may miss a
registrar uh the other document that
Canada put up which is uh hrf000083
foreign
and you were it had Willows put to you
the video of Mr King Pat King was put to
you with respect to the bullets comments
and this was the media release I take it
uh that was released in response to that
the Deeds seemed pretty far apart for
that I believe the bullets comment was
earlier so I'm assuming
this was this was the day I was arrested
so I I haven't read this one okay
do you want to have a read
yes
yeah I I didn't review it at the time
but I've seen it now since
and I take it do you agree with those
statements therein
I do yes okay thank you and I also
understand that with respect to the
Daily security briefings the one that we
looked at earlier you aren't involved in
drafting any of these I was not no and
I take it you didn't review any of them
before they were sent out no sir all
right
all right now with respect to the
mandates and I just want to touch on
that briefly can you tell the commission
about how the mandates impacted your
children uh other than what you already
have with respect to uh your daughter's
uh clarinet story
we've got a 19 year old son Jonathan
um he was 18 at the time he's refused to
get the vaccine
um he's been around people with coveted
multiple times and he's yet to catch it
for some reason so
he's going off his natural immunity he's
uh he's a very strong-willed guy I don't
know where he gets that from
he uh he refuses to get it and I stand
behind him on that
okay
and what else anything else other than
what you've already said my parents
um
my father received his second dose of
his and it could be
together not is gallbladder quit working
on him and I watched my father
deteriorate quite badly he's fine now
but still you lose that body mass you
don't seem to get it back at 70 years
old so okay now I want to move on from
that and talk about some of the moving
of the trucks I understand at some point
in the protest in Ottawa you moved your
trucks from Wellington or your truck out
of the city uh to a remote Camp yes when
was that February 7th my best
recollection okay
and is it true that when you were trying
to leave downtown Ottawa that the police
Road box made it very hard for you to
leave
it was very tricky yes there was
roadblocks everywhere
um so can you describe for the
commission your initial moving your
truck and trying to get out of downtown
Ottawa and just sort of walk us through
in a timeline
it was February 7th I believe I was
parked in front of the supreme Supreme
Court so
they still didn't really know my way
around Ottawa that well at that time so
I remember going down whatever street
would have been near there lion or or
somewhere in there
um it was tough it was hard to navigate
your way back out of there and then make
sure you're on the right street that was
heading the right direction So
eventually I made my way out of the city
it was tough
and how did you get past the barricades
and the blockades uh you had to get a
police approval to move every single
barricade there was a police car there
was when we first arrived in Ottawa the
city officials used payloaders graders
and trucks
to block Industries for
safety concerns or whatever it was they
did and then uh when the snowfall came
the first snowfall came I remember they
they removed all that and they replaced
them with concrete barriers and then a
police car would sit at each barrier in
the center and would be able to move to
allow traffic to go through so and to
your knowledge was there any incidence
of any of the truckers and protesters
trying to leave but could not no no no
if somebody needed to leave we would
facilitate that no matter what we uh and
what I mean is is with respect to moving
the police barricades oh
no it was it was a job to get somebody
out of the city but nobody ever was out
of troubles it wasn't forced to stay if
you're meeting that sounds good
and with respect to you walking the
streets during the protest what did you
see
life-changing
um yeah it was it was amazing there was
so much
grown men crying on your shoulder women
crying on your shoulder grandmas
Grandpa's you name it kids
um
it was really it was really and it is an
experience Unforgettable is there
anything notable that you remember of
who you spoke to
who I didn't speak to
um it was everybody you couldn't I
remember Mr marazzo when I went for a
walk and Mr Wilson and uh it was like he
uh Mr Wilson explained it is like
walking down the street with Mick Jagger
he said because no matter where you went
there was somebody wanting to stop and
talk with you it was
it was a lot of a lot of love
and can you tell us about the efforts to
move the trucks on Monday February 14th
frustrating
we had all those trucks ready to go
seven o'clock in the morning we'd spoke
with them the night before on the Sunday
we had the streets lined up we had
everybody all placed we had uh
organized trucks to come I don't
remember the block it was right in front
of parliament on the pretty much on West
block
we were able to uh we get them all
organized all warmed up and then we
couldn't get anybody to move the police
wouldn't move the city officials you
could tell by my text messages with Kim
that it was uh it was frustrating we
were we were ready to go and and we were
we were deprived time to get things
going so at that point in time the
police block hated you from leaving yeah
even though you were trying to leave
we were trying to the truck I don't know
if the truck's leaving had trouble as
much trouble as the trucks trying to get
up onto Wellington that was what my
focus was my focus was only getting the
trucks on the Wellington other guys
looked after the ones that wanted to
leave the city so from where the trucks
were parked did the police move the
barricades to allow you out
I'm assuming so I didn't take part in
the actual leaving like I said my focus
was the trucks on the Wellington okay so
you were up at Wellington at that time
and you weren't down where the trucks
were trying to get out of yes okay
and I understand during that time that
you were able to get approximately 100
trucks and protest vehicles to leave
downtown residential areas which
included 40 semi-trucks of which 23 went
up to Wellington is that fair yes
and you were aware that the vehicles
that left downtown and did not go up to
Wellington they were either went home or
they went out to a base camp in Arne
prior or enbrun is that fair yes
and so you had cleared out two blocks on
Albert Street and from some other
streets is that about right in the time
we were allotted we cleared out the two
blocks we had plans to clear out more
you just hold on a minute yes um
it's David mijikovski for the record I
did not object initially but I do
understand that the rules of the
commission do not allow counsel for the
parties to cross-examine and my friend
has been cross-examining on several
locations this is a matter of some
contention so I would just ask that his
questions be phrased in a non sure
that's not a problem
um so can you tell me about uh then how
many trucks uh do you believe were moved
in total
I was told a hundred drugs 100 vehicles
uh approximately 40 trucks 23 of which
we moved up on to Wellington
and while you were involved in the
protest and in Ottawa did you attend any
businesses in downtown
many frequented the Tim Hortons for
meals we we frequented any restaurants
that were open
um any business that I was in the iconic
Cafe was another one Shawarma any
business that we were in flourished they
did really well then they said a lot of
a lot of the businesses said they hadn't
profited so much in the last two years
as they did in the in that three weeks
and during that just adding to it what
was your relationship like with those
business establishments their staff and
owners during the protest
I remember the Tim Hortons on on one of
the corners there truckers were mopping
the floor because the staff was overrun
and uh and guys said the mob pale out
and they were cleaning the floors of
course it's winter time sloshy and
disgusting floors
pretty proud to see that and did any of
the business owners approach you before
the end of the protest about anything
they wanted to say to you
not that I recall no
and I take it you've seen throughout
this preceding Witnesses discuss views
on assaultive or threatening behavior
and what that means you've seen that
apparently yes
now I understand that you heard a
statement from the Prime Minister where
he called unvaccinated Canadians racist
misogynists and asked should we tolerate
these people
do you remember hearing that I remember
hearing that yeah
what's your perception of that would you
say in your opinion is that assault over
threatening just
let's be careful again you've got the
understood
what was your perception of that
statement a very divisive for a for a
leader of a country to be pitting one
person in the country against the other
person I would say I felt you know not
very leadership worthy and have you
experienced assault of and threatening
words and behavior from other
politicians or others
I've seen some of the news reports I
guess yeah there's a few
um not that I can recall
um not that I can recall the names of
the ministers but there's been a few
well thank you those are my questions
thank you
okay any re-examination uh yes
commissioner um a few a few points of uh
clarification based on some of the
answers you provided Mr barber in
response to uh questions from Council
for former Chief slowly uh you indicated
that uh in your efforts to speak to the
protesters at Rito Sussex you said I
think uh you spoke to them and you said
they had a point do you recall that yes
do you remember what their point was I
don't remember what their point was they
no there was a barrier a language
barrier there because there were French
Canadians so my my French is I don't
speak French so I had a hard time
understanding them
and uh when Mr champ was uh asking you
questions I thought I heard you mention
that uh Miss belton's group was one of
the groups that was handing out cash do
did I hear that correctly there was sort
of a riff sort of a split between the
two groups Miss belton's yeah when we
heard the 500 versus the two thousand
dollars
um that was Miss Bridget's
um was trying to the group people that
were donating or passing out two
thousand dollars instead of the five
hundred dollars did Miss belton's group
have a label
I don't think so no okay and how many
people were in Miss belton's group uh I
I that I can't say 10 15.
and then again in response to questions
from Mr champ uh you mentioned a Mr
Borgo yeah okay can you do you know Mr
Burgos first name Joseph okay and can
you just tell the commission a bit more
about what Mr BOGO was doing in your
interactions with well Joseph Pergo is
is a um a good friend of mine he is a
business a big business owner in the
province of Saskatchewan
well-respected man and he offered his
services
to Mentor he spoke to me on a regular
basis just a protocol and advice and
a really good guy and what's he
providing financial support to the
protesters
well I think at first our bank accounts
were all like we had no money coming in
Gibson go or GoFundMe wouldn't release
any funds to us so we were financially
strapped for the amount of
hotels so
hopefully someday we can pay that back
and sorry I don't think I got the answer
there did Mr burgo provide financial
assistance he did yes okay
um and how did he provide financial
assistance with hotel rooms okay
um Miss uh Miss creuska from the ccla
was asking you about bank accounts that
were being frozen and I as I understood
the TD count you spoke about you said it
had been frozen for 3.5 months yes sir
do you know why it was frozen for that
to this day I still don't know I would
imagine it had something to do
um Miss Lynch
added my name to her Toronto Dominion
Bank where the funds the GoFundMe funds
went into for the for the GoFundMe the 1
million and then the e-transfer
for transparency she added myself to her
bank account so everything was out in
the open there was two sets of eyes
looking at it she was the biggest worry
for her was that somebody would accuse
her of
misusing funds which wasn't the case so
the TD Bank account you're referring to
that was an account that originally was
opened by Miss Leach I had a personal
Toronto Dominion so all she did was
merge the two
savings accounts so I could physically
see her savings account on my card
that's the only thing that I assume had
to do with why my bank account was
frozen for three and a half months so
you had a pre-existing TD account and
then missile each added you to the
account that she had created for the
purposes of getting the GoFundMe funds
yeah for the purposes of transparency so
that there was more eyes on that account
than just hers
and then my final area to examine is
we've we've heard a little bit uh more
about Confederation Park and major Hills
Park did you ever see Confederation park
or major Hills Park
I'm hoping I can this week I've never
seen it I I've only heard about it so
that'll be on my list to do after this
inquiry um do you know what use is made
of that Park I normally no idea those
are my questions thank you
okay
um I just have a couple of questions uh
the probably just uh
General in the sense of what would be
the cost of the fuel to have driven here
from Saskatchewan
so today's fuel prices uh roughly about
three thousand dollars probably in fuel
to come out here from Saskatchewan that
was quite the feat
okay and just one thing I wanted to
follow up on was the uh you were
one of your uh
main functions or certainly what you
were doing was to try and keep the
emergency lanes open yes sir and you
said there were some that you just
couldn't couldn't keep open and I think
you mentioned Rito is that Frito is the
hard one there was uh Rita was the one
we tried multiple times the other one
was somewhere on Kent I believe we tried
really hard to keep Kent open I remember
the first time we visited Kent we worked
all day we got that lane wide open and
we were so proud of ourselves we came
back the next morning and it was
completely plugged again we kind of we
kept working on them
so those are two areas where the the
lanes just
couldn't be kept open yes sir were there
other areas that uh you found uh either
you couldn't keep open or were regularly
uh
problematic
to my recollection everything was well
looked after other than those two areas
those were the only two two areas of
concern that I felt that I had troubles
with personally and the group of people
that I was with
and would would that be because they
were not among other things they weren't
part of your group is that or is it were
they part of your group some of them
yeah the read of Sussex was not part of
our original group they were there a day
or so before we arrived
Kent may have been I didn't recognize
all the trucks there was some encant
that was part of the original West group
I can confirm that yes
okay and uh that's those are my
questions so thank you very much for
coming thank you very much uh we'll uh
we will adjourn for the lunch break
we'll take an hour for lunch and come
back with another Witness
the commission is in recess for one hour
thank you
foreign
order a lot
foreign
foreign
stop it
find the process will play
a hospital
in the
um
because I'm just yourself
[Music]
responsibility
thousand procedure of uh civil criminal
cancer
a uh
results foreign
foreign
Mercy
mercies is
mother
foreign
anticipate
this is the clerk speaking of for the
record uh we do have the French version
available it's the doc ID for that is
s-a-e-60010.fr thank you
if you could please put that one up
thanks
wait
at budakovics
okay
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
interesting
[Music]
foreign
foreign
sexual
foreign
foreign representative
imaginative
foreign
foreign
foreign
Studio
hello
among the responsibility the
transparency
is
foreign
foreign
foreign
thank you
hello
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
pick up
okay
um
exactly
okay
legislative or Quebec
is
um
foreign
foreign
foreign
look glorial
excuse me
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Criminal
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
levels
um
we
can Eternal health
[Music]
it is no
uh
yeah
foreign
[Music]
without foreign
there are only
Paul McDonald Cartier
Vehicles is
[Music]
McDonald
s
um
foreign
foreign
exactly
foreign
no
foreign
[Music]
movement
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
if we can go to page two
oh sorry scroll up
and I see so I did the Ops has advised
that members of fafade are blocking
major intersections in the vicinity of
the blockade
and are being uncooperative with the
police
is
no worry about the
um
says that's ops85886
.
um
on episode the war memorial and I'll see
how fast
the Tomb of the Unknown Soldier says
foreign
[Music]
document thank you
um and I'll see if we scroll down
analysis at the approximately 200 people
scattered throughout different locations
on Wellington focal point of
demonstrators
focal point of demonstrator activity at
Sussex and Rito were a group known as
farvada from Quebec has completely
blocked intersection to vehicular
traffic falfa de group was uncooperative
with police throughout the day organizer
of the group indicated that they would
open the intersection if permitted to
move further up on Wellington towards
Parliament Hill
information passed on to PLT for further
contact
login
um
Cartier
no
okay
[Music]
Municipal I get to know
uh
you understand the living man we all
know yeah
foreign
salubis
um
Littleton
Leach
uh
[Music]
no
only on their group
is foreign
with the polo
the movement foreign
effectively
available
[Music]
no
if they Count Their truckers lost if
Nadu
let's give it
is
Quebec no
no the
um
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
Italian
San Andreas
um
foreign
movement
is
[Music]
popular
foreign
[Music]
Wellington
foreign
no
is your favorite
is
foreign
communication
is
my name is
the blog
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
virtual
is
we
um
Metallica OPP are set sys set
page 33.
at our schedule mode
um
foreign
J G Intel advised that according to
Israel
the group falfa de has handed 14 10 000
to Quebec truckers in Ottawa in the last
two days he also mentioned that an
additional ten thousand dollars will be
distributed to truckers today in Ottawa
as because it's exact
ly is that true I don't remember the
exact days but the exact amounts yes
this is money you receive through
electronic transfer or cash gift both is
the answer we had electronic transfers
that were gone through as someone else
of the movement and
when we had the booths for soup and
coffee we had voluntary contribution and
so they would put 20 in a pail and we
redistributed it
totally distributed more or less 24 000
more and more than that is the answer
can you tell us not exactly we're now
closing our account books on 31st of
October this is the end of our year for
the fact that but I couldn't tell you
exactly
question that money was redistributed to
getting into the people who needed it
people who had some needs yes is the
answer
during the three weeks we were there we
concentrated our efforts on what was
happening and casino and Ottawa that we
spread out in helping the families
throughout the province
question earlier today we talked about
the agreement you had with the parking
lot zibi and you mentioned the court
order in Junction
the owner of ZB parking lot with the
except your payment 100 no
1 000 a day
sorry yes
at one point that owner
stopped receiving your payment and asked
for an injection at the Superior Court
in Quebec could you explain that
well there were quite a few steps in
that negotiations we didn't go from
stopping the payment to injunction
directly
we realized that
he was not accepting the payment days
went by and we had other things to deal
with so we didn't deal with that we
tried to made up to make a payment every
day
and then the municipal the municipality
can plane the firemen came for two
inspections
we have retired firemen in our
organization that were the link between
our organization and the municipality to
follow the municipal recommendations
which is what we did
there was a lot of pressure more and
more pressure
to get rid of us
legally
but it didn't work because we were
trying to pay according to our original
agreement
we did exact thing we was asked to do
concerning the public safety fire fire
and so on that was respected and then
one day we received this injunction
to get us to leave
question the complaint by the city of
gatino
yes
what were the firemen
say when they were talking about the
security reasons safety reasons well
they came for an inspection and they
recommended to put the the fuel
somewhere to put extincter here and
there in the Strategic and they
inspected the wood stoves and they made
recommendations which we followed
respected
very logical
questions so you follow this and despite
that there was an injunction
the court
it was the 15th of February when the the
court looked at this injection so you
moved to Notre Dame Parish
is right now no that's not that's not
I went like I come I went to court
through internet no but the group that
was at the Zippy parking lot where did
they move after the injunction when we
left
well I couldn't say that it wasn't I'm
not from that area but we went to a
parking lot in the church
that was offered to us by the person
responsible for this church
until the next day because he was asked
to tell us to move on which we did
question
so you were in contact with someone from
the parish and over the past three weeks
they were collecting food to distribute
to the people of get to know
well
I don't want to cause any trouble
to this person since we're supposed to
be in camera maybe I could talk about is
this person
couldn't fulfill its mandate in society
because of the covid measures so this
person could not welcome the get you
know homeless and feed them because of
covid measures because of the fact that
most of the homeless were not vaccinated
did not have their vaccine passport
couldn't go to the church
and get hot meals so he had excess food
and he said instead of seeing it going
to waste I will send you the food and
send you the homeless and that's what we
did we fed them
so you remained in that parking lot one
evening and did you leave on February
18th
I think that's the right date
can someone tell me what was
the date
the Sunday when Parliament was
dismantled
I'm not sure but
we have a document that states that she
left on February 18th okay I will trust
you that's probably right
so question that was a few days after
the invocation of the emergency Allowed
by the government that was February 14th
and the measures put in place under this
act did it have any effect on you
personally answer no question was your
bank account Frozen answer yes yes it
was first of all restricted when you
asked me if there were any impact I said
no because I don't remember going to
Ottawa after this act was put in place
we took care of our
settlement and we just observed what was
going on so physically speaking didn't
have any impact on me but yes I started
having problems with my bank Network
well first of all the National Bank
restricted my privileges quote unquote
reduce the amount I could withdraw on a
daily basis so they
cut a lot of the Privileges I had
acquired over my 30 years as a client of
the national bank first and then
around mid-april I received a letter
telling me that mid-may they would close
my accounts because they did not want to
do business with me anymore that's what
they did
question saw your account there were
restrictions on your account and that
lasted until mid April or mid-may and
Sir until they closed my account
question what impact did this have on
your capacity to use your money
answer well you know what it is to live
in 2022 without a bank account it is
almost impossible
it was very hard and even today if I try
to open an account in another bank I
will have the same restrictions as a
beginner where as I've been a client of
the same bank for 30 years with those
privileges today I lost those privileges
I have to go elsewhere question so when
your account was closed by the national
bank mid-april or mid-may the only
reason they gave you was because of your
involvement in the freedom comfort and
sir no they gave no reason
same as my friends they just said that
our business relationships were
terminated we tried to ask questions and
they did not want to answer
that's the case with some people I know
who participated to the same events
so two plus two is four question there
uh bank accounts were closed permanently
answer yes question
it was it mid April or mid-may as well
or was it in February answer all the
same dates
okay
so you went back home on the 18th and
then you went back to Van click Hill and
you were arrested by the police is that
right answer the weak following yes
question what were the counts
mischief and
um
counseling to Commitment Chief question
earlier you said that it was the first
time that you were arrested by the
police answer yes question what impact
did it have on your life
23 days in prison 10 days in isolation
it took me a month to uh get over it I'm
not a criminal I'm not used to the
Justice symptom I never did anything to
appear before the Justice now people
know me I'm recognized everywhere with
the hatred and the media I don't I don't
only have friends they are people who
judge us based on the opinion spread by
the media I'm not always in security I
never move around alone so that's what
happened
question you said you spent 23 days in
jail yes answer and if I was
released is because I had to abide by
some very strict conditions I cannot
express myself on the social media I
cannot be seen in the presence of some
people on Wellington Street it's the
same and there are more conditions
so that's part of the fundamental rights
to be able to express oneself in Canada
as far as I'm concerned but I lost this
right question do you have anything else
to add about the impact of the emergency
act on you before I move on to my next
questions answer yes when you started
with the examination you asked me if I
had been the witness of violence and yes
I witnessed Violence by a group called
antifa that vandalized Vehicles during
the night to damage or to harm the
manifestation and I was the witness of
Violence by the police and I don't know
who are those mercenaries who had no
number on their uniforms they couldn't
be identified and most of them did not
speak our language and they were violent
to dismantle that peaceful protests with
women children and the elderly eye was
the witness of that violence and I had
never witnessed any violence in any
protest and I also spoke with residents
of Ottawa and I can assure you that
everything you heard in the media is to
[ __ ]
foreign
please yes I understand this is
emotional I understand please respect uh
that this is uh in the nature of a
hearing and
outbursts like that may
require that I empty the hall which I
don't want to do
because it's a public inquiry and it's
important that people be here to witness
it
thank you Mr commissioner
I'm sorry says uh
if I is responsible for this well you
can express yourself freely I'm
responsible for a discipline
thank you you giving me my right to
speak and that feels good that's the
goal says the commissioner
I cannot believe that in Canada in a
peaceful country
with peaceful protesters that a
protest is dismantle where people just
want to be heard in that way I know
people today who are in Exile in Mexico
and in Cuba because they cannot stand to
see what is happening in our country it
makes no sense we've always said that we
live in a free and peaceful country and
the protests were always conducted in a
peaceful Spirit if it had not been the
case I would not have gotten involved I
never got involved in any protest
managed by and On In The Name Of
Violence not before not today and what
the police force did is really
disgusting people were harmed wounded
cayenne pepper was used we were evicted
before that maybe that's a good thing
but it's awful what happened on the hill
just that just because the government is
not willing to have a dialogue engage in
a dialogue with us when we ask for that
thank you question I'm almost done I
have two quick questions were you in
contact or in communication with
protesters or organizers involved in the
blockade of the border and Enterprise
Emerson in Manitoba and Windsor the
Ambassador Bridge
answer no
question thank you Mr Sharla that's it
for my questions is there anything else
you would like to say to the
commissioner something that maybe you
did not have the opportunity to say
today answer yes
yes
apart from those events apart from all
the protests
that took place in our country after
more than 30 years being actively
involved in politics as a citizen of the
people with the people who want to try
and get involved with the citizens and
the people of this country who I find
really awful and terrible is that one
day your ancestors who were elected
wrote the Canadian Constitution and the
Chargers of Rights and freedom
for Quebec and the other provinces
at the outset I can't believe that we
are given a charter to explain
what we're allowed to do
you gave us Charters you gave us tools
to explain to us what we're allowed to
do and not do
that is an aberration I believe that is
ludicrous and today in 2020 do we have
to stand up we have to neglect our
families we have to neglect our jobs we
have to neglect our houses neglect our
life because we all pay the price all
this to ask you to do your work again to
make sure that the Canadian Constitution
and the Chargers of Rights and Freedom
are complied with I don't understand how
come things have gone so Orient our
country I've always been proud to live
here in this country because it was a
democracy and apparently at peace we've
always had a place to speak up
peacefully and we've lost this if this
commission does not
agree with us no one in this country
will have the right to protest those who
are against my opinion and the others
the media created the left and the right
I don't even know what that means I'm
of the people and I want to stand up so
that the people can keep on standing up
and be heard left right up down I don't
give a damn
it's become the people against the
elected officials
who are managed by
multinationals by money by other powers
and that makes no sense in a quote
unquote
evolved Society in 2022 how come we have
to demand that our Charters are
respected otherwise we are put in jail
because we offered soup and coffee to
people who were in need
I will keep on saying this during my
trial if I'm accused of Mischief for
what I did a lot of people in this room
should also be in jail
thank you Mr Shalom thank you for your
time that's it for my questions
my friends and my colleagues will have
questions for you
so I will turn it over to them thank you
thank you
this is Mr commissioner suffers the
Canadian government
I'm part of the team of councils
representing the government of Canada
before this Commission
do you represent the government or the
Liberals
I represent the government of Canada Mr
shalom
I just want to clarify something
your movement you call it farfada with
two A's at the end but you pronounce it
answer depends on who pronounces it I've
always said I'm a fafade
yeah
answer okay I will follow your examples
so I will say fafade
one of the distinctive signs and you
mentioned that you sold a lot of items
with the Fafa DE logo one of the signs
is the black leather jacket the
sleeveless jacket that you we wear over
other pieces of clothing and they are
some
um
some badges
our crests
right answer yes yes you have to speak
up
question there is a transcription at the
end of all the
proceedings answer while I'm used to
shutting ma'am out now so I'm sorry
question okay the badges let's talk
about the badges correct me if I'm wrong
but typically there is a blue flor de
lis on the chest on the right side right
there is the signature badge in the back
there's a big big badge a half moon
shape and it says
but with a a right answer yes question
below
on the back of the black leather jacket
there is another badge in the shape of a
finger right and inside of the finger
it's written f u
we answer
answer we say [ __ ] you I'm not saying it
to you but
question you personally
some people add other badges their name
so on on their jacket
and you had the word laxis on the chest
and on the side you had the badge saying
Chef Guru answer yes
question as you say so use the the
movement sells different items to
collect money they are various
iterations of those items close answer
I'm sorry do you have questions about
the jackets because
we only had
discussions question yes that was the
idea so pieces of clothing uh
accessories with um f logo embroidered
on the items t-shirts anything else
answer well there's been so many
some people took care of the Fafa
Boutique for a while question more
specifically for the Ottawa Convoy did I
understand that you had
um
what struck
Charles made that you wore around your
neck here personally regularly did you
have those made like the one you're
wearing today the um the scarf so it was
black with the badge on nato in front it
was upside down Maple Leaf right and so
yes one side blue one side red answer
for the Flor delis and the maple leaf
yes and a question within the the maple
leaf we could see Upside Down symbol of
a fleur-de-lis answer yes question there
was also
um
Hearts chicks you sold those we see them
often on the internet and social uh
media
[Music]
that is a sentence that you liked you
said that you tried not to watch cable
and so well that's what I said some
people liked it uh question yes so you
sold a lot of Turk with the coupla cup
cut the cable written on it and tooks
with a f logo also those were popular
and so yes question we saw during the
protest in Ottawa many times that you
created your own flag
in inspired by the Patriot flag answer
yes question with a horizontal line a
green white and red and you put on top a
fafade
a
a little Leprechaun dressed in blue that
says hi answer well it says salute
question yes which is another of your
signature phrases in the social media
answer well you did your homework I can
see that
second night but I'm starting to
know you so the flags you brought a few
right in Ottawa with you because we saw
them often in your Publications on the
social media you or other members of the
movement of the movement answer yes
and we spoke about the social media
up until it was forbidden you were
present mainly on Facebook you posted a
lot of videos
um live videos as we call them answer
yes question you're calling your
signature uh Colin was called Dominic
and so yes you posted many uh answer
until 2017 I've been posting those
question and since 2017 okay
specifically during the Comfort but even
before the Convoy you were involved in
several protests
to denounce the sanitary measures am I
right am I mistaken answer no denounce
the sanitary measures
I'm trying to fight for
freedom and Truth
question you to part and protests
Associated to with denouncing the
sanitary measures in Quebec answer yes
um foreign
ERS were recruited to ensure Safety and
Security during some meetings
no we don't recruit anybody people come
to us and they find what they can do for
us
and you'll convene with me
is that in the past so at meetings who
we have seen people who were
wearing the vest or sweater with
farfetter to ensure safety and and there
was a case in Quebec
where people showed up against Health
measures and several favor members
whether you can tell me what you saw
because I was there myself
do you recognize this event no you
haven't given me all the details that
you're telling me what you read in the
media but the media reported and I mean
that forefather had some interaction
there
and there were people wearing your name
what is it that you call interaction
first of all
I should understand
that this is a contentious event for you
you're not in agreement with what was
reported no because it didn't happen
that way
or at the National Assembly
but you mentioned
that you had interaction with someone
who called you at the beginning of the
Convoy
men who
was mentioning safety as a goal yes I
already answered that
yourself on January 9th
asked for further to take care of the
parking safety yes
and then on Facebook on January 31st you
said that the parking lot was insecure
and if it is we will have to call
farfada uh what we say between ourselves
is when you feel insecure called farther
but this is what you did on January 31st
yes indeed
I talked before
and in just a minute I
in your
testimony you talked about the money
that you were handing out to the
truckers in Ottawa
and you mentioned the rules that were
applicable
how much you should be getting and
keeping and or giving away
for further members who are not
considered to be a welfare organization
and you haven't set up a welfare
organization to
hand out the money you were when I had
the funding I did it myself and
everything is up to date
you
have met several newsmen who when you
were around the Convoy you know at the
wall
you gave
[Music]
a
reply to 547 in
Ottawa in got to know that came up in
the morning
do you recall that the newsman who was
asking you details
what will it take for you to take off
what is needed for you to hook up your
trailer and leave other one you recalls
anything like this yes it's a bit vague
though
well we'll try to make it a bit clearer
it will look at a recording
that ends by 6 0 12.
and ask Alaska to take you start this at
15 minutes 12 seconds
I hope it's not going to take too long
because your time is almost over yet
well I'll go beyond that then
and hit another question
thank you
in Ottawa and you got to know
are you
were saying that people must hold the
line and it means that the truckers had
to remain on Wellington yes and this is
where you started to give money out to
help out truckers yes
and hold the line
who was spread till February 14th yes
and particularly
as regards the Dorito Sussex
intersection the farthest is very often
would not allow the vehicles to travel
through
and um uh
I've I've answered this question already
three times
at this
is an identifiable group with their
motorcycle jackets is
simply
uh
maybe I could give you a helmet here
it's a bit difficult the farfeather
would meet consistently uh Davido and
Sussex
the forefathers
were the the regular vest or
[Music]
if this is not necessarily the truth
I think it's not the case for everyone
but indeed you had a leather vest with
farfada that could be easily identified
easy to identify and motorcycle are two
different things
but I I still don't understand why you
are bringing this to talk about
motorcycles
we have motorcycles but most
firefighters don't have any
and there she was just to explain when
the police says
a group known as farfata from Quebec has
completely blocked intersection to
vehicle vehicular traffic
uh farfata was uncooperative with police
throughout the day LA police
are they still wrong
the only thing I understood was so
sexier and riddle we've talked about it
already six times I'm sorry about that I
took it for granted that you could
understand
things in English because many extracts
were presented in English
the idea for a riddle in Sussex he
already answered about it about 15 times
already so I don't think it's a pretty
good use for the additional time to
repeat the questions hoping to get a
different answers
thank you very much the last series of
questions it's going to be very short Mr
commissioner
I want to confer
I want to confirm a few points here
Mr marazzo you don't know him and you
don't know anything about the
understanding he had with the city for
trucks and reduces sakes but on February
14th
you know if you're not aware either
of the hearing
of what Chris Barber did in order to
move the trucks around the 14th no no no
I'm not aware of this
what I do understand is that on February
14th on Facebook you publish the text
and it says that there was no
understanding between the
Ottawa truckers and awarenament the
government there was no greed I wasn't
aware of the agreement anyway if any
but you on February 14th you published
on your Facebook page saying there is no
understanding between the truckers and
the government that's what I had been
told indeed
Quebec uh trucker that we talked to
and
you said the far for the issue is not
solved at this time
it means we need the assistance from our
members you're talking about GB and the
the trucks that are inaudible last
question
to clarify what was said earlier
and you mentioned
that your
apprehension on
in January 31st was the first time I was
already apprehended way back but this
was uh totally forgiven
if you're not being accused for a
Mischief for blocking streets or roads
on LaFontaine well I have to go to court
but I was never apprehended for that yes
there are accusations Maybe
I'm not really accused
we haven't been to court yet you haven't
been condemned yet but for something
that happened in January 20s
third your
spouse
were also members of farther
and this took place on March 13th
uh 2021 thank you Mr commissioner for
the
additional length of time I have no
further questions
thank you have a good day
the Convoy
organizers
our next
I'm just going to say no questions in
French Messi
okay
no questions in French
and the Ottawa Police Service
yes
all right
foreign
can you hear me
good afternoon my name is Jessica Barrow
and I'm counsel for the Ottawa Police
Service I just have a couple of
questions for you
um I believe you've went over this a
couple of times but just to be clear you
were not at the intersection of Rito and
suffix at any time during the course of
the events is that fair
foreign
voices together
it
makes it more interesting
I'd like to get the French translation
okay
because
they all talk English
are we there we go
thank you
so I think I have the answer to this
question now multiple times but just to
be clear since you didn't perhaps
understand my full question uh the
previous time uh you yourself were never
at the intersection of Frito and Sussex
throughout the events of the Convoy is
that correct
of course because we visited a lot of on
several occasions so I must have walked
through there at one time I don't recall
anything about it but I must have walked
through the street right there and
I think was your evidence correct
no
no I didn't you wouldn't have any
first-hand knowledge of the behavior of
the protesters that were at that
intersection
no no
didn't necessarily have control over who
may have identified themselves as
members of ferfata is that correct
no
I as I said earlier in another reply uh
yeah I can't figure out what happens
everywhere with everyone
and do I have it correct that you were
not downtown Ottawa on February 18th
and for the weekend that followed the
February 18th
we said the exactly yes indeed I wasn't
Ottawa we were moving around at the time
I I don't even recall if I went back to
Ottawa after February 14th I don't think
I was there at all
after the new legislation was
implemented
uh on the 18th I wasn't there that's for
sure okay
okay firsthand knowledge then as to the
arrests that occurred on February 18th
to 20th
in downtown Ottawa
no
I wasn't there
more specifically you don't have any
firsthand knowledge of the behavior of
police officers in the course of those
arrests
no specifically for this apprehension
but we listen to the media the media
we're on the Spot somewhere in Ottawa I
don't know for sure but they talked
about it but in terms of first-hand
knowledge or observations you don't have
any of that is that correct
no
no I didn't
it's on the part of the police if I were
to tell you that no disciplinary and or
criminal charges were filed in relation
to members of the Ottawa Police Service
would you have any information to the
contrary
if I was to accuse myself I might know
about it but it wasn't me it was
mentioned by the media I might have
heard a few things from my friends I
know that some people were expelled from
their vehicles
we have seen a great many things in the
media
have seen what happened on the TV I
wasn't there myself
when you were referring them to violence
on the part of the police you're
referring either to conversations with
friends or to things you've seen in the
media but not to any first-hand
observations
indeed I wasn't on the spot myself okay
thank
you
we'll see
[Music]
the Provincial Police
foreign
with audio we can't hear you
so we're done
is it going to be in English or French I
don't know I can't hear him
it's it's a it's a it's on mute
yeah
okay so I'm not sure what
can you hear me now yes
I apologize for the inconvenience with
my audio
um it's Christopher Diana on behalf of
the opp doing this virtually for the
first time and so I apologize for the
inconvenience so I have no questions
this afternoon thank you commissioner
silver play please
it's this is not
a theater
please I was extremely patient and
frankly if I have to I will empty this
room you can watch it from somewhere
else in the video room and I know that
that's not what you want
but
I insist that there'll be some
discipline in this room
to cooperate
if it happens I'm going to have to ask
everyone to leave and you will still
watch it from the room by video and I
know that's not what's wanted
but that's what I'm going to do this is
a serious matter it's the equivalent of
a court
and I think everyone wants a certain
amount of respect for the process
next time
Council for Mr slowly
good morning Mr Charlotte
um Stefano I'm the lawyer for the
Mr chief of police and I want to have a
few small questions for you
you testified that you had a lot of
experience with the protest movement how
many how long has it been since you've
been involved in these movements
my first participation directly always
in a conference in 1992 where we were
talking about free trade
and I took part directly at that level
and I've been involved since so you took
part in quite a few demonstrations yes
as a member of la mode in before yes
before that yes and other
manifestational demonstrations with the
father yes
you took part in some demonstrations
with the
sanitary demonstration in the past well
I mean before the freedom Convoy yes
is the answer question when you get to
to get to know on January 29th
was it is it true to say that you
noticed that there was an atmosphere or
a different type of support than with
the previous demonstrations you took
part in
no different no the atmosphere has
always been quite good in our
demonstration we've always had a very
good relationship with police forces we
dealt with
well I left the question in a different
manner
is the the importance of this was much
bigger than other demonstrations and so
yes that was without any precedent but
just something to have never seen before
yes
yes something that I haven't seen before
you questioned you even testified I
didn't notice exactly but encouraged me
if I'm wrong but you were surprised by
the support that your group received
when you were going to Ottawa
and so yes we were pleasantly surprised
yes because we realized that how many
people were behind this Movement we
don't see that too often and they were
ready to
help us with the food wood or whatever
was needed we got a lot of support
question so you'll agree with me that
you did not yourself expect
such support in so many people and so
much so many resources and January 29th
and sir absolutely question when you got
to get you know negotiate with the CMP
to go through Ottawa you mentioned that
the answer yes a question you also
discussed with the getting a police
services
in French I spoke I speak a little bit
of the English but I prefer to use my
mother tongue to make on myself
understand understood
when you negotiated with the RCMP
members you said that you wanted to go
to Ottawa to for for a peaceful
demonstration and so yes question once
in Ottawa were you aware of any
um exaggeration not necessarily by
members of your group but by the various
demonstrators and so no
in the city was a quite clean people
were getting together it was like a
feast all the cultures were getting
mixed up it was quite festive
question
no lack of respect towards the Ottawa
people and so no no intimidation answer
no
could we see PB MSC
c-a-n62000 89.
um
information
PB NSC
can
six zeros 89
and can we zoom in on the that
screenshot of the Facebook post please
in
starting this is a document that was
produced by the RCMP
concerning the police forces we see an
excerpt on Facebook
document
can we blow it up so we can see it
unfortunately the person the name of the
person who was
um
deleted uh it was um
in Black when blackened
redacted
first of all as you've seen this yes
you're the one who wrote this yes so you
show that there's only one Authority and
this is with the father
I know that I was not a good example in
the past recently but I apologize for it
you say that you were not an example of
respect recently was this
about the
Ottawa discussions no no that was
because of our internal discussions
we've heard quite a few testimonies
saying that they were disrespectful
Behavior violence and so on or you're
aware and so no not from us
so the question a couple of other small
questions you testified I don't have the
exact uh quote but that you did not have
the control over all the far Friday
because it was a movement though then
the control group the answer we tried to
[Music]
deal with the prophet that we're there
but we cannot control or we're gonna be
around all the members of the fafade
when they were getting no listen you
agree with me then the developer are not
speaking in one voice
that they don't speak in one voice yes
indeed
so it would be impossible for the member
of a police service to negotiate with
you for the whole group for the whole
movement
in as much as possible I do try
but it would not be possible for you to
come up to an agreement with the police
in the name of all the members of the
farthest to leave Ottawa yes we've done
it
followed your directives no I don't
think so we left the parking lot we were
supposed to and everybody went home and
I know that there were still some people
who say that and they were still in
Ottawa
all right thank you very much
thank you
next
the residents of Ottawa
thank you commissioner
good afternoon Mr Charlotte
I'm the lawyer for the group of
residents and businesses in Ottawa
I will ask my question in English if you
don't mind
like Mr bober I come from Saskatchewan
and I don't speak very good fresh well
you're doing fine up to now
I just want to know uh you mentioned
Mr Shalon you testified earlier that uh
you had heard from Mr King or from
friends of Mr King that he wanted some
assistance for security is that right
we yes
uh do you know what he needed security
for what what why was he in danger why
would he require security
as from what I was told that he had been
threatened and he was nowhere to stay
because he wanted a very safe place to
for the night because he was threatened
uh by whom by the police
no not by the police but we don't know
by whom exactly on on social media
guys dangerous in downtown Ottawa at
that time is that fair to say
no no no it was not downtown he had not
arrived on Ottawa yet
I think it was one day before he arrived
to Ottawa he wanted to find a place to
stay outside of Ottawa
you assist him in finding a place where
he could stay safely
yes
I got him in touch with people from that
people that that area and they are the
one who that took care of that
then did you ever meet with him or speak
with him during the course of the
demonstration
no
attend at the um I'm sorry I'm not sure
it'll be called in French but the uh the
bikers Church in Vanier in Ottawa
no
I believe that no no
uh thank you Mr Shaman those are all the
questions I have
foreign
can you see me on the screen
yes
I wanted to ask my question by Zoom I'm
the lawyer for the career Association of
civil liberties
uh
all right I would like to ask questions
about the restrictions on your bank
accounts I understand
that the first you said that you are
going to the National Bank
was limit restricted these accounts were
restricted as true yes
did you have a personal and corporate
bank accounts with the National Bank
yes my personal account and the
corporate with my my spouse yes
uh both accounts be resisted they didn't
touch the corporate accounts only your
personal account yes because in my
personal account which I was also
dealing doing business with the top edit
that's where the money for the Fafa they
went yes
question
when was this restricted
oh do you have the dates
I think it probably is February 4th
because that's when we started having
problems and we asked somebody to else
to do it that I think it might be the
4th of February but I might be wrong
so you think it was the fourth of
February I think so
have you
have your accounts been restricted later
on after February 14.
no I received a letter in April saying
that they were closing my personal
account
question and that letter that you
received in April was from the National
Bank
yes
did you receive Communications before
that letter from the National Bank
concerning your account no
if you receive some Communications
concerning your account
from the RCMP no
did you receive information concerning
your account
from the analysis and declassification
and from Canada no
do you know and it
the reasons decides a letter from the
National Bank why your accounts were
restricted no people will get in touch
with me
in April
and I could never get an answer from
them I I don't know why they were
closing my account
if I had to separately used today you
don't have an account with the National
Bank
and you had to open an account with
another bank
or another popular case popular yes is
the answer
thank you very much Mr Charlotte those
were my questions
next democracy fund
this is if
no question for that witness thank you
Mr savior
no question thank you
all right
other questions
no question Mr commissioner thank you
very much
if I may ask one question briefly myself
just to end where we started
your account that was restricted that is
they reduced your limit
yes from a daily transaction limit I
think call it a Transit I couldn't
withdraw as much and I couldn't deposit
a check and withdraw the money
immediately all the Privileges I had in
the past for the past 30 years
and Commercial trading with them and
some were diminished or totally and
nobody talked to you it just happened
right
and
you mentioned
and maybe I misunderstood that's why I'm
asking the question
when you talk about violence you talked
about policemen
and you mentioned another group is it
antifa yes what is that
the antifa group The
exists everywhere in North America we've
talked about it within Lambert
these are people who are against
identity groups against groups such as
ours
and during the Ottawa events it was told
us by trackers who didn't know what it
was that would be with saying some
people said that the antifa was doing
all this
that they vandalized the things that the
good the tires and then they said it's
they're a protest group today but that's
not the same type as us
Jesus
have you yourself seen members of antifa
or activities by the groups of that
group
in your group no no I was not a witness
of this myself so these were reports
that you received about violence yes
you had the Winnebago is that right
answer yes question where was it parked
answer in the CB parking in gatino
question so you would commute to Ottawa
respond by foot
and question
what was your
I don't want to give you any title or
position but what was your role when you
went to when you commuted to Ottawa
answer I was called the spokesperson of
the movement questions so you were there
to represent the movement is that right
answer yes and question and your group
if I can call it group because
I'm not going to talk about Ruidoso sex
don't worry
so the group that you had
went up riddle but
is there an identification as to how far
they went on riddle answer the purpose
of our operations was to hold the
camp in the ZB parking to offer food and
shelter to the protesters and the people
who needed it we also had a food kiosk
on Wellington managed by fafade and we
took care of the truckers but the
members of the fafade movement were all
over the place it was a festive
atmosphere the you know we would meet
people all over the place so I'm sure
that they were faffade everywhere where
there were truckers questioned I know
I'm talking about when you cross the
bridge the McDonald County Bridge you
said that they uh diverted to Rideau so
you went as far as possible
answer yes question I'm trying to see
how we could figure out
how far did the group you were
associated with went
and sir it's hard for me to say I'm not
from here and I don't remember the
intersection per se but we went
behind the trucks who were parked there
the police escorted a
all the way there and they said it stops
there we can't go any further and we
left the truck owners there question
during that movement were you at the
head of the movement were you in a
vehicle or is it just hearsay when you
say what happened
answer I was part of the walk I was on
foot
question
I just want to confirm the interactions
that you might have had with the police
I'm not talking about those on the
bridge and I'm not talking about those
in gatino but
interactions or observations of the
police when you were in Ottawa
doing
I don't know what being a a spokesperson
PR
what interaction did you have with the
police answer
which is uh waved her hand and we said
hi we thank them for their service and
they thanked us for being peaceful and
that's about it question
okay good
so those were my questions thank you
very much for your testimony thank you
for
being here and you're free to go
thank you
now we're gonna go to our afternoon
break 15 minutes and then we'll be back
with our next Witness
for 15 minutes and come back with the
next step with
the commission is in recess for 15
minutes
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
give me
your mic's not on on yet the uh I'm
sorry okay go ahead the next witness is
uh Miss Bridget Belton who is here with
her legal representative Ms Jane Scharf
who I understands once wants to address
you
okay
um
scarf
it's your choice you can do it from
there or come up to the front as long as
you can be heard and recorded okay
um I have a few requests to make
at the outset bridge it needs more time
she's been allocated uh an hour it's an
hour and 15 minutes
she was one of the persons who initiated
the Convoy she participated all the way
through and she has a lot of information
about the organization uh element and
it's it's insufficient uh amount of time
so that's the first request the second
request is she has
um severe dyslexia
of sufficient time to deal with the the
numbering and documentation so we have a
person here uh Rebecca Shepard who has
her her documentation ready and she can
quote the numbers that need to be uh
advised about what to bring up
and also uh I want to request that I ask
the questions of my client because other
uh Witnesses are having their own
counsel asked questions
we find it unfair unreasonable to to for
her to have to uh structure her
statement according to questions given
by somebody that doesn't know her case
and I also want an opportunity
to question I would like to question
many different witnesses that were up
there but uh I I'm only asking at this
time to question Keith Wilson because
he's he's submitted
um a statement from an interview that he
did on October 20th and it discusses
James spouter and Bridget Baldo and they
need an opportunity to
question him about that information
and that's all the requests
and then I have two objections
the first objection is uh this Council
or sorry this commission was struck
under Section 63-1 and it requires
ordering Council which is the entire
cabinet and only it was only based on
the recommendation of Justin Trudeau so
that that is a problem considering he's
the subject of the inquiry and he's
calling it as well uh I'm I'm
understanding that Bill Blair set it up
so he chose the chose yourself and and
whoever
else
um is our significant
administrators in this process we find
that that's unreasonable considering
these are the people that are being
investigated so they should not be
setting up uh this process and the chair
should not have been somebody that was
selected from the liberal the liberal
Camp so to speak
and the other objection is uh
the inquiry is focusing on the grounds
whether there was sufficient grounds to
call the emergency Act
and this is I in my view moot because
the emergency Act was also not invoked
legally according to
section 17 1 which required an ordering
Council which would have been the entire
cabinet the only time the executive is
allowed to make ordering Council without
going through cabinet is in an emergency
so they had to at least initiate the
process through the cabinet that wasn't
done so all of this in my view seems
moot because if it wasn't legal out of
the gate there's
there's the main issue and that's it
well what good list
um we haven't had a list like that in
any case so uh let me let me uh try and
address them
um firstly you may not know but I'm not
in the liberal Camp I've been a judge
for 20 years so that's just a fact who
are you appointed by uh I was appointed
by the government as you know by the
liberal government I'm not I'm not here
to be cross-examined I'm sorry that's
not how it works so but I'm just giving
you a fact now having said that
you of course can object to what the
commission how it was set up that's
something I can't do anything about
that's something you would deal with in
the federal court and you're certainly
free to do that in fact I believe there
are other parties who are in the federal
court attacking the emergencies act and
uh I'm I believe there's also
someone in court today attacking one of
my uh one of the subpoenas so
that's something if you think I'm not
properly constituted obviously that's
something you can pursue with it there's
nothing I can do about that
in terms of your four questions uh
the objective here is to get the
testimony
that the public wants as to how this all
developed I think your client
is is we've heard was uh very involved
in it and
the commission would like to hear her
evidence
obviously how that's going to happen I
said earlier today you weren't here that
because of the
nature of these
questions and the nature of what
Witnesses like Ms Belton have I will be
flexible about time because ultimately
what we're after is getting a proper
representation from the people as to
what happened why it happened
so I can't I can't say more than that
except that that's what our objective is
and we will be flexible for time in
terms of help of course if she needs
help
that's something which quite frankly uh
were more than sympathetic about we want
the help needed
if she needs it to get the documents out
and to get the story out that's what
this whole commission's about
is about trying to get the information
out in terms of you questioning her of
course you can question her it's not it
it's provided in the rules it will just
come at the end and how long
you'll help guide us as to what's needed
our expectation is and and
commission Council if you have been
following the commission have been very
good to let the witnesses
tell their story because we're not here
to try and push one line or the other
I think if you were here for the earlier
Witnesses today they're here to tell the
story
commission Council will help bring it
out but of course you're entitled to as
belton's Council to make sure if we've
missed something to allow her to do it
um in in terms of
questioning other Witnesses
all I could suggest is at the end of the
day you speak to commission Council
as to issues that you think commission
should pursue because again same
objective whether it's this witness or
any other witness we want the story to
come out
so that's that's my best answer for your
questions your objections as I say I can
do little about them federal court might
be happy to deal with it might not I'd I
leave that to you so that's that's my
response I I'd like to be able to get on
with his belton's evidence if I can
but I just want to hear if that's if
that's agreeable well uh I've been
allotted 10 minutes because as I say I
will be flexible for that and if you
want more time I will give you more I do
want more time I want a lot more time I
would like to question her throughout
well and we need more than an hour okay
so I mean that's I mean I'm just putting
it out there that's the end of it
okay so can we proceed uh one other
thing I did speak to uh Mr Mather
regarding
um Keith Williams statement and where
it's problematic and he said to defer
this issue to you okay well and I I
think he was deferring to me whether you
could question
and and as I've said that's not the way
we operate but if you speak to either Mr
Mather or uh to Mr Leon they can make
sure the
the concerns uh to the degree they're
they're relevant is evidenced can be
brought out because obviously we want to
make sure the issues that are important
to the commission and to the public
are
uh the other Council are invited to ask
questions to Witnesses I can't
no I understand I'm just asking for one
not all and that should be fair okay let
her have one yeah I'm sorry that's not
the way it works it it is not the
process but I'm trying to accommodate
you that's the best I can do
so we're are we gonna allow
um Rebecca to assist
thank you okay I think what I think it's
for documents as I understand the issue
so when it comes to a question of
documents we'll we'll sort it out
either have her come up or have whatever
it's gonna work she's gotta go get set
up and organize the paperwork so that
she can pass the numbers that need to be
given to bring up the documents they
can't yeah do that
I can refer to them by the name that I
sent them to but you renumbered all of
them so if you can't find them then
we'll sort it out okay great I I
appreciate that and believe me the
numbers the system has been very good
but it's not simple I I need help but we
will help for that and you can refer to
the document and when you refer we'll
find it we may take a minute may take
five minutes but
we're all here for the same objective I
hope is that okay yeah that sounds fine
okay so uh perhaps we can have the
witness sworn and get started
Ms Belton will you swear on a religious
document or do you wish to affirm
I have my Bible with me
for the record please State your full
name and spell it out
Bridget
b-r-i-g-i-t-t-e Evelyn
e-v-e-l-y-n ilsa
i-l-s-e Belton b-e-l-t-o-n
do you swear that the evidence to be
given by you to this commission shall be
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth to help you God
yes ma'am thank you
thank you for being here Ms Belton
uh let me just by way of uh introduction
and I think
um you understand this but I just want
to make sure that um
the you understand the way the process
works
um I have as you know an hour and 15
minutes uh to ask you questions as the
commissioner has stated he's going to be
flexible with that
than the other lawyers here have the
same amount of time to ask you questions
that's all the lawyers together not each
one of them or we'd be here for a long
time and then as you've heard your legal
representative will then be able to ask
you questions
my objective is to ask you questions so
that you can tell your story about the
freedom Convoy and the role you played
in it
uh if I miss anything
I hope to give you the opportunity
to to say so and we'll try and deal with
all of the the points that you have
if you don't understand anything that I
ask you don't hesitate to ask me and to
clarify it
and if I can just start by asking you
that the documents that you have in
front of you are those the the documents
that you provided to the commission
today yes sir
okay just for reference
so um can we start off uh with you
telling the commission about a bit about
your your background were you born in
Ontario uh yes I was born in Ontario I
was baptized at Saint uh St Peter's
Lutheran Church on Bay Street
um I lived in Toronto for 16 years but
with travel uh holidays back to Ottawa
for my grandparents who were immigrated
here with my parents with my mom
um from Germany
and
I grew up pretty normal I guess and uh
moved when I was 16 to Ottawa
over a man
and uh had three wonderful children and
moved back
after my divorce to the Toronto area and
became a truck driver
and where do you live now I live in a
very small place called Wallaceburg
Ontario
and it is a border community
all uh truck traffic goes Southbound
and is that close to Sault Ste Marie
have I got the joke no that's a little
further north
um I'm probably smack dab in between
Windsor and Sarnia okay
and um
just in terms of a year when did you
start working as a as a truck driver uh
and does on December I believe it was
19th I
got my license December 19 of 2014.
thank you and of 2015 on February 6th I
started driving for Schneider National
which is no longer in Canada after the
mandates came in
you see and um
after at some point did you start
driving as an independent
yeah
um
we thought essential meant essential my
husband and I
he resurrected his business that had
been stale for about two and a half
years
um we bought a truck from Manitoba and
uh Was preparing to grow a trucking
company we were hoping to provide Canada
with a Landstar option style company as
Canada doesn't have that for owner
operators
we were hoping to grow this over the the
next few years
we took possession of the truck in
October of 2021 or September I think it
was 2021 and we signed uh finally got
signed on with Landstar in October
of 2021
and uh from there we really honestly
didn't think the government would would
uh change the definition of essential to
only when necessary
uh can I make an objection
this line of questioning wasn't in your
set of issues you were looking for her
background
that caused her to make a decision to
pursue the Convoy that was one in the
list you weren't looking for detail you
know history that's taking up a lot of
time yeah well I I think it's just we're
trying to get the story out I there's
you can't really object to her telling
well that's why I wanted to ask the
question so we wouldn't waste any of the
hours yeah well we we will try not to
waste time and if we work together on
that I'm sure we'll get to the end let's
get started
go ahead
now let's uh come to November 16 2021.
I take it you were driving into Canada
from the United States with the load on
on that day yes I was
and you had
I think what you would describe as an
extremely unpleasant interaction with a
border officer Canadian border officer
correct yes Windsor is typically
um a very hard difficult
bordered across regardless of mandates
once the mandates came in
they were unreasonable
and it was not the first
um
first issue with Windsor it was the
second issue with Windsor and the third
incident was cbsa during the covet
covered years okay and immediately after
that encounter you posted a tick tock
video about your experience no I was
locked into their compound not allowed
to leave when I posted that video I was
afraid that I was going to be taken away
by Windsor Police
I thought that time was the time they
were finally going to take a truck that
they did not own take a load that did
not belong to them take my dog and
euthanize him and take me to jail that's
what I thought that night and I was done
with cbsa I was done with the crap
Canada was going through and I was
definitely done with the behavior of
Canadians
okay
um but
can we uh move then and I'd like to show
the video if that's uh okay uh it's uh
com50589
Council can we have a brief uh minute
while we're loading that video please
let me while that we're getting the
video uh loaded uh at that point were
you an active uh user of tick tock
actually not really I think it's maybe
my fourth video on Tick Tock I had been
repeatedly
um put in Facebook jail I guess most of
us now in my situation use that as a
badge
um I think one of my comments was
something about somebody eating crayons
and I got banned for 33 days so this was
probably uh a double hit on this one I
think it was 50 55 days total at this
time that I was being restricted uh from
reaching out to my community
um on Facebook so I had taken to tick
tock I I thought it was really people
just running along cars and jumping in
them and singing but it was so much more
well you know more about it than I do so
and then um
were you so you were on other social
media like Facebook as well yes I was on
Facebook again I was censored on
Facebook uh my first real big sensor on
there was when I had explained to people
that Florida wasn't never closed that
the only blockade for people getting in
and out of Florida was on I-96 that I-90
uh I-75 and I-10 were wide open because
I had been there but our reporters here
were telling people they couldn't get to
Florida which was total BS
everybody could go in and out and the
only restriction was on I-96 and I
believe it was only for
um New York residents at that time
okay well let's watch the video then
uh if I could just please have the
number again Council
if I could please have the document ID
again please oh I'm sorry c-o-m
five zeros
589
this is Canada do you want to know what
it feels like to be this is Canada
attack do you want to know
just across the Canadian border
as a truck driver I just crossed in
today
and uh
an officer sent me into secondary with
the threat of the Windsor Police coming
and uh
foreign
and
um giving me a fine or whatever they're
gonna do to me I don't know
um the last time I was here for a mask
mandate issue they threatened to take my
truck they threatened to empower my load
um
and then I spoke with Windsor Health
Department
um
and uh they gave me you know Jessica's
number and I was supposed to um
supposed to deal with her but see in
Canada we're no longer free
and um
this may be the night where I uh I go
and ask for Exile into uh into the U.S
because
um this is a big country
this is what my grandparents came for
being harassed at the border over a mask
um
I just uh
I just wish that somebody understood
that not all of us can wear it and what
happened to me the night
the reason why I mentally can't deal
with being something over my face
um
I shouldn't ever have to explain
over the last two years
it would make my life hell
over the last two years
people have become rude and ignorant and
I'm done
I'm done
I don't know what I'm gonna do next oh
but I'm done
this is ridiculous
absolutely [ __ ] ridiculous
this is what it's like to be Canadian
people get out move
foreign
could you tell the commissioner
what impact this incident had on you
going forward
um
right from that night the first impact
was noticed as my husband was
asking me to stop I actually passed
three trucks drops not even realizing I
had passed them on the 401 eastbound
when I finally uh pulled in to the
Flying J in London
it was full there was no parking London
Police are known for ticketing trucks
so I left on my exit
from the London truck stop
you get to a dead end and you have to
turn right on that right turn I did not
see a minivan
and I nearly killed the people in that
minivan that night
hmm I pulled out I proceeded down the
highway
and uh I stopped at the very next stop I
realized at that point I was
I was I was
just over the moon upset
um
I stopped at the Husky
and I pulled in the back and I said
goodbye to my husband
I told him I'm done
I couldn't do it I told piak when they
called me
that night on the phone that I was done
I told the Wiley driver that came up to
console me I was done
I couldn't live that way anymore
every time I came back into Canada
we couldn't buy clothes we couldn't buy
supplies to work
we worked eight months with no sanitizer
no face masks nothing we had no
bathrooms we had no showers we were
refused everywhere we went
you have no idea what it's like to pee
in a park on your way home from work
because nobody
nobody meaning Subway in Chatham would
let me use their bathroom and I just
delivered a frozen load
of Subway bread
it was the same store I was supporting
and they wouldn't let me use their
bathroom
you have no idea
how demeaning those coveted measures
were
to our industry
and yet I felt it my duty
to support Canadians and bring you the
goods and services that many hoarded
thank you
and if we can move forward it was later
that week that the Canadian government
announced that a vaccine mandate would
be introduced effective January 15 for
people coming over the Border including
commercial truckers I'm sure you recall
that yes I remember the smugness of our
prime minister
and um what did that mean for your
ability to work as a as a trucker that
would mean that the truck that my
husband just purchased
would go bankrupt
at that time
jbt I had gone to that Trucking Company
looking for Canadian only loads
and to move the truck our his company
truck over to jbt we were refused
because of a vaccine mandate
um we were also looking for companies uh
even just to drive
the rate had dropped from approximately
50 to 60 cents a mile to 38 cents a mile
it was slave labor
we then
um
and that was for Canadian only and
Canadian only loads I have to tell you
between Ontario into Manitoba are some
of the worst roads you'll ever drive
there are no places to stop
nobody cares about the people up in
Northern Ontario
and yet truckers do it every day and
it's a death highway it's a death trap
and sorry
so during all of that there was very
little solution for our truck
um it would mean bankruptcy of the of
the company
and I take it that shortly
after that
um you came up with an idea for a a
convoy a protest Convoy is that right
yes and my husband and Chris Barber both
told me convoys never work
they just never had a woman do it
so um what was your idea
the idea was actually to work like cbsa
cbsa had a strike
uh during covet they felt they didn't
have enough money or enough benefits
they left
truck drivers sit on the bridges I was
lucky I was only there for two hours
without food fuel or a bathroom
a friend of mine was there for 14 hours
stuck in the backup and the backlog from
cbsa
so I thought well if cbsa can disrupt
our country
and be just fine
and have a settlement within 24 to 48
hours
truck drivers could do the same we'll
just follow cbsa's lead
and that's what we did and
am I right that uh it was shortly after
that that you came into contact with
Chris Barber yeah I had been trying
throughout the month of December
especially the more that our prime
minister hit the airwaves threatening
Canadians with consequences his favorite
word
um
I uh I kept continuing looking on Tick
Tock because I found out you could use
the search bar and put in truckers and
find truckers and I put into their
comment bars Convoy 2022 Convoy 2022 and
I just kept going until somebody
responded and thanked God for Chris
Barber
and did you ultimately get in touch with
Mr Barber we did we touched base I
believe our first uh exchange was on or
about the first of January our second
honor about the 2nd of January where he
agrees and I build a flyer
and we go from there
okay now I'd like to
show you what I believe to be a copy of
that flyer the document number is c-o-m
five zeros eight six nine
and I take it you posted this on your uh
tick tock
in early January is that right yes
that's the only place I wasn't getting
banned
so if we look at that uh come to join us
Convoy to end mandates
it says uh
please contact Kathy
who is Kathy Kathy was our
um Calgary
it says right there Calgary she was our
Calgary Road captain
leader organizer
so at this point had you already started
to identify
organizers and it happened overnight
once uh Chris and I started taking to
the Airways
um
it literally exploded overnight
and it says at the bottom January 23rd
we slow roll
I think it should be every Province uh
until mandates stop yeah so what what
was your plan our plan was to Slow Roll
in place not necessarily block borders
that was never the plan
um it was to
slow traffic be a nuisance
but be within our legal rights to
protest
and
the the you said that it all happened
very fast
um what were the things that you and Mr
Barber were doing to to make it happen
uh putting information such as this out
on Tick Tock uh with our email address
our phone numbers
both Chris and I uh had conversations
regarding how much our phone was ringing
and we had no time for anything else
uh I would frequently stay up till 3 A.M
answering text messages emails uh
messages through Tick Tock for
information I'd been contacted from the
Yukon from Nineveh uh from BC through to
Newfoundland
and I take I understand that at some
point
your original plan shifted to a con boy
of trucks to Audubon is that right
yes I mean the idea never shifted it was
uh always for the mandates
um
I received a message from the women's uh
Federation of trucking
and Shelley is a friend of my husband's
husband for quite some time they've done
uh
um cancer
convoys together
she had contacted me with Mr bowders
uh Convoy information and I remember
saying to her those are my dates I'm
going to have to call him and tell him
to change his dates
I I wasn't planning on working together
however James is a good salesperson
and he told me he had a lot of resources
he had done a convoy before
and that we could work together
and so had you known uh Mr bowder before
no
and um did he tell you about uh a prior
Convoy that he had organized he just
told me he had a convoy
and um did you know anything about uh
his uh social media presence
at that point not really uh
I have gone back through my emails
somebody had asked me to sign it his mou
uh basically gave me a rundown of what
it was and I went over and I signed it
just as support I've never read the full
document
and um
is he a trucker himself
I have no proof he isn't
okay
now at some point
um you also got together with Pat King
at the same time actually okay who
arranged that
I was talking with James
uh regarding the dates and him offering
a whole bunch of support
and he had mentioned that Pat King was
trying to get a hold of me
um I'm like who's Pat King
um
and we did a three-way call to connect
and
that was in early January uh January
12th
and then the next night
um you uh were part of a Facebook live
streamed event that Mr King hosted yes
sir
and uh you were there Mr bowder Mr
Barber and there were a few others as
well yes there were
and um
what did you talk about as a group what
was the discussion like
I do know that it was being presented to
the other Convoy
um who I would say the core group of the
leadership uh Dale Joe myself and Chris
uh whether we were going to work
together on what was being pro on the
table and of course our silly truck
driver cells uh was mixed into their so
um it was just a basic you know are we
going to do this as a group or are we
not and I believe the consensus uh
was that we were
um
I believe it was Joe that spoke up first
that said I guess we're going to Ottawa
and Joe do you recall his last name uh
Jensen
and Dale
Evans that's kind of with a question
mark on the end of it I believe that's
his last name
and uh so at this point in time
what stage was the plan at was it
well
we were growing very very fast
um
Pat King had a huge media prep uh
presence so he claimed his claim is true
and that helped us reach out to more
people
uh James bowder also had a huge media
presence which helped us reach even more
people
at the time Convoy started I had less
than a thousand followers I was new to
tick tock
Chris had
explosive numbers I think he was in the
160s
I can't give it an exact number
so these gentlemen had the numbers to
get going
I had the passion the drive and the
Heart
and I take it at that point you um
hadn't reviewed either Mr bowders or Mr
King's uh past social media posts or no
I don't typically go spy on people
did you do that subsequently
not really
um I like to judge people on how they
behave with me or to me
now at this Facebook live event it was
reported that 3 000 people tuned in did
you were you familiar with that number
I'm going to take your word for it okay
and um
I understand that towards the outset of
the this meeting
um
Mr King introduced you
um as one of the organizers who was
handling the Ontario section
was that right yeah I'm from
Southwestern Ontario I believe I also
expressed I would be doing Sarnia as my
own personal
but I dealt directly with
um
ADT Trucking
the Yonkers
David
Steinberg steenberg sorry Dave
um and a whole lot of others
um Mike and Andrew throughout Ontario
Ontario being my home it gave me the
ability to grow faster
in the area they knew out out in the
western provinces so they had their
connections there I would like to object
again
we were told there was several topics
that you were going to introduce and
leave it open-ended for her to present
her
uh information or testimony and it's not
it's being led and there's a lot of
information here that is not critical
for such a short amount of time
she has some very important information
that she intends or wants to put out
there and it's not coming out in the end
he's direct and we asked for questions
and they said oh there's it's not
questions it's a list of topics and they
gave us the topics and said it was going
to be open-ended for her to testify
under those topics but that's not what's
happening here okay is there a problem
with the questioning Miss Belton or are
you okay with with the way it's going is
there a problem as long as we get the
time to get all the information out we
can go forward okay go ahead
and by that point in time we saw that
you I think you already had your
departure date set as January 23rd for
York Convoy that was set prior to even
uh Chris Barber agreeing I was going
forward whether he agreed or not
uh I was just lucky that it was him that
did agree and had you planned your route
I had uh a very good idea of what the
Sarnia would look like
I understood a lot of the Geographics of
the highways throughout Canada I've
driven them for quite quite some time
I did realize that some routes we
couldn't get close enough to the border
that we would have to
um push back into the city centers just
so that we could keep rolling and not
block things we could actually get
around in a loop
um so those were all coming into play
and they were all thought of there was
no
um intention to block anything just to
slow things down and
just be a nuisance I guess
to be heard to be seen yes
and in the same Facebook live
presentation I understand that
Mr bowder discussed operation bear hug
were you familiar with that yes that
well I'm familiar with the term I'm
familiar with James bouter and James
bouter can talk about his bear hug I
don't know his in and out workings
that's his organization have you ever
been involved in the the Canada Unity
organization I was on a live where James
proudly and I accepted a mug two
T-shirts and two stickers maybe one
sticker but I think there were two
and a keychain
and you've already told us
um
about your your signing the mou without
reading it in that same Facebook live
meeting you recall Mr bowder uh
discussing his mou
I kind of roll my eyes when James talks
about the mou to be honest
and do you recall that Mr King in the
course of the uh
the meeting
um
thank you and gave you and Mr Barber
credit for lighting the spark
to make this happen
yes I guess
now at this point in time
um what did you understand from your
point of view the purpose or the goal of
the freedom Convoy
to end the Mandate so I could go back to
work and every other essential
uh worker could become essential again
and did you have a vision at this point
as to what would happen when you arrived
in Ottawa
I actually believed that the Prime
Minister wouldn't run away
and he would come and beat with us
I believed that our
voices would be heard I believed that we
were validated in our complaint
and that after two years
maybe somebody would care
and at some point I understand you met
Tamara Leach yes was it around that time
or before
around which time around the time of the
Facebook live presentation
I don't have a date that I met tomorrow
Leach I
can estimate approximately the 14th of
January
and um
the people that I named that is you Mr
Barber Mr King Ms Leach Mr bowder
did you regard them as the the
leadership group of this effort not all
of them who did you regard as the
leadership group
Chris
myself
James
a pot was lead on media
there were Road crabs there's a lot of
leaders tomorrow was not considered an
organizer or leader
she was never presented to me that way
she had offered to
do the gifts uh GoFundMe I apologize
and uh Facebook media that's where I
understood her to start and stop her
involvement
and so you've told us about your role in
in Southern Ontario
um were you doing publicity as well
yes it was difficult uh as I was
receiving phone calls from all over the
country and was there a sign up
procedure
I believe
um
it came out later uh someone provided a
document
to hand out to the truck drivers
to sign up
a lot of that didn't happen due to the
chaos at each of these stops Canada came
to welcome US Canada came to travel with
us and Canada came to support us
and Mr Barber was responsible for the
Western Convoy is that he was
responsible for his province
and he what were Mr bowder's
responsibilities
for his group
am I correct that he already had a
number of maps and and roots from his
prior Convoy to Ottawa that's correct he
was our support he uh
stated that he would provide us with
support places to park information
a group of people that would welcome us
and assist us I don't think he failed on
that
was there anybody else involved in the
uh this organizing process that we
haven't talked about
at the beginning yes
not that I'm aware of
again however each leader
had a group of individuals that they
worked with
so it expanded outwards okay and uh
did you have Road captains
that's what they tended to be called
I considered everyone I spoke with
to be their own leader
to follow the director the the idea
that we had envisioned
and go from there
and how did you make sure everybody
understood that idea
when we had our initial contact I mean
Southwestern Ontario uh
leads or Road captains or organized or
whatever you'd like to call them
it was very clear this is what we are
doing
this is how we'd like to do it in your
area this is possible and we'll always
be about safety a lot of these drivers
uh that's that stood up to take
leadership roles
were business owners independent
contractors or
just owner operators in general they
know how to do Logistics I don't need to
tell them
so if if if we can
move forward then to the date when you
departed from
uh with your convoy yes is there
anything else you want to say about what
happened before
is there something specific you're
looking for no I just want to make sure
you I didn't miss anything
I had been in contact with OPP Brian uh
from Sarnia
we were on the same page
I was following his advice
I was instilling it into the drivers
that I was working with that safety's
number one
and we went forward the day we arrived
on the 23rd
was um
overwhelming
at that point how many
trucks were in your convoy
there was too many people to count
the truck stop at Wyoming at Exit 25
I've never seen more than maybe a
hundred trucks in there
and that day
it was hard to get a lane in and out of
the truck stop it was a snake you had to
snake around
London was no different and neither was
any other truck stop or our plan stop
along the way so you had planned to have
other stops along the way where other
trucks joined you for the console they
would just roll in with us a lot of them
excuse me there's one important element
that's missing that was in her timeline
and it would have been included had I
been asking the questions and that was
the things that she did to try and
resolve the issues prior to initiating
the Convoy
with the cbsa and MPS and so on and I
think she has uh or I know she has
entered uh those documents uh to the
commission
okay so if you could take a note that's
the sort of thing you're welcome to do
maybe that question can be dealt with
but if you can make notes those are the
sorts of things that would be helpful of
the commission at when you get to do
your questioning we can fill in those
blacks okay
now I I'm coming to this but if I can
just have the uh the clerk turn up uh
com
five zeros eight seven one but before
you you start that I have a couple of uh
questions
um
what was the the route that you followed
to Ottawa I'm sorry which was what was
the route that you followed to Ottawa
just in general
for uh I took 402
down to the 401.
401
to the 416 416.
to
um
I believe it was the 417 to Pinecrest
Pinecrest to Carling Carling to the uh
Parkway
and I was blocked in with the rest of
the trucks uh
at the intersection for the last Bridge
before uh Wellington
how long were you blocked in there for
the trucks remained there the whole time
I was uh in my pickup truck I didn't
bring a big truck to Ottawa
it would be easier for me to assist and
help people move around in my pickup
truck
so I took my pickup truck and I was able
to turn around and go back the other way
so I was in and out same day
so is that location where your your
convoy stayed for the uh that's the
where the map sent us that's where the
police sent us and that's where we went
I was going to ask you did you have
ongoing contact with the opp or the
Ottawa Police Service along the way
honestly can't tell you if I did or did
not I'm sure I did I had a lot of phone
calls coming in and a lot of police
talking with me along the way
once uh Sarnia met up with uh the GTA
Dave Steinberg took over
um lead as he had the most vehicles
so I'm sure he can answer those
questions and we did communicate between
myself Mike uh Andrew the Yonkers uh ADT
Trucking we were all in communication we
all knew each other at this point we had
approximately three weeks to two and a
half weeks to prepare
so we were definitely constantly in con
communication your understanding though
is that there was a contact uh with the
police along the way my understanding is
yes and did they is it your
understanding that they directed you
where to go when you arrived as you've
described my pictures show that where
the police officers moving the barrels
and my truck is going through where he
directed now if we can take a step back
you did another Tick Tock video along
the route of what you were experiencing
and at least one that wasn't during that
was probably posted afterwards well let
me bring it up and you can see it and
we'll it's a com50871
[Music]
from
[Music]
inside
[Music]
promise
[Music]
black
[Music]
now we see in
Council when was this document disclosed
to the parties
is this one of the documents that were
disclosed this morning sorry is this one
of the doc sorry is this one of the
documents that we disclosed this morning
no
now
um in that video
we
we saw people along the sides of the
roads on the the overpasses
um
and you just describe what you were
experiencing along the way
Canadians finally peaceful
Canadians supporting each other
Canadians finally not separated or
segregated in any way
and
before you arrived in Ottawa did you
have a plan as to where you were going
to go or was your plan just to follow
the directions that you you received
that would be questions for James bouter
he had
the information had made arrangements
and we were following his lead on that
so those organizational details went to
him I was following what was sent to me
from his organization
um and I do believe I had to request it
on the 28th I had as I hadn't received
it
uh but we were following the directions
he had done this before
I was following his Direction
and so you say he said told the
commissioner that you had a you were in
your pickup truck you got out of that
line where did you go
after everybody was parked yes I went up
to arm prior to meet my buddy Chris
and what did you do then
I hugged them okay
um
at some point did you come back into
Ottawa
not that night I stayed at a relative's
home
and so you came back on the the 29th is
that I went back up to arm prior on the
29th and I led Mike stock and the rest
of the Convoy and I knew the area
it's easier when you have a pilot car
that knows the directions and the city
streets
we were again told to go
through onto the S Jam however a portion
of the Convoy
was unknowingly to me then
directed by overhead signs to use
different streets
some of us were already on the sjam and
others were being directed by overhead
signage
you know to use what streets do you know
I was on the S Jam so I wouldn't know
okay
and uh where did you
and this this was the Western Convoy was
it that you were guiding it yes sir and
where did you end up
on the S Jam
and at some point did you
make your way into Ottawa
well the S gem comes right up
we uh the Ottawa Police had moved
whatever
barricade or block blockade whatever
they had preventing vehicles from moving
forward allowed Chris and myself to move
up onto Wellington Street
I parked
right beside this building
uh off the roadway
Chris found a parking spot on Wellington
and that's where he parked big red
tomorrow and Chris got out
and um
had you anticipated that
Vehicles would be parked on on
Wellington itself
I understood what James bouter had told
me
I believe we had permits
I'm not sure if we did or not I didn't
double check anybody's work
and um
and at some point did you become aware
that trucks had been were located in
residential areas off of Wellington
I came in and out of the city almost
every day for approximately five days I
had no problem getting in and out of the
city
uh if you learned how to snake around
the city it was open access
I did understand there were some concern
about where trucks were and
Chris being Chris was taking care of
that so I let him do that
okay and um
I should rephrase that I didn't let him
do that we agreed that he would do that
and and what did you do during the the
weeks you were in Ottawa and
um just in very general terms so how did
you uh occupy yourself
oh there was so much to do
I made uh designs for sweaters for the
show up on
um at Parliament Hill
I donated food to the u-ville center
which I'm a former girl of
I helped with Logistics when I could I
helped with mopping I helped my hand was
in every pot
although I was not in one section they
tried to uh Tom morazzo kept trying to
fit me into a box and I said I'm sorry I
don't fit into the boxes I'm up here and
I just went off and did whatever uh
wherever anybody needed me and can you
give me some examples of where you were
needed
I had a call from a city of Ottawa
resident that her and a few of her
family members were having a hard time
reaching a food bank
so I told her to give me her number I
would work on getting her support to get
to the food bank that she needed to
since taxis buses and other
Transportation were not coming into the
city
and that's what I did I passed her
number off to uh John I do not know his
last name
and I do know he's from Ontario
and I passed her number off to John
checked with him made sure that was
taken care of and away we went so when a
fire came up if I could put it out I'd
put it out if I could not pass it on
how did that person get your phone
number do you know it was posted all
over the internet
okay
and um
I'm going to if you can turn up uh to
register com50870
it's another one of your Tick Tock
videos
but um
while that's happening
um
what were you
seeing in Ottawa on Wellington Street
love unity
people happy
this had been two years
people had been surprised two years
people were struggling
two years
that our government had told us
shame your family do not allow them to
come to Christmas do not allow them to
come at Easter do not allow them to come
to your home if they are not vaccinated
if they don't wear a mask
there was a lot of hate in Canada
and the Toronto Sun supported it or the
Toronto Star excuse me supported it
people were evil towards each other and
that is not what I saw in Ottawa I saw
love I saw Unity I saw Quebec with
Alberta I saw Ontario with Quebec
hugging
I saw people happy
it was the best thing that happened to
our country in two years
hey can we play that video then that's
getting threatened is a little upset
this morning or yesterday tweeted that
he was
getting threatened he's got work to do
in Ottawa
I've heard this rhetoric before actually
but I'd like to tell you sir
this is what it's like to be a truck
driver Crossing into Canada
because of you and your staff and the
mandates
you have threatened me for two years
how does it feel
doesn't feel so good does it
I've lost 22 pounds now
because of what has happened to me at
the border
who's going to address the mental health
issues that your agents your CBS agent
they're a direct extension of you
have done to me
nobody's paying for that
tortured me for two years
and you're worried about our peaceful
protest
maybe stop paying antophia to show up
if you don't want to be threatened
it's not our group
have a good day
and what led you to make that video one
of the ministers complained they were
getting harassed and they had work to do
in Ottawa
we had been harassed every day for two
years
and um if you can bring up please
another video
com50872 did you while you were we were
doing that while you were um
in Ottawa did you see
um you've described the how you felt
about the conduct there but did you see
any conduct that was you felt was
inappropriate or caused you concern
I mean there were people drinking
maybe it wasn't in a LCBO
licensed establishment
but I saw food not being checked by food
agencies either
is that the risk
I guess we all took it we survived
hey can we play that video
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
and where was that taken uh up in
Parliament Hill on Wellington okay that
was the day I
um arrived I believe thank you now if I
can just shift gears here for a minute
uh I guess that's not the appropriate
expression to use for someone who drives
the truck but I if you can do it without
clutching I'm impressed
um at some point I uh you learned did
you learn about protests in in Windsor
and Sarnia
yes oh
um how did you learn
media
um did you speak to anybody who was
involved
not involved
who did you speak to I spoke with ADT
Trucking who uh called me and asked me
if we could block the Windsor border and
my response was no way continue to slow
roll
and what who was who called you from ADT
I don't know who called me from ADT and
um
any other contact uh with anyone
involved in the uh what was going on in
Windsor or Sarnia
in Sarnia yeah
I saw Tick Tock videos of Farmers on the
roadway only through social media did I
have contact I had no idea that was
planned I had no idea anything like that
and we've heard about other protests at
Borders in other places in Canada did
you have any contact with anyone who was
involved in in those protests no even my
Tick Tock suggests that I don't know
anyone at the Coots border but I thought
they had a lot of gumption I guess you
could say
now
um
coming back to your time in Ottawa did
you maintain contact with James bouter
could you repeat that question coming
back when you were in Ottawa did you
maintain contact with James bouter
coming back from where
oh sorry
I'm just coming back and my questions to
your time in Ottawa did you maintain
contact with James bowder
I saw him
every day we were in the same Hotel
and can you do you did you have any idea
about how large his group of uh of
protesters were no okay
did you have any conflicts or concerns
with him
we all have conflict with each other
it's Human Nature
anything of significance
no
did you understand that
there were concerns being expressed
about his memorandum of understanding
there were
concerns expressed about
pretty much all of us at one point in
time
and what was did you have any reaction
to the concerns about his memorandum of
understanding it had nothing to do with
me
and did you have any ongoing contact
with Pat King while you were in Ottawa
yes he offered to pay for the sweaters
that I designed
anything else
we hugged in the street we live streamed
together he was doing his job as media
when it came to me
and
were you aware of that there were some
criticisms of things he was doing in
Ottawa
there were criticisms of all of us from
somebody
did you have any concerns about what he
was doing in Ottawa I've already said no
now I I understand that uh at some point
um
you and some of the others that you
dealt with at the beginning uh when you
were organizing the Convoy
um at a disagreement is that a fair way
to put it
wouldn't be the first time probably
won't be the last
at some point did you
break away from the the leadership group
or anything like that while you were in
Ottawa
not while I was in Ottawa I did
not show up as often at the Sheridan
where uh Keith Wilson and Tamara and
Chris were were mostly stationed with a
few others
I felt more comfortable at the arc doing
more of the humanitarian Style
helping and just being me
and we heard evidence this morning
um that um
uh Mr
uh
sorry let me rephrase that um were you
involved in
um Distributing envelopes of cash to
people uh in Ottawa
did I physically go out and do that yes
no
did you have any involvement in putting
them together or anything like that
I did have
uh one or two incident in
let me start that again I had one or two
times where I put envelopes together
due to transparency I had requested that
we filmed those that when we got the
money we counted it we put it into
envelopes and they were distributed
uh
the group over at the Sheridan got a
little upset with us as they were
handing out five hundred dollars and
um and Drew
had suggested we hand out 2 000 since
500 is not a large number
and the group at the Sheraton who who
was that that would be Chris Barber
Keith Wilson Tamara Leach Joe Jensen
Dale Ryan Miranda
and who I'm sorry I missed what you said
who suggested two thousand dollars
I believe it was Drew I could be
incorrect
and did what happened with that did
anything come of that
they got two thousand dollars
and in terms of your relations with the
the group at the Sheraton
they were upset
they said we made them look bad
now on
February 12 2022
um you you were aware that um
or at least you're you're now aware that
there an agreement was reached with the
mayor of Ottawa to move trucks on to
Wellington
I'm assuming I wasn't there
did you know or hear about such an
agreement I heard the agreement was not
valid
and who did you hear that from through
social media
and did you discuss it with anyone to
find out whether it was valid or not
no I heard the report and moved on
in fact if I can ask you to bring up com
uh five zeros eight six eight
and I understand this to be a tick tock
you posted on February 13. 2022.
hold that line boys
down there
okay so that was the uh a copy of the
agreement
yeah a notice of the agreement I'm sorry
yep I don't know how I got it if I took
it myself I have no regulation of how
that got to be but I always forwarded
information onto my tick tock
and why did you uh put it as fake news
because I believed it to be fake
and did you check with anybody one way
or another
how did you come by that belief
that's what I was told by whomever was
around me it was fake news so that's
what I posted
and
at some point in time you you left
Ottawa to read
the Ottawa Red Zone or Ottawa as a whole
well let's deal with both uh at some
point did you leave the Ottawa Red Zone
yes I left on the 18th of the in the red
zone
and where did you go
to
Ottawa West to a family member's home
okay
and um why did you leave on that day
because
the police were about to attack Canadian
citizens
and were you arrested at any time no sir
um was your bank account Frozen yes sir
uh for how tell me about that what
happened
I understood the government officials
stated that
they had notified
organizers their bank accounts would be
frozen
my husband notified me my bank account
and his bank account
where and our business bank account were
frozen
and at 1004
on the 17th is when I received a phone
call
from and
person stating they were from the Royal
Bank
and that they had Frozen my accounts
they had a very nasty exchange with me
because they had no right to do so
I told them to open the accounts they
told me to call them when I left Ottawa
and I said you need to open my accounts
we ended the exchange I realized other
people in the room were also getting
that same phone call
whether it was the same person making
the phone call I do not know but I do
know other people in the room were
getting the same phone call
and so what happened after that
I had no money
and what did you do
I had to ask for money or let people
know that I didn't have any money and I
was lucky enough that two gentlemen uh
on the street actually understood my
truck payment was coming due and I was a
few hundred dollars short I think it was
six something I was short
they together collectively sent me
enough money to cover my truck payment
um
a Woman by the name of Messina was kind
enough to give me a hundred dollars
which helped because it put gas in my
car in my pickup truck to go
and uh from then we had to scramble on
how we were going to pay for medication
for my husband and how we were going to
pay the mortgage
and so this was all while you were still
in the uh excuse me the Ottawa area
yes
and at some point were your accounts
unfrozen yes and when was that
you'd have to ask my husband he takes
care of that
and when did you leave Ottawa to come
back home
March
I don't have a specific date I'm sorry I
don't have a specific date but it was
March okay
and is there anything else uh you want
to tell the commissioner about what
happened while you were in Ottawa
I just want everybody to know that we
weren't there to disrupt the city
residents we were there to be heard
I had given 32 emails approximately to
MPS and mpps
32.
not one of them
did anything for me
I followed
how things are supposed to go you first
go and you complain
you try again you try again
and when cbsa sent me a reply pretty
much suck it up buttercup this is the
way it's going to go and you're about to
lose your job so don't worry about it
what did you want me to do
sit down lie down
lose everything be over a mandate
that was really no longer effect in the
U.S
that's what my country was asking for me
that's what Canadians that were
supporting vaccine mandates were asking
of me
to lose everything
because they were afraid because our
government did a very good job
at scaring people
making them so afraid that today still
some wear face masks
many of us here are not
and that propaganda hurt our country
and having our prime minister saying
that there will be consequences for the
unvaccinated and we don't want them
sitting beside our children on planes
and Trains and Automobiles and the
amount of
I'm trying to control my anger over this
gentleman but the wording that he used
was division
the whole time
pick one person against another
shame them make them comply and if they
don't they will
I'm sorry
I draw the line when my government wants
to throw something into my body I cannot
remove
that is where I draw the line bodily
autonomy it is mine it is not my
governments
thank you for answering my questions
foreign
we're going to take a break and uh
I'm gonna
consider whether we're going to clear
the hall so I'm going to take a short
break and when I come back I'll decide
if we're going to clear the hole
five minutes the commission is in races
for five minutes
thank you
foreign
Lord
the commission is reconvened the
commissioner
thank you
thank you for that uh Indulgence I've
decided
hesitant but I've decided not to clear
the room at this point I did notice uh
there's a significant group that is I
think doing its best to comply
um I'm uh but I am concerned I mean this
is
I I I firmly believe this is an
important process and that it should be
as much as possible respected so
we'll go ahead I hope uh not to have
more issues
so we were about to turn to uh some of
the questioning are you okay to continue
yes okay
thank you so the first uh is the
government of Canada please
foreign
good afternoon Miss Belton my name is
Andrew Gibbs and I'm part of the council
team for the government of Canada
um I have two quick areas of questions
for you
the first areas with respect to uh was
touched on a little bit with the
commission's council with respect to
some of the um I'll call them fights but
disagreements as you as you indicated
amongst the leadership group
and in particular
um with respect to the handling of money
by Tamara Leach
did you have concerns about the uh the
handling of money by Ms Leach I
understood Keith Wilson was
directing her and taking care of it
he's a lawyer there should be no concern
okay so do you recall uh posting as
something on Tick Tock expressing
concern
Tick Tock video was actually not even
about Tamara everybody has taken that so
out of context The Tick Tock was
regarding the
um uni unified people of Canada or
whatever I have an embassy it's called
the Canadian embassy
um
this Embassy was was trying to associate
with the Convoy I didn't know any of the
organizers or if they were with uh
involved with Tamara I know they had
stated they were I had never seen them
before
um I was trying more to denounce what
they were doing
um they had said they were advisors of
tomorrow
I was concerned over a
comment in a car
that would had been made over spending
money on a building
I did voice my opinion in the car that
we were here to end mandates when we
were done working with the government or
getting our
five minutes with them to speak with
them though we were planning on leaving
there was no long-term plan to stay
okay if we can just call up the video
just to confirm for the record it's
[Music]
pb.can.340177 Council of fuel allow me a
brief Indulgence but just trying to
resolve the hard drive issue it will be
two minutes okay if that's appropriate
thank you very much
and I only have one other question and
it's on a on a particular document
um
we were provided uh the parties were
provided with documents over the lunch
break
um about 216 documents that you had
filed uh over the lunch break for us
with my team yes with your team okay and
so I've only gotten through some of them
there was one document in particular I'd
like your help just to understand so
welcome to my life you guys threw a lot
at me in a short period of time
uh yes I think we're all in the same
boat on that
if you can call up the video please The
Tick Tock video
it'll be just another 60 seconds the the
videos right now are just about to be
ready
we've had to deal with a lot of
documents you can imagine yes I could
pull it up on my phone faster
if counsel has any other documents uh in
paper format I do have those available
the other document then is is brb
five zeros sorry six zeros six two
do you recognize this document
yeah those were things that were had
been posted on a telegraph
site who posted them I'm unaware we were
uh very
um
very concerned over safety of you know
protesters and stuff like that
and for the sake of the commission and
others in the room who are perhaps less
familiar with Telegraph I'm starting to
figure out Tick Tock but uh what is
Telegraph
it's a platform that steals a lot of
space from my phone
that's about the best way to explain
it's pretty much just a messaging a fast
way of messaging through a group of a
bunch of people
and is it a secure messaging platform I
have no idea
okay fair if you can um focus in on the
bottom left hand corner I believe it's
item number three
there's a mention with respect to excuse
me is there any way to enlarge that for
those of us with
poor eyesight
thank you I may have another pair
there's a there's a reference to tow
trucks which is a common theme in the
commission
um before the commission and I'm just if
we can perhaps shift a bit to the or I
can see it up here perhaps
um
were you aware uh that people in the tow
truck industry were being encouraged not
to provide tow truck services
to the uh to the police
not necessarily but I understand they've
been put in a very Rock and Hard Place
kind of position had I known they showed
up to tow-toe trucks
I wouldn't use their service
that's me
I'm sure a lot of other truck drivers
would have felt the same
so the message reads the most strategic
and effective way to protest once you
arrive in Ottawa is absolutely nothing
Park your truck on the road turn off the
engine and let it sit there no tow truck
company would dare tow it away and if
they do get it on video if they do get
it on video and make sure everyone knows
not to do business with them vote with
your wallet
does that capture the sentiment you just
expressed
we do that with lots of things
we don't like what Coca-Cola said we
don't buy coke anymore we don't like
what somebody says about children or
animals we don't buy their product
anymore it's the same thing tow truck
services are a product
if we don't like what they do we don't
have to buy their service
so for them to assist the citizens of
Ottawa and tow the trucks or to assist
the police and tow the trucks that would
result in not buying their services
I wouldn't buy their service
they weren't supportive of Canadians
thank you uh Mr clerk do we have the
video now if you could just briefly
repeat the document idea I should be
able to yes pb.can
dot four zeros one triple seven
underscore rail
and for the record commissioner I would
have ended a lot earlier
I know I've burned a bit of my time in
previous rounds so this one I
Ottawa
tomorrow's handlers are advisors
have set up a
a permanent residence at St bridges in
Ottawa
hmm
that building's worth 5.2 million
dollars I have no idea what the rent is
but I do remember sitting in a car which
uh Sean
Tamara
a female family member of hers her
husband and Chad Eros while they laughed
about spending 3.2 million dollars of
the trucker's money on the building
beside this West you can look that up
it's still for sale I looked it up in
the car and didn't think it was very
funny that they wanted to spend 3.2
million dollars of the truckers money on
a building so they could continue to
protest I reminded them we were here to
drop all mandates and when the mandates
were done so were we
I wish I could say the news story is
untrue but it came from the mouth of
babes herself the advisor to Tamara
it's pretty hard to deny when somebody
puts you under the bus as being someone
that that was there to change political
policy and was there for a political
agenda
tomorrow when she joined up with us
agreed to only do a fundraiser she then
threatened me
she threatened others
and she obviously had another agenda
other than dropping the mandates and
setting Canada free
as I said it was more directed to Saint
Bridget's but
and you said she threatened you in The
Tick Tock video she did and what was the
nature of that threat the threat was
that if I used my voice and did any more
media that you would include me in the
lawsuit with the city of Ottawa
and if you did not
if you were silent if I was silent
there was no if you're silent but
that was the threat
thank you I have no further questions
thank you uh next uh the Convoy
organizers
sure uh I'm going to ask under I can't
recall the rule but with respect to
the order of examination as we got the
documents from this particular witness
several hundred of them not until this
afternoon I do have concerns from the
brief ones I've reviewed and I have
given a written objection to your
council with respect to those what I
would like to do in the meantime sir is
I would like your leave and approval to
examine this witness following her
paralegal examining her I can tell you
at this point I don't have many
questions for this witness at all my
concern is the beginning of a character
assassination as well as attacking my
client the corporation itself and given
what was just asked by the government of
Canada and what was just said I I would
like to sit back and see what the
evidence is with respect to the
character assassination evidence that I
think this witness is intending to give
before I do my examination sir
okay well I'm not sure if we should be
talking about character assassinations
rather there are some issues being
raised I think let's try and
not inflame things and take one step at
a time so you'd like to defer at the
moment
and maybe I can hear from
I'm okay with that I don't mind if we if
we go first I think that's what he's
saying that's okay okay so that should
not be a problem so let's go through the
rest of the roster and then we can get
to that
okay so next to the
Ottawa residents
uh good afternoon Miss Belton my name is
Paul champ I'm the lawyer for the Ottawa
Coalition of uh residents and businesses
and I just have some questions for you
further to your testimony today
um you testified uh earlier Miss Belton
that it was not your intention to uh
disrupt the lives of residents of
downtown Ottawa is that right that's
correct but you did recognize that the
activities of the protests the the
trucks taking up all of the streets and
the horns and so forth did indeed
disrupt residents who were living within
the six or eight blocks of those
activities
as did millions of Canadians that
demanded people get vaccines and demand
that they wear masks and demand that
they be thrown to the ground yeah I
understood what had happened over the
last two years and I'm sorry they were
affected for three weeks
but I suffered for three years well two
years
and did you um associate the people with
downtown Ottawa with the government of
Canada like the Jews soon that these
were government federal government
workers in some way who who deserved
that disruption no that would be
ludicrous
and on your arrival in the city
um we've we've heard some evidence about
a strategy to gridlock the city can you
tell us about that
I wasn't part of that design
what was uh what was the plan as far as
you understood with the 400 plus
semi-tractor trailer trucks converging
on downtown where did you think they
would go
I understood there were two locations
where we were to go but that the police
had redirected us once we uh got
together at the arc we started to hear
uh concerns and I believe the guys were
working on it
um doing whatever they could to to deal
with the logistics issues I did not deal
with the logistics issues in Ottawa you
you were Road Captain managing the
Convoy of trucks from Southwestern
Ontario to Ottawa is that right yes and
I went where the police directed us
which was nowhere near your residence by
the way where sorry what does that mean
that means your residents were further
further north right ours were on the S
jump there was no residence where we had
been we were in front of the war
memorial right I believe that's the war
memorial there is uh you would have seen
the apartment buildings there right in
front of your trucks no it was further
back okay it was not right directly with
a truck
um
with respect to uh mask mandates I
understand your position with respect to
vaccines you're also opposed to mass
mandates is that right
I'm not opposed to mass mandates I'm
opposed to women who are victims of
violence to be forced to wear them or be
thrown to the ground
where people in restaurants and stores
throwing people to the ground is that
what you observed I observed video from
Canadian Tire and Costco both where
Securities threw people to the ground
also a woman in BC that had no
hands arms from the elbow down was
refuse service at a grocery store
because she couldn't put a mask on
so the the
General Public
lacked empathy and sympathy for those
that could not comply
uh did um you have sympathy or empathy
for uh people who were elderly or had
medical conditions where they'd be
susceptible to dying from uh covet 19.
absolutely but we have never locked up
the healthy
ever
now with respect to the mass mandates
there was a lot of people in the Convoy
demonstrations who were very opposed to
masks and mask wearing correct
everybody had their own
belief some warm us some didn't there
were people on the street that wore
Mouse can I object that question doesn't
go to the Mandate that was established
for that
process so why should you have to answer
questions about that I don't even
believe there was a mass mandate in
effect at that time
uh indeed there was I'm not sure if I
understand the objection
the objection is that the protest was
not about masks it was about truckers
mandates for truckers for travel I think
we've heard a great deal of evidence I
apologize I'm sorry I apologize there is
a process you speak through me uh Miss
scarf I I understand your point but this
is cross-examination so I I tend to give
a little attitude so if that I think
that question is within that Latitude
so miss Belton uh we've heard previous
evidence uh from the police and others
about
um some Convoy protesters uh being very
upset about people wearing masks and
doing
um protests by going into stores and
shops and restaurants in large groups
without wearing masks Did You observe
those kinds of activities while you were
here
I observe massless people I didn't see
protests you might want to talk to those
that caused the issue that was not me
uh so when you went into restaurants and
shops you wore a mass during the Convoy
protest sir I'm a victim of violence and
I won't put a mask on to make you feel
better so so when I have to go through
what I have to go through and take
Ativan because you want me to wear a
mask and then you don't want me to drive
a car however I live in the country I
take issue to that I can't walk home I
don't live in a city center like you do
so yes there are issues on both sides
and there is no compassion on this side
that is the issue
you are painting this exactly like the
Toronto Star did
you have no empathy for us
so I'd take that as a no you didn't wear
masks when you went into a store no
because I'm a female victim of violence
and you need to respect that okay and uh
Did You observe others that you'd go
with into stores and shops wearing uh
not wearing masks the people you were
with that was asked and answered yes the
answer is yes and uh what would how
would people respond when shop owners or
staff sometimes young teenage staff
would say please wear a mask what are
some things you observed in those
interactions I didn't have those
interactions
no one ever asked can you please wear a
mask or leave no sir
um with respect to the uh money
um
so you were aware before you got to
Ottawa that there was the large
fundraiser people were raising funds to
support the the truckers with covering
their fuel and their food and their and
so forth you're aware of that yes Tamara
did an amazing job at raising funds for
us for sure
and but by the time you arrived in
Ottawa you recognized it was in the
multi-millions that had been raised is
that right that's correct and
um when you came to Ottawa how long did
you think you'd be staying
24 to 48 hours
that and and you required 10 million
dollars to stay 48 Hours Canadians
thought our voice needed to be heard and
we needed to be supported
so you were planning to leave in 48
hours because you assumed the government
was going to agree with your demands
we thought we would get a meeting okay
so what changed why didn't you why did
you stay after 48 hours because Justin
Trudeau did exactly what he's done for
the last two years
he literally came out and called us a
whole bunch of names
I'm sorry sir but if I came and called
you a whole bunch of names and said that
your ideals and how you felt didn't mean
anything to anyone
how would you feel
and that you losing your job your income
your way to pay your wife's expenses to
put food on the table for your children
was irrelevant how would you feel
so because of his actions there are
consequences and that meant we stayed
so Ms Belton then if I understand your
answer correctly your plan was to come
for 48 hours assuming the Prime Minister
would respond to your demands but if he
did not you're going to stay until he
did is that right
I didn't say that so what are you saying
I'm saying we were looking for a meeting
and you're going to stay until you got
your meeting
some sort of response would be good so
you're going to stay until you've got
your meeting or a response
um now uh you stayed in a you stayed in
the ark hotel for most of the time most
of the time uh who paid your hotel bills
Joseph bergalt from what I understand
okay and
um the the there was also money raised
in cash you've told us and your
testimony that uh America tell you were
putting together envelopes to hand out
to the truckers because many of them
were staying living in their trucks
right that's where Trekkers live yeah
they're living they were living Ralph
that was very tough uh for them and so
you were putting together envelopes of
two thousand dollars to to assist them
with their with their expenses right
correct now the fuel that they were
getting uh they were getting Jerry cans
of fuel and so forth to keep their
trucks running to keep warm I understand
correct I understand the same well you
were involved in it though right you
were involved in the logistics not
everything not everything but you were
involved in meetings where there's
discussions about how to get the fuel to
those trucks that were still running
yes and I may have been dealing with
something else at the time right and the
uh the fuel that they were getting
um they were getting that for free
because that was being provided by
someone else is that right I don't know
that you weren't involved in those
meetings I don't know who paid for what
okay
okay now the the envelopes that you're
handing out how often did you do that
how many rounds were there of envelopes
being handed out I know of two instances
from the ark Hotel yes and then the
Sheraton Hotel
um they were also handing out envelopes
as your understanding
you'll have to ask them
well you testified I believe that you
understood that the sheratum was handing
out yes that's the end of my
understanding fair enough well just for
your assistance Mr Barber testified
about that and indeed they were handing
out and he was over at the Sheridan
right and uh how would you know or how
did you keep track if truckers were
getting the same we're getting envelopes
from multiple groups we would ask them
okay
just a reminder you're out of time so if
you could try and uh don't I don't have
15 minutes sir sir I had to Note 10
minutes so uh well if I'm a commissioner
to ask for a lead for five extra minutes
I think I was getting some longer
responses than anticipated
um I'll give you a few more minutes but
please get to the point
thank you commissioner I believe I'm
trying to be on point for my clients
thank you um so with respect to honking
uh Miss Belton as a truck driver uh
you're aware air horns and train horns
can be Extremely Loud
yes they have a purpose they're warning
signals yeah their trucks are heavy
they're very they can be dangerous
Vehicles they need very trained people
to drive them and if there's a hazard or
something far away you use those very
loud horns to ensure people absolutely
know that the truck is coming there
might be a risker so we're noticed yes
yeah but the the sound of the horn it
can be dangerously loud if you continue
to hold on it correct so it could be a
racetrack an airport
several other things absolutely I agree
with you now but the horns were used by
the trucks uh as a sort of a symbol of
the protest throughout the time in
Ottawa is that fair
well I noticed on your lawsuit you
didn't list every child that came in
honked a horn
they're also responsible or they're not
so I take that as a yes that you were
aware that horns were used as a protest
tactic
they were no they were used by the
drivers some were having fun I do know
that Chris and the rest of them had
talked we needed to get the horns down
to a minimum we also needed to do some
sleep time because some were somewhere
in the city making louder noises we did
try to assist citizens
it's not that we left you out to dry we
tried to assist citizens well Ms Belton
there was a schedule of horns was there
not there was a time they would start at
7 A.M and go on throughout the day isn't
that right not that I'm aware of
not sure wherever you were downtown you
didn't hear those horns I don't know of
a schedule for the horns okay
um
you say that you tried to control the
horns is that right is that what you're
telling us I said organizers tried to
control the horns I never went out
except for uh once during some speeches
on the hill where there was a a vehicle
that was making excessive noise
actually I think there were maybe two of
them I went up to both and I said look
guys that's enough
um one complied one didn't
uh some of the other organizers though
very much supported uh the the horns at
any time is that right
I would know you'd have to ask the other
organizers well in your discussions like
for example with Pat King Pat King was
very much in support of the horns was he
not in emergency use
an emergency use only
from what I understood his Direction was
if you are in trouble to honk your horn
just final Point Ms Belton uh you've
testified that the the mayor's deal that
we've heard about your understanding at
the time was that that was fake news
that wasn't true there was no deal is
that right that's correct and the people
that you knew uh and you were dealing
with at the ark Hotel
opposed any deal in any event is that
right no I never said that so what are
you so you would have supported a deal
if if there had in fact been a deal to
move the trucks uh to different
locations you would have supported that
kind of a deal absolutely if we could
have lessened the events to the citizens
absolutely we weren't there to disrupt
the citizens we were there to have our
government finally hear us after two
years I did my due diligence sir I wrote
32 letters I went the right way and no
one listened to me so I don't know what
you expect of me
but bringing my truck
well I brought my pickup truck I had to
bring a big truck
did they notice me
did somebody finally try and come and
talk to me
this the answer to that is still no
so what do I need to do to have my
government that is elected to talk to me
to help me solve my problems you had
horn honking
I watched people get thrown to the
thrown to the ground I watched
children's in Parks getting thrown off
their uh off their skateboards by police
officers no one helped those people
matter of fact people were supporting
this kind of behavior this is not the
behavior of a free country
so in your view the people of downtown
Ottawa were unfortunate casualties if
the Prime Minister had listened to you
what happened to them those three weeks
of sleeplessness and so forth that
wouldn't have happened it's the prime
minister's fault I feel for them I
honestly do
but I feel for those truck drivers that
were about to not be able to feed their
families many of those drivers had their
whole families in those vehicles with no
income they lose their home
kids are raised in a truck until school
age we had a one-month-old baby that the
city of Ottawa took fuel from and we had
to find accommodations so it didn't
freeze to death
which is more inconvenient
not having Fuel and watch your your
child freeze to death or listening to a
few horns I'm sorry that your clients
feel that they are entitled to 460
million dollars for horn honking
who was going to replace my income if I
took a vaccine that killed me so my
husband could survive
not any one of your clients I guarantee
you
but you inflicted that on my clients and
your clients
they're well over your time and I think
it's turning into a debate which I don't
think is constructive thank you
commissioner thank you
okay next uh call on the Ottawa Police
Service
questions sir thank you okay the Ontario
Provincial Police
all right
you're still on mute
can you hear me now yes
sorry about this uh I have no questions
for the opp okay thank you uh
Council for uh farmer Chief slowly
foreign
good evening Miss Belton Rebecca Jones
for former Chief slowly
just a few questions for you this
evening
you testified that you thought the group
in Coots had a lot of gumption right
that's not the word I used on my video
but that's the word I can use here okay
to remove them from the border
no that was just in blocking a border
completely just doing that act
um
they were in
all in they were all in right they
maintained their blockade uh despite
attempts to remove them
I'm assuming so I wasn't there okay
um I do have to say the horse thing was
brilliant that was just the
most beautiful scene I'd ever seen
coming across
you also gave evidence that Mr marazzo
tried to put you in a box right
I believe I started that with Tamara and
yeah as well as Mr marazzo okay Ms Leach
and and Mr marazzo and by that you mean
I take it that they attempted to manage
you somehow
manage me distance me
I found my own way and I found where I
served the public better and that's from
the heart and off the sleeves so I I
found my place right okay so can I take
it then that you rejected or resisted
those attempts to manage you and and did
your own thing
yes I'm a truck driver an independent
truck driver and a business owner and
I've been business owner several times
so
yes okay
and so I take it that if Ms Leach or Mr
marazzo told you how you should be
protesting
um you would have resisted that as well
it depends on what their message was if
their message was incorrect you'd be
correct about that right so if they told
you it was time to leave Ottawa and that
in your view was incorrect you would
have resisted that
not likely
okay
um and if they told you that there were
too many horns and asked for your help
to stop the horns I take it your view
would have been it's up to the
individual protesters to determine how
they protest I assisted when asked
when asked and I suggest to you when you
agreed with what you were being asked
you can suggest that but you weren't
there
okay so you just said you disagree with
me you would have gone along with but I
went along with a lot of the things that
made sense right if it didn't make sense
I mean horn honking I can understand why
people want that reduced absolutely
however when the government goes and
says you can't honk your horn but we
want you to leave they obviously didn't
read the schedule one of a truck which
means you have to honk your horn in
order to leave the city so was what was
it did you want us to leave or did you
want us to stay we couldn't complete a
schedule one
okay and just a couple uh more things
we've heard some testimony about the
swarming of police officers did you
witness that I did not witness that okay
and do you have any information I I take
it you didn't witness it
um but do you have any information about
which groups were involved in that I do
not
um you also testified that Pat King was
the lead on media
um in January correct that's what he
agreed to he agreed to put out media for
us uh to put us through to his followers
that would allow us a broader reach
um
just kind of like I don't know when you
do a newspaper adcept it was free so
thank you Pat okay and um did Mr King to
your knowledge did he continue to take a
lead role in the information that was
being disseminated
um into February
I'm not sure I understand your question
okay fair enough
um Mr King took on a media lead role in
January in terms of giving information
to the public or other protesters about
the convoys right right he also had his
own podcast sure and my question was
only did that sort of lead role continue
into February
I know some of the organizers asked him
not to do so much
um I do remember in a one news
conference that Pat and I were in
together that my job was literally to
make sure that Pat didn't ramble uh Pat
likes to go on and my whole job was to
sit there and nudge him if he decided to
ramble
um
final question you referred to bands
that were put on in place on your
Facebook account right over time and was
that on the basis that Facebook said you
were spreading disinformation yes but it
was true information they just didn't
like the truth in Canada
thank you those are my questions you're
welcome
hey thank you uh next is the ccla please
oh good good evening I'm going to be
asking my questions via Zoom can you see
me
I can
perfect uh my name is Eva craevska and
I'm Council to the Canadian civil
liberties Association and I just have a
few questions with respect to the
freezing of your bank accounts I know
you already spoke about this in the
examination conducted by commission
Council
um and I understand from your from that
evidence that you learned from a phone
call you received from RBC that your
bank accounts were frozen on February
17th that's correct but it wasn't from
RBC it was actually from a police
officer
okay I see so the the telephone call
that you received on that day was from a
police officer that your bank accounts
were frozen yes when I called it at a
later date it's a police officer
and do you know whether that police
officer was a police officer of the
Ottawa Police Service the the RCMP or
the opp I believe it was Toronto service
or from the Toronto area
and uh and the police officer told you
that your bank accounts could be
unfrozen once you informed them that you
left Ottawa is that fair that's what he
stated
and did you check at the time that your
bank accounts had in fact been frozen
I was already informed prior to his call
by my husband
so your husband called you to let you
know that he was not able to access your
joint bank accounts
his business account which had my name
on it to pay for expenses
his uh and my joint household expense uh
account as well as my personal bank
accounts uh were all Frozen he informed
me at approximately 8 A.M
uh could be sooner than that and I got
the call at 1004 by the person claiming
to be from the Royal Bank
so they claimed to be from the Royal
Bank but you believe that they were a
police officer is am I getting that
right now I believe they were a police
officer because I called the number
afterwards
a few months later not not directly a
few months later
a few oh so they left they left you they
left you a telephone number to call back
that no I screenshotted the message when
they called I screenshotted their phone
number
and you called them back later and then
how did they identify themselves when
you called back later
I'd have to recall the number would you
like me to try
no I I ca I can't ask you to try that
now I'm just asking how do you know that
when you called back a few months later
that they were a police officer because
they had no connection with the Royal
Bank
when you when you spoke to them a few
months later I did not speak to them I
called them back and got a message
machine it stated their name and no
association with the Royal Bank
so it was not for example of corporate
voicemail where the person would answer
I'm so and so at the Royal Bank of
Canada at this Branch you're correct
okay
and
um you said that your bank accounts were
frozen for for a period of time but you
said you don't recall for how long
because your husband manages the banking
is that fair that's fair yeah he he
dealt more with that I was dealing with
of course other situations other people
not having money
um trying to help truckers get home the
the freezing of the bank accounts
created a larger problem than solving
the problem
okay and in terms of the length of the
problem do you know can you can you
provide your best estimate of whether
your bank accounts were frozen for a
period of days or whether it was a
period of weeks after February 17th
I can't be I can't nail down a time for
that I know it was a very long time that
I did not have access to funds or it
felt that way and do you know that do
you know that because by March 1st you
had a mortgage payment due that you
weren't able to make
that's right a friend went and made that
that mortgage payment for us they went
and deposited the money for us so that
would be correct
okay and so can you just elaborate for
me how on a personal basis the freezing
of the bank accounts affected you with
respect to your your personal bank
accounts other than the payment of your
mortgage other than the hundred dollars
that was gifted to me by another
um participant
I couldn't put fuel in my pickup truck I
lived nine hours for Ottawa
so I couldn't get home
I couldn't pay for my husband's diabetic
medication
we were looking for solutions to that
because the money we had we had to
decide what that was going to pay for
the his the one unfrozen bank account
which wasn't a main bank account that's
not where we put all our expense money
so my expenses are now he's trying to
cover he's trying to cover his expenses
he's trying to cover his business
expenses
he's trying to cover everything out of a
very small account that's just meant for
him to do with you know uh by groceries
or food in the U.S
our lifestyle is a little different and
it's very hard for people to understand
that do not truck there is usually a
joint account to pay things that either
husband or wife can do because we never
know when we'll be home
my estimate time away is approximately
289 days a year equivalent to 4.5 trips
around the Earth in a year
so we need to work together to make sure
bills are paid
so if if I can summarize the your access
to the joint bank account that you have
with your husband
is essential to manage your household
finances because of the time that you
spend away from home that's correct
and the only bank account that you had
access to was the personal bank account
of your husbands that was not frozen I
did not have access to that that is his
personal bank account so he had access
to money on the road I was in Ottawa
nine hours from my home and I had access
to nothing
can you I asked you about your
experience personally with respect to
the freezer well you're well over your
time so you're gonna have to wrap up
please
okay uh yeah so this is my gonna be my
my last question and uh I apologize
commissioner can you just elaborate on
how it affected your business to have
your business account Frozen
how it affected our business
correct we ended up having people
um we actually I believe deferred the
payment a month we had to call and defer
the payment
okay thank you commissioner uh thank you
these are my questions
thank you uh next is the Democracy fund
and jccf
hey Mr commissioner Miss Belton uh my
name is Antoine Dai I'm counsel to
Citizens for Freedom representing the
peaceful demonstrators in Windsor
Ontario I just have a few questions to
clarify some of your earlier testimony
the first Tick Tock video that was
played today the one that you indicated
was broadcasted while you were detained
at secondary at uh at one of the Windsor
borders Crossings was that the
Ambassador Bridge you were being stained
at
yes not Bluewater yes it was uh Windsor
Ambassador Bridge yeah perfect and what
was the approximate date of that video
November
17th uh it's either the 16th or the 17th
that's 20 21 or 2020 2021 2021
yeah
and and you had indicated in your
testimony that you were afraid that you
know Windsor Police would be involved
other policing agencies did other law
enforcement actually have uh become
involved in that interaction with you or
was it just cbsa that day
on that day when I crossed in
I tried to explain to the Windsor border
cbsa agent that I could not wear a mask
that my visor that I usually used had
been broken during the trip
but he would open the window and go put
on a mask and he would slam it
then he would open it up and yell put on
a mask before I could answer again and
slam it
um
he we finally got to the she's not got
one
and
um I tried to explain it was not good
enough
he was on some sort of Power Trip and he
told me to enjoy my time with the
Windsor Police I took that as a threat
to my Safety and Security as a Canadian
entering my country but but when you
entered did you actually have an
interaction with Windsor Police on that
particular day no my interaction first
was with
a cbsa officer that was yelling at me to
get back into my truck
I had waited a long time for them to
come see me so I've I was like have we
gone back to the old rules where you got
to go in so I went to go in and I was
yelled to get back in my truck
I got back in my truck I did as I was
told
um and then I had the officer ask me if
piak had called me
I believe at that point they hadn't the
second time they had piac said they were
waiting on police to arrive to issue a
six thousand dollar fine or of that
nature and just for clarity P Factor
you're talking about the public health
agencies that's what they call them yeah
perfect you also indicated in your
earlier testimony that you had witnessed
a cbsa strike a number of years ago and
that you had been left to sit on the
bridge for over two hours yes sir do you
recall about when that occurred
I actually have it within my files I
believe it was
um
2020
possibly August it's in my files I don't
have it right in front of me okay and
that was the Ambassador Bridge as well
then I was on the Blue Water uh at that
point the cbsa strike was more than one
Bridge
it was unilateral it was all over the
news okay and when you were on the Blue
Water Bridge that day uh your truck was
at a complete standstill on the bridge
as in no traffic was entering Canada
through that Port of Entry because of
the actions of the cbsa officers is that
correct it was entering
almost in Reverse mode it was extremely
slow
I sat on the bridge I looked down and
from my location you can see their
parking lot
in front of their parking lot they had
their picket signs they had uh
approximately three or four agents who
walked pointed at the trucks on the
bridge turned around walked backwards
walked so slow to their Gates I'd never
seen them walk so slow before you'd
think they were on vacation did not
appear that they were concerned and
speeding up the uh the access they did
not care about Canadian truck drivers or
American truck drivers coming in not one
bit my buddy was there for 14 hours a
lot of these drivers especially for
um
the
garbage removal go in and out a couple
of times a day
that could have meant that any one of
those truck drivers didn't have any full
supply of medication on them they didn't
care what happened to those truck
drivers Canadian government didn't care
what happened to those truck drivers
Doug Ford didn't care what happened to
those truck drivers cbsa's top
management didn't care what happened to
us either I understood and and you had
indicated that you had received a report
that one of your colleagues had been
stuck at one of these ports of entries
for 14 hours was that also at the Blue
Water Bridge or was that the Ambassador
Bridge he was also at Blue Water
understood thanks
um turning to the Convoy that sounded
like you led from Sarnia to Ottawa uh
can you remind me again that the precise
date that that you left Sarnia and would
have passed through uh London Ontario
we left on the 27th 27th and for those
less familiar with the structure of the
highways in the area is it accurate that
the 402
merges into the 401 either westbound or
eastbound right outside of London that's
correct
and that that juncture where the 402 and
the 401 connect is about 200 kilometers
away from Windsor Ontario that's correct
were any of the trucks from the Convoy
you were leading from Sarnia directed by
you at that Junction to head towards
Windsor so westbound instead of towards
Ottawa eastbound on January 27th no sir
a subsequent video was showed earlier
today in which I believe is one of your
Tick Tock videos where you're speaking
about being threatened by CBS agents
being extensions of the federal
government you mentioned a group that
was carrying out some threatening
activity and I'm not sure on the
pronunciation but was this antifa is
this the same group that was referenced
earlier today by Mr Charlotte
I don't know what was referenced earlier
today
understood and a final question here is
were you physically present in Windsor
at any point between January 23rd and
February 14th of 2022.
I'm sorry the date again January 23rd
and February 14th of 2022.
I may have been there on the 23rd
I would have to recheck my logs I did
come in late into the Convoy I was
having issues uh with my load
when I had left to Alberta I ended up
being delayed and I did arrive back to
the Convoy late to get started I had
um a gentleman by the name of Carl start
my Sarnia
so I may have been a day late which
meant I would have gone there Park
dropped my trailer and then joined the
Convoy and so on January 27th then when
the Convoy left Sarnia you were not with
the Convoy at that point you joined them
at some point no I was only a day behind
so then on January 27th you started in
Sarnia is that correct absolutely yeah
perfect those are my questions thank you
thank you
thank you next it's uh
is belton's representative so do you
have any questions or has everything
been covered
uh no everything hasn't been covered
okay go ahead okay first off
um the original map
I believe the uh commission number is
brb
five zeros two one seven
this is if it's helpful to cancel would
uh is there a place where you'd like to
start or
there is a there is a dialogue on it
you need to play it
the first one is not available to me
this was the other one that um the
printing came out a little blurry so we
didn't use it uh as much we did put some
notations on it
um but this is can you start it at the
beginning we missed some of it it was
sort of muted okay thank you this is the
secondary map that we had in Ottawa the
first one is not available to me this
was the other one that um the printing
came out a little blurry so we didn't
use it as much we did put some notations
on it
um but this is the map that we had
um in our our boardroom
and uh this is the transportation
Mastermind plan seven or map seven from
uh the city of Ottawa website it was
blown up uh that was uh supplied To Us
by uh Andrew
um peloso so on January 28th the
Southwestern Ontario GTA
um
and uh Niagara region arrived in Ottawa
we were LED down the um
the
Ottawa River Parkway
by the police they told us to take this
route even though it was a non-truck
route
and uh The Carling exit
onto the S onto the Ottawa Parkway was
very difficult for trucks to make
bobtail and with trailers
the police had it barricaded and removed
the barricades in front of me
to allow us to go on to this this Jam
uh we arrived here
and we're brought over by the war museum
the police had a blockade right here
uh and wouldn't not allow trucks to go
up onto Wellington
on January 29th when the Western uh
group came in
led by myself Mike as the second pilot
car and uh Chris Barber as the lead
truck
came up onto the Ottawa Parkway
police then moved their uh barricades
which were barrels they were Barrel
barricades and allowed Chris to bring
his truck up onto Wellington
uh approximately this area right here
uh just before the parliament Hills
he was uh pretty much across from the
parking area because I remember parking
close to there
they did not let the rest of the trucks
come they all remained behind the
barricades that were put there in place
by the city of Ottawa police trucks were
on both sides a lane was open on both
sides they used the center medium for
their uh kitchen
and along the sides of each each roadway
each direction is where the cars and
trucks parked
the full intention with this map was to
make sure that we left Flames open and
emergency routes available for quick
access for police
we knew that there were several
hospitals or care homes in the area that
was very important to us to leave those
open there was Elizabeth Brier center
right up here
and we wanted this route straight here
straight down open as well as through
Dorito and down to the 417 open it was
imperative it was very important for us
to leave access for emergency vehicles
I had a friend who was a resident at uh
Elizabeth Briere so that was very
important to me and being a long-term
resident of the Ottawa area
and a former city of employee uh safety
is definitely top priority for myself
and we worked as a team to make that
happen
so we were aware that there was a lot of
vehicles in the area we were trying to
solve the parking problem and get more
trucks off the street uh making almost
two lanes open some places we succeeded
around the bank Street area lower Bank
Street area we were able to do that so
we were looking for other parking the
problem was getting them in and out
of areas so we knew there was parking
down here we knew there was parking over
here
um but to get big trucks in and out was
an issue and to make sure that the
police didn't block off the access so
trucks could come and go at their will
should they decide that they wanted to
leave
we also had
um
notes on this map you'll see over here
at the side
um
these notes are of leaders
um excuse me and their uh designed roles
the first one we have would be pot
it states right here that we knew right
from the beginning because this map was
done within the first two days
uh of being in Ottawa so approximately
between the uh 29th and the 2nd of
February I would say uh approximately
the first two days we started working on
this to the best of my knowledge this
map was done within the first few days
of us being in Ottawa we were working on
a smaller printed map but Andrew of
course provided these for us which was a
great help
as you can see
uh pot was on here this is not my
writing some of the best of my knowledge
this is Tom marazzo's writing but he
would have to confirm that pot was here
for video information and output of uh
social media that was his primary goal
however pot was very very instrumental
in helping us solve problems with great
suggestions for the truck drivers
as you see Tamara had Tamara leech and
that was Pat king sorry this is Tamara
Leach she has no dedicated spot to her
name however when we were on a zoom call
approximately
between January 12th and January 14th
her role was designated as social media
and fundraising uh crowdfunding
Chris this is Chris Barber PR talking to
the Troops he did a very very good job
at talking to a lot of the truckers and
uh getting his picture taken and being
there for media shoots
these marks represent the amount of
people I was
giving credit to for bringing trucks
here and I have forgotten a lot now that
I look at this map uh there are far more
than eight
um and then we had four more of course
those were the key eight were were uh
the four starters so that would be
myself Chris Barber
Pat King and James bouter that we had
eight more underneath those would be
ones that we had brought into the
organization uh through social media
calls however we touched base the BC
organizer is listed here as Sean this is
not the same writing I'm not sure who
wrote this on the map because the BC
coordinator that I was dealing with was
calling and his last name uh escapes me
at the moment uh we also have it as all
of the West as Chris somebody wrote that
in there West was
um there was a lady by the name of uh
Kathy there was Chris
there was uh James bowder
um I don't know Kathy's other name her
last name uh Southwest they have Ben
that would be myself
uh Ben I don't have his last name he's
80d Trucking we have myself and Tim and
Harold Yonker
uh the GTA was uh David's Steinberg
she has to steamberg
we also have in uh
Ontario we have Mike Benson and Andrew
Dieter
those were also associated with myself
Quebec was Joni
um not sure of her last name I know it
starts with a P the PC coordinator was
Jeanette
um her last name to the best of my
knowledge is piquette I haven't
check my emails to give you that
information uh 100 I I apologize uh New
Brunswick was Pei
Leanne
Indie and Ben I have no idea what these
two indications are on the map at this
point
okay
so I wanted to also have you indicate uh
what um
transpired
to
change the leadership from what you've
described there to what it ended up
being
that would be the direction of Freedom
Corp and Keith Wilson jccf I assume
you have a number of emails with
interactions between various members
with Chad yeah okay can you bring those
up I have no idea what they're entitled
identify the numbers
sir I'm gonna rise at this point all of
this happened after the fact
well after the events in question and
there's actually as I understand also
some potentially privileged records in
here I would like
privilege would mean I would have had to
sign on a privilege excuse me we're just
yeah we I haven't went through me sorry
so sir
um with respect to relevance and
materiality I think that
if you gave a direction that this
witness is limited with respect to
giving evidence regarding the time frame
up to and including say after the EA was
no longer invoked I believe that would
be appropriate sir that that's okay with
us our information is prior to the EA
invocation okay because I I think as is
probably obvious we're dealing with the
Declaration of the emergency act and
that's fine so on there may be things
after okay yeah I'm not talking about
that actually could could you uh give a
timeline where you saw difficulties
begin and then just I have we have the
numbers so when you in indicate what
document we have the numbers
those documents were provided to me
afterwards yes okay but they said they
don't want anything outside
after that time frame
well it's about
it's information about what happened
right but they don't want all the truth
out they only want selected truth though
I know but he didn't confine us to I
think he did again it's turning into
discussion
if it relates to events that occurred
before the
invocation
that's
can be relevant I don't know if it is
but ultimately we're we're concerned
about
the Declaration of the emergency and the
organization of the Convoy and
it's
function or
what happened in Ottawa and if it's
related to that then tell us what it is
and we can then think about whether we
go to the documents but I don't know
what we're talking about so okay it's
documents that were generated in before
the EA
but we can
just talk about uh the meetings what
what what was happening when there was
one of the first meetings that I went
into was with uh Tom quiggins Chris
um tbof uh James peloso
uh don't believe there were any lawyers
present at that time
uh Tom quiggin had come in and looked at
Tamara and said this is all because of
you I asked Chris to deal with that and
to solve that issue so that people
understood that that was not exactly
true her fundraising did amazing she did
a great job
but she did not start the Convoy and
and I didn't want that to go on that uh
fake
kind of presentation I guess I I don't
know
um
I want it to be cleared up it ended up
that Chris asked me to uh not divide not
to create an issue to go along with
things and we repeatedly had those
conversations amongst us Chris and I for
me repeatedly asking him to clear up
this fake narrative that had been
presented
um and that just kept being presented
okay uh also you mentioned you had
mentioned to me a meeting that you went
to in which your character was
um assaulted
that would have been on a zoom call
there after though I was on a zoom call
after the emergency yeah but well after
okay we'll leave that one that's why I
was saying some of that as well some of
it okay so
um
the emails concerning uh the new
leadership like who who became the
leader
or who directed The Convoy
at what point can you pinpoint the the
period of time like roughly not not you
don't have the specific date because
it's a process
but at what at what point did you
recognize that the it had been taken
over
as soon as we got taught while there
were issues and they continued and
started to magnify okay
um at at any point did you feel that you
were specifically uh undermined and
targeted
yeah I it just seemed like uh I provided
the lawyers with a complete list of uh
organizers not one of those names uh
showed up on the freedom Convoy
documents for the NFP
um my name didn't show up on there uh I
understood that the freedom Convoy Corp
uh dealing with the monies that we had
raised as a team and we were to be a
team uh
my name didn't show up I was obviously
being admitted okay uh who did you
um who do you regard
as the
how do you say the new leader like who
was giving direction after you guys were
kind of uh it seemed we took a lot of
direction from Keith Wilson okay do you
have any evidence for that
just in whatever documentation that I've
provided okay so can we be specific I've
got again that would be after the EA I
I've got the titles and then there's
there was a video where he's telling
people to come to Ottawa
I do not know what video that is okay
and there's uh I don't know the number
for the just
I'm looking for it hang on a minute
yeah
maybe you could just it it may be
helpful uh if you try to summarize what
it is that you're trying to give as as
in terms of the
the story and we can leave the documents
they're in they're in uh the record and
if need be we'll turn them up but okay I
I know what it is it's a an interview
uh with the commission and Keith
Williams
I'm sorry Keith Wilson
so it's it's Keith Wilson's uh witness
statement yes what you're referring yes
so uh the the document ID for that would
be WTS uh
58 I'm not sure how many zeros I would
note that that's
sorry WTS six zero is 58 uh it is a uh
interview statement that uh would
require leave
okay
so is that what you want to refer to is
that uh or is there a need for that
is there a need for the document yeah
yes
okay is it this one that we're referring
yes can you indicate the the three
places that we wanted to focus uh
okay if you could turn up the uh the
witness statement let's see where we go
with this yeah we'd like it brought up
and she's going to identify what's that
assistance this is the kind of thing she
needs assistance for
or do you have it you have it okay
so which page are you looking at starts
on page two and on the second paragraph
second paragraph page two yeah yes
paragraph which paragraph Was it for uh
page two uh paragraph two
okay so oh yes okay
that that paragraph
if
do you want me to read it or do you want
to read if you wouldn't mind okay
uh Wilson found the tvof leaders in the
arch hotel and informed them that the
freedom Convoy organizers would be doing
the press conference leech told Wilson
that she was not in a position to
respond to all the questions that may be
posed by the Press Wilson agreed to lead
the press conference he decided the
event needed to be focused uh with a
clear message around this time Wilson
met with Daniel bulford bulford
suggested he speak speak
at the press conference about the
Convoy's work liaisoning with the police
regarding safety and emergency vehicle
access Wilson agreed Beauford should
also speak at the press conference so
we're the the position is that that
statement indicates that he's taking a
leadership role uh with with regard to
the members of the of the freedom Convoy
yes okay well I think the wit it's it
should come from the witness I think so
uh what is what are you trying to why
are you referring to this comment then
well Keith Wilson was writing uh writing
the speeches and directing what we said
uh many times he he came into a
conference room and he goes let's get
the messaging straight and he said what
are we here for
mandates what mandates all mandates this
was the message
that started the Convoy so was he out of
touch with what was going on
did somebody not fill him in this
message was already in place
okay so any anything
there was one document there
um
that he distributed to everyone with
regard to plain people of persons coming
in on plane what's the name of that
document
uh uh I believe he says that in this one
as well
um
I don't think we marked it but he uh did
make statement that he came aboard on a
flight with others that he picked up
along the way
okay what did what did that letter say
it was addressed to to all of the Convoy
organizers was it
I'm not sure what you're referring to
but if you're we're still on this
document the one about the planes no
what what page are you referring to uh
we're trying to go to another doctor I
don't know what where the document is
I'm sorry okay
I'm not sure which one we're referring
to
this is why I had
some help from Rebecca because
everything got jumbled this morning when
it was sent back to us I have no idea
where my documents are at this point
um I find it extremely unfair that this
has happened if they would have left the
uh naming that I had on the documents I
would have been able to pull these up
for you and we could have referenced and
and Rebecca and I or uh Jane and I would
have been able to be more effective up
here okay well maybe somebody can help
her we're able to get the title of the
original document or more information
about it we can try to assist in
identifying it it as I understand it's a
notice that Rebecca has a list of the
documentation if she could come up here
she can show me what it is that we're
we're pulling if that would be all right
with everyone
or if I can see a copy I can I can take
a look
okay yeah we can even
go ahead
okay we've got come on up this let's
just get it done
we're here to move it along
and all the help we can get
I'm sorry that's okay
is that it
did you say no no
okay
is that what you read yeah did you read
it though do you want me to read it
I don't think
so just read what it says
um
Jane it says uh on February 2nd Wilson
traveled to Ottawa on a chartered flight
with Eva uh I'm sorry if Eva I'm sorry
and I'm going to butcher your last name
so I'm just not gonna do it
um Dwayne Leach uh Chad Eros and others
uh Wilson and
Eva boarded the flight in Edmonton and
others were picked up along the way
is that not what you were looking for
you're gonna have to speak on the plane
the one uh the email where we were
instructed not to talk about uh anything
to do with the plane yes that's the one
I'm right I'm sorry I didn't make it
clear that was a signal message yeah do
we have it
I don't know what it's been numbered and
I'm not
okay maybe maybe you can just testify to
that if you remember now which which one
that was yeah the email was to a group
of us
um
in regards to they had found out somehow
about the uh plane and they were curious
whether uh the lawyers and uh Chad and
um Mr
um Leach had come in and followed
mandate requirements
um I didn't think it was a big deal but
we were told we were not allowed to talk
about it
oh who were you told that by uh Keith
Wilson
okay
are there any other
um emails please stay here to help
you yes may I have a chair
thank you very much
okay go ahead I'm sorry
is there anything further you yes okay
I I think we'll leave that
she had some other ones but
there was just one one more item
actually two more items but one the CB
what is it um
see if we okay now I'm frustrated too
cbsa the letter that you wrote to the
cbsa and their response right
um
we don't have it
okay there's the cbsa letter came in
December
um and it basically made no
accommodations for those that couldn't
wear a mask
um those that
they they just wouldn't make
accommodations and I had had uh piac
there at one point in February of uh 20
21.
um and the woman's name was Jessica and
she had given me exemptions
um my company that I was working for at
the time even wrote a letter based on
her name on the um
uh
uh face mask requirements from uh from
piac that they they give you she wrote
her name said that if there was any
problems just to refer to her that never
happened so every time I went through
there was an issue it depended on what
age and I got whether the issue was a
small issue or a massive blown out fight
between cbsa and myself
okay and uh you wrote a letter of
complaint my husband actually took the
initiative uh because I I was
I was done I
I didn't plan on staying
I didn't plan on breathing
I couldn't do it
and and
um
I plan to end my life and give him
everything but
um for some reason I was here to cause a
truckist I guess and um I couldn't do it
as fast as I would like to
my husband went ahead and filed the um
filed the complaint first on my behalf
uh cbsa wouldn't allow it I told them
that I was afraid of repercussion at the
border that this would continue to
strain the relationship between myself
and cbsa
um
and after their letter of basically not
providing accommodation uh following the
rules of Ontario which were if you did
you didn't have to be uh masked if you
actually had a valid medical reason I
think
going back to a terrible time in your
life is a valid medical reason
um
and uh
they minimized the suffering and the
experience with them at cbsa
and I I wrote them back and I said
please don't ask underestimate what
you've done
I had at that point uh started on a
downward spiral of rapid weight loss
um my southbound trips were fine but my
Northbound trips were
um
unable to sleep tossing and turning not
eating losing rapid weight shaking uh
driving up to cbsa it at first it was
just a little bit
then it became more and more strenuous
more more stressful and it just started
compiling it shaking driving from Texas
to
to on Ontario and actually being so
overwrought on the second day that I had
to take a day and I couldn't move I
couldn't get out of bed I had to take a
day
and uh kind of get my stuff together and
continue on so it was a very traumatic
experience although cbsa thinks they
were just doing their job
so after you got the response back from
cbsa uh you wrote
um
to various uh MPS and other officials do
you can you uh State the names of those
individuals and roughly what you were
asking them for or what to do
I was asking for help help
I wanted help I wanted someone to help
me
um some of those messages I believe
start with 9-1-1 help I need help Randy
Hillier Roman baber
um Leanne Rood
um maybe even Monty McNaughton Naughton
I know there were letters to him I went
Federal I went provincial nobody
listened nobody helped
I don't want to listen to your staff
member when I'm having an issue
that is life-changing I want to talk to
you I want to sit down with you whether
it's with a Tim Hortons coffee or a
bottle of water and let's figure out the
problem and find some solutions but
those weren't available
and how many of those emails did you
send approximately 32. okay so I just
have one last statement uh you indicated
to me that your grandfather had given
you an explanation of
the conditions under totalitarianism or
communism uh you you recounted that to
me can you recount it here
uh yeah it was uh November 11th I was 14
and I was visiting
and um
being a
teenager with attitude I sat well the
while the services started in the minute
of Silence
my grandfather grabbed me by the back of
the shirt by the back of the collar
Lifted Me Up and he said you'll stand
here and you'll respect our dad
afterwards
um
after the time had passed on the on the
television I remember we were watching
it on television
um I went to sit back down
and he made me stand for a full minute
after the when we were done I was
ordered to go to the kitchen table
I sat with him
well he explained to me what it was like
to be in Nazi Germany
he told me about the snitch lines that
if you wanted your neighbor's piano
and they weren't going to give it to you
you just called up the Nazi snitch lines
and they would take care of the family
and you would go and get their their
belongings
they talked he talked to me about
children
who would go to school and the teachers
would ask
what did your parents talk about last
night
and they would come home and find their
families murdered because they said bad
things about Hitler
the warning signs were here we had
people snitching on people at Christmas
time enjoying family members because
there were made have been six people in
a in a home that that person doesn't own
and then we watched Quebec police
officers pull people out of those homes
throw them to the ground and arrest them
because they were spending time with
their family
we were headed down the road that my
grandfather talked to talk to me about
I don't want to live that way
I want to live the way we have been in
Canada
I want us to be United again I want us
to look at people and smile as we walk
down the street that works everywhere
but the GTA
um I mean
I want us to get back to where we were
in 2019 that's all I want it's not that
much to ask for we're not that far away
and we need to stop
yelling at people and dividing
and pitting each other against each
other we have a prime minister that was
a former Drama teacher and all he has
done
is has made Canada full of drama
he's very good at what he does
okay so that was uh that's the last
question thank you
I do believe that the Canadian Bill of
Rights will help maintain our freedom
providing that's that's relevant to what
we're doing here but I'll let it go go
but please we've heard your message I
think yes I understand
providing it's uh allowed to be
addressed in courts I do believe that
it's still valid and still exists
okay that's it thank you no question sir
for the freedom Corp
okay I I have just one
little
trying to understand my notes so it it
shouldn't be long
you talked about ADT Canada asking
you you're contacting you about Windsor
and I just I my note is ADT Canada was a
company I just got the ADT phone number
I know Ben was one of the heads uh had
owned the company but the number came
from the company number so I I can't
recall who I was talking to at that time
it very May well have been Ben but I I'm
not sure and and what did they ask you
if if the Windsor border should be
blocked and absolutely not I said and I
thought there was something and I have a
note about Slow Roll yeah continue to
Slow Roll which is what the whole Convoy
was originally built on was that we
would slow roll in a convoy together
across Canada
okay so this call was from ADT Canada
someone and it had to do with
the Ambassador Bridge was it or was it
the Blue Water it was Ambassador it was
masseter and you said Slow Roll so would
this have been before the Ottawa uh the
the 28th or just trying to get the data
no no this would have been before the
Windsor block 80 happened I was asked
should it happen and I said no you said
Slow Roll Slow Roll as had had we been
what happened was a lot of the Convoy
came to Ottawa but in each region there
were people that couldn't make that trip
so they continued supporting us in their
region
and uh I'm just trying to understand
also uh about your pickup truck in
Ottawa you said you turned around when
you got here and went
uh and because you had a pickup truck
you could turn around and go to iron
prior I think it was uh yeah I did go I
went to Ottawa West first uh to a family
member and then I went up to arm prior I
actually have a video on my Tick Tock
where I'm I'm telling Chris to hurry up
uh because I haven't got to meet him yet
um him and Tamara I think I'm saying
hurry up guys
um but in all fairness they didn't know
I was going there to meet them so
um I did I do have a tick tock add-on
that day you have to be fair I have to
be fair I mean I couldn't I couldn't
bust them up for not beating so then you
picked up that Convoy and went into
Ottawa and you described that and so on
did you then stay there that's what I'm
trying to get at her no I wasn't there
for quite a few days I actually came in
and out of the city
um and as long as you know how to sneak
through the city there was no issue I
got in
um I believe it was
honor about the Wednesday before I was
offered a room
um and I I was told by tomrazzo that I
should
um should get a room there because I
needed to be more accessible instead of
coming in and working late going home
well going home going to my family's
home and uh coming back in the morning
so okay and just to close up on this and
when you would come back where would
your pickup truck go would it become
part of the Convoy again either oh no
sir I paid for parking and when I I had
those parking passes if you'd like to
see them and I also have the um a little
pass from The Arc where I parked my my
vehicle I never parked on the street
okay so that's what I was trying to
understand no I'm respectful
I'm not I'm just trying to get the
information I'm uh okay so that ends uh
I think for the day uh and uh it's a
long day today and the good news is
it'll be a long day tomorrow so
um 9 30 please
the commission is adjourned the
commission